THE SENATE WILL COME TO ORDER.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ELLEN AURORA. GILL. ARCHULETA.
ASHBY ATKINS. BECKER. BLAKE.
SPEER. BRADFORD CABALLERO.
CORTEZ. DALLY. DODD. DURAZZO
EGGMAN. GLASER. GONZALEZ. GROVE
HURTADO. JONES. LAIRD. LIMÓN.
MCGUIRE MENGIBAR. MIN. NEWMAN.
NGUYEN NILO. OCHOA. PADILLA.
PORTANTINO. ROTH RUBIO. SATO.
SKINNER. SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS
STERN. UMBERG. WAHAB. WIENER.
WILK MEMBERS. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT. I'D LIKE TO ASK ALL THE
MEMBERS OF THE SENATE AND OUR
GUESTS BEYOND THE RAIL AND IN
THE GALLERY TO PLEASE RISE. WE
WILL BE LED IN PRAYER THIS
AFTERNOON BY OUR CHAPLAIN,
SISTER MICHELLE. AFTER WHICH,
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING FOR THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO THE
FLAG. SISTER MICHELLE. THANK YOU
. SO AS WE GATHER IN GOD'S
PRESENCE, WE PRAY THE PRAYER OF
HOWARD THURMAN TODAY, THE LORD
MY GOD, OPEN UNTO ME LIGHT FOR
MY BLINDNESS, COURAGE FOR MY
FEAR, HOPE FOR MY DESPAIR AND
PEACE FOR MY TURMOIL. OPEN UNTO
ME JOY FOR MY SORROW, STRENGTH
FOR MY WEAKNESS, WISDOM FOR MY
CONFUSION, AND FORGIVENESS FOR
MY SIN. LORD, OPEN UNTO ME
TENDERNESS FOR MY TOUGHNESS.
LOVE FOR MY HATES THYSELF FOR
MYSELF. LORD, LORD, OPEN UNTO
ME. AMEN. PLEASE JOIN ME IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE. I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA FOR
WHICH IT STANDS. ONE NATION
UNDER GOD, INDIVISIBLE, WITH
LIBERTY. US. MEMBERS, I WANTED
TO GIVE YOU AN UPDATE OF OUR
WORK. CHAU MEMBERS, I WANTED TO
GIVE YOU AN UPDATE OF OUR WORK
SO FAR THIS WEEK, AS WELL AS
GIVE YOU A GAME PLAN FOR OUR
WORK THIS AFTERNOON. SO EVERYONE
CAN BE AWARE, FIRST, LET ME
SHARE THE GOOD NEWS THAT WE
HEARD FROM OUR PRO TEM
YESTERDAY. WE HAVE DISPENSED
WITH THE VAST MAJORITY OF BILLS
THAT WERE BEFORE US THIS WEEK.
FOR TODAY, WE DO HAVE A HEALTHY
CONSENT CALENDAR THAT WILL BE
TAKEN UP. WE ONLY HAVE
APPROXIMATELY 19 BILLS ON FILE
TODAY, THAT WE WILL HEAR, BUT
THERE ARE SOME LIMITATIONS TO
THOSE BILLS. MANY OF THOSE BILLS
HAVE ARE ON FILE HAVE TIME
STAMPS, MEANING THAT THE 72
HOURS WON'T BE UP UNTIL A LITTLE
BIT LATER THIS AFTERNOON. SO
WE'LL HAVE A COUPLE STOPS AND
STARTS AS WE WAIT FOR THOSE TIME
STAMPS TO BE IN EFFECT. ALL THAT
BEING SAID, ON BEHALF OF THE
LEADERSHIP, I WANT TO THANK
EVERYONE FOR THEIR HARD WORK. WE
ARE AHEAD OF SCHEDULE, AND
CERTAINLY, THAT WILL CONTINUE AS
WE FINISH OUR BUSINESS TODAY. WE
WANT TO ASK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE AS WE DEAL WITH SOME OF
THE LOGISTICAL ISSUES, AS WELL
AS SOME OF OUR SOUND EFFECTS
FROM NEXT DOOR ON QUÊ. SO AGAIN,
THANK YOU ALL FOR YOUR
COOPERATION TODAY. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO A GREAT SESSION THIS
AFTERNOON. ALL RIGHT. WE WILL
BEGIN WITH PRIVILEGES OF THE
FLOOR. THERE ARE NONE AT THIS
MOMENT. MESSAGES FROM THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY. I
THINK WE MAY BE HEARING THEM.
THEY WILL BE DEEMED READ AS
WELL. REPORTS OF COMMITTEE WILL
BE DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
NEXT TO MOTIONS, RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES. SENATOR MINH, I SEE
YOUR MICROPHONE UP, I REQUEST
THAT FILE ITEM EIGHT, SB 1126 BE
MOVED TO THE INACTIVE FILE. THE
DESK WILL NOTE ANYTHING ELSE
UNDER MOTIONS, RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES. SEEING NO MICROPHONES
UP, WE WILL MOVE NEXT TO
CONSIDERATION OF THE DAILY FILE.
WE WILL BEGIN WITH THE SENATE.
THIRD READING. AND LET ME GIVE
YOU A PREVIEW ON THE MEASURES
THAT WE'LL BE TAKING UP FIRST.
SO MEMBERS CAN BE PREPARED.
WE'LL BEGIN WITH FILE ITEM 18.
19. EXCUSE ME. WE'RE GOING TO
BEGIN WITH FILE ITEM 19 AND THEN
HEAD BACK TO FILE ITEM 18,
FOLLOWED BY A FILE ITEM 21 AND
22. SO WE'LL BEGIN WITH FILE
ITEM 19. THIS IS SENATE BILL
1323 BY SENATOR MENGIBAR.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ SENATE
BILL 1323 BY SENATOR MENGIBAR.
AN ACT RELATING TO CRIMINAL
PROCEDURE. SENATOR MENGIBAR, THE
FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. COLLEAGUES KICKING US
OFF TODAY WITH SB 1323. IN
CALIFORNIA, THERE IS A MONTHLY
STATEWIDE WAIT LIST THAT
AVERAGES BETWEEN 200 AND 300
INDIVIDUALS ALLEGED TO HAVE
COMMITTED FELONIES, WHOM THE
COURTS HAVE DEEMED MENTALLY
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL.
THESE INDIVIDUALS ARE WAITING
FOR A BED TO BECOME AVAILABLE IN
A STATE HOSPITAL SO THEY CAN
UNDERGO EVALUATION AND A PROCESS
TO RESTORE THEM TO COMPETENCY.
THIS BODY, THROUGH THE
LEGISLATION RAN BY THE SENATOR
FROM LOS ANGELES, HAS VOTED TO
ADDRESS THIS BACKLOG. BACKLOG.
WHEN IT COMES TO MISDEMEANORS,
SB 1323 NOW ALIGNS WITH THE
RECOMMENDATIONS OF EXPERTS AT
THE COUNCIL OF STATE GOVERNMENTS
JUSTICE CENTER AND THE COMMITTEE
ON REVISION OF THE PENAL CODE TO
IMPROVE STATE COMPETENCY TO
STAND TRIAL PROCEDURES FOR THOSE
CHARGED WITH NONVIOLENT FELONIES
. IF A PERSON IS FOUND
INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL, THE
CRIMINAL CASE REMAINS ON HOLD
WHILE THE PERSON PARTICIPATES IN
COMPETENCY RESTORATION, WHERE
THE GOAL IS TO PREPARE A PERSON
TO PARTICIPATE IN AND UNDERSTAND
THE COURTROOM PROCEDURES, NOT TO
PROVIDE LASTING THERAPEUTIC
TREATMENT FOR THOSE WHO ARE
RESTORED TO COMPETENCY. VERY FEW
ARE ACTUALLY CONVICTED OF FELONY
OFFENSES AND SENTENCED TO STATE
PRISON. THAT'S BECAUSE FOR LOW
LEVEL, NONVIOLENT FELONIES, THE
AMOUNT OF TIME NEEDED TO GO
THROUGH THE RESTORATION PROCESS
IS EQUAL TO THE AMOUNT OF TIME
THEY WOULD BE INCARCERATED IF
CONVICTED. SO BY THE TIME THE
RESTORATION PROCESS IS DONE,
THESE INDIVIDUALS ARE QUICKLY
RELEASED TO THE STREETS WITH NO
LONG TERM TREATMENT. UNDER
CURRENT LAW, JUDGES HAVE NO
CHOICE. ALL INDIVIDUALS ACCUSED
OF A NONVIOLENT FELONY WHO ARE
FOUND INCOMPETENT TO STAND TRIAL
MUST BE SENT FOR COMPETENCY
RESTORATION. THESE INDIVIDUALS
ARE FUNNELED THROUGH OUR STATE'S
MOST RESTRICTIVE AND COSTLY
STATE HOSPITAL BEDS AT TIMES
WAITING. LIKE I MENTIONED
EARLIER, MANY MONTHS IN JAIL
PRIOR TO PLACEMENT AT A STATE
HOSPITAL. THAT IS WHY SB 1323
WILL REQUIRE MENTAL HEALTH
EXPERTS TO DETERMINE AT THE
BEGINNING OF THE PROCESS IF A
PERSON IS LIKELY TO BE RESTORED
TO COMPETENCY. IN RARE CASES
WHERE EVERYONE AGREES AT THE
OUTSET THAT A PERSON IS NOT
LIKELY TO BE RESTORED, A JUDGE
WILL HAVE THE DISCRETION TO
PLACE THAT PERSON IN OTHER
OPTIONS LIKE CONSERVATORSHIP,
SPECIALIZED PLACEMENT, INSTEAD
OF WASTING RESOURCES ON A
PROCESS THAT WILL NOT WORK. TWO
IT WILL ASK JUDGES TO DETERMINE
IF SENDING THE PERSON FOR
RESTORATION OF COMPETENCY IS IN
THE INTEREST OF THE JUSTICE
INTEREST OF IN THE INTERESTS OF
JUSTICE. IF IT IS NOT, JUDGES
WILL HAVE DISCRETION TO PURSUE
THESE OPTIONS INSTEAD. LIKE I
MENTIONED BEFORE, ANOTHER OPTION
WOULD BE TO GO THROUGH CARE
COURT. FINALLY, IT'S GOING TO
ALLOW JUDGES TO REINSTATE
COMPETENCY PROCEDURES
PROCEEDINGS IF THE PERSON DOES
NOT SUCCEED OR CANNOT BE PLACED
IN ANOTHER TREATMENT.
RESPECTFULLY ASKING FOR AN I
VOTE. SENATOR MENGIBAR HAS
OPENED THE DEBATE. ANY MEMBER
WANT TO BE HEARD ON THIS
MEASURE? ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING NONE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALAN Ó
RODRIGO ARCHULETA. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLI. NO DODD. BARRASSO AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE NO OR DATO.
JONES. NO. LAIRD AYE. LIMÓN AYE.
MCGUIRE AYE. MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN
AYE. NEUMAN. NGUYEN NO. NILO NO.
OCHOA. BOGUE. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH RUBIO. AYE.
SATO NO. SKINNER A SMALL. CUEVAS
AYE. STERN. AYE. UMMER AYE.
WAHAB AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK. NO
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS.
ALAN. ALVARADO. GILMAN NO.
ARCHULETA DODD. NO. DODD Ó.
NEWMAN MIN. IDA. NO OKOBO. ROTH.
ON A VOTE OF 24 TO 10, THE
MEASURE PASSES. MEMBER. WE DO
HAVE A SENATOR NOT PRESENT. SO
WE'RE GOING TO SKIP A FILE ITEM
18 AND MOVE TO FILE ITEM 21.
EXCUSE ME. THIS IS SENATE BILL
1413 BY SENATOR NILO. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL 1413 BY
SENATOR NILO. AN ACT RELATING TO
COMPUTATION OF TIME. SENATOR
NILA, THE FLOOR IS YOURS. PLEASE
GIVE HIM YOUR ATTENTION. MEMBERS
THANK THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
I AM PRESENTING SB 1413, WHICH
RELATES TO PERMANENT STANDARD
TIME. THIS IS A POLICY THAT SOME
MIGHT SAY IS AS OLD AS TIME
ITSELF. NOW SURVEYS SHOW THAT
ALMOST EVERY BODY WANTS TO DITCH
THE SWITCH THAT IS, PEOPLE ARE
GENERALLY TIRED OF GOING BACK
AND FORTH EVERY SIX MONTHS. THE
QUESTION IS TO WHICH SWITCH TO
DITCH? AND THAT'S WHERE THE
CONTROVERSY BECOMES RAIMES AND
CALIFORNIA'S ONLY OPTION THÀNH
ABSENT AN ACT OF CONGRESS QUITE
LITERALLY, IS PERMANENT STANDARD
TIME, WHICH I ORIGINALLY
PROPOSED IN THIS LEGISLATION, IS
OVERWHELMINGLY SUPPORTED BY THE
HEALTH COMMUNITY AND SLEEP
EXPERTS. BUT AS I SAID, THERE IS
SOME CONTROVERSY. THERE ARE A
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WHO PREFER
DAYLIGHT SAVINGS, BUT WE CAN'T
DO THAT UNTIL CONGRESS ACTS ON
THAT ISSUE. BUT I'M SAVING YOU
FROM THAT DECISION TODAY. THE
BILL IS JUST A STUDY BILL. IT
WAS AMENDED IN APPROPRIATION TO
HAVE THE CEC DO A STUDY TO
ASSESS THE NEAR TERM AND LONG
TERM IMPACTS OF OBSERVING YEAR
ROUND STANDARD TIME ON AN ENERGY
DEMAND AND SUPPLY BASIS, THE
OVERWHELMING REASON FOR IT
REALLY IS HEALTH REASONS, BUT
THAT IS THE STUDY THAT WE HAVE.
SO TODAY'S PROPOSAL IS JUST TO
AUTHORIZE A STUDY TO HELP US
MAKE A MORE INFORMED DECISION IN
THE FUTURE. I ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR NILO.
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
MEASURE, ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE. SEEING NO MICROPHONES
UP. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ELLEN. AYE. RODA-GIL AYE.
ARCHULETA. ASHBY AYE. ATKINS.
AYE. BECKER BLAKESBERG.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO AYE.
CORTEZ. DALLI AYE. DODD. AYE.
DURAZZO AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER. AYE GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE
AYE. HURTADO AYE. JONES AYE.
LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN AYE MCGUIRE.
AYE. MENGIBAR. AYE. MIN AYE.
NEWMAN. NGUYEN NILO. AYE. OKOBO
AYE. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO AYE. SATO.
SKINNER A SMALL. CUEVAS AYE.
STERN AYE. UMBERG WAHAB. UMBERG.
AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER AYE. WILK
PLEASE CALL. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN. ARCHULETA
BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER CORTEZ
. AYE NEWMAN. NGUYEN SATO. WILK
AYE. CALL THE SECRETARY. PLEASE.
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS ONE LAST
TIME. ALLEN ARCHULETA. BLAKE.
SPEER NEWMAN. NGUYEN SATO.
RUBIO. AYE. AYE. A VOTE OF 33 TO
1. THE MEASURE PASSES. ALL
RIGHT, MEMBERS, SINCE WE HAVE
EVERYBODY HERE, WE'RE GOING TO
DEVIATE FROM OUR AGENDA AGAIN. I
KNOW I'M KEEPING YOUR ATTENTION
SPAN UP, WITHOUT OBJECTION,
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE UP THE TWO
SPECIAL CONSENT CALENDARS. I'D
LIKE TO ASK IF THERE'S ANY
MEMBER THAT WOULD LIKE TO REMOVE
AN ITEM TO PLEASE. SO INDICATE.
IS THERE ANY MEMBER WANT TO
REMOVE ANYTHING FROM THE CONSENT
CALENDARS? ALL RIGHT. SEEING
NONE. THE SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ALL THE ITEMS ON BOTH OF THE
SPECIAL CONSENT CALENDARS.
SENATE BILL 892 893 906 916 NINE
2939 946 958, 969, 974, 995,
NINE, 97, 1002, 1004, 1015,
1019, 1043, 1073, 1088, 1108,
1111, 11, 13, 11, 2011, 38.
1151, 1152 1159 1161 1166, 1187,
1192, 1197, 1200, 1207, 1217,
1231, 1234, 1244, 1246, 1248,
1258, 1315, 1332, 1333, 1341,
1382, 1384, 1387, 1390, 1391,
1397 14, 19, 1443, 1452, 1454,
1456, 1465, 1487, 1499, 1511.
SIMILARLY, CONCURRENT RESOLUTION
118, ACR 173 176, 178, 129, 133,
167 184. SENATE BILL 896 899
914. 185. ALL RIGHT. THE CONSENT
CALENDAR HAS BEEN READ. THE
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
THIS IS ON BOTH CONSENT
CALENDARS. ELLEN, I'LL RODA-GIL
I ARCHULETA. ASHBY I ATKINS, I
BECKER I BLAKE SPEER I BRADFORD
I CABALLERO I CORTEZ I DALLY I
DODD I OSO I EGGMAN I GLASER I
GONZALEZ I GROVE I HURTADO I
JONES I LAIRD I LIMÓN I MCGUIRE
I MENGIBAR I MIN I NEWMAN NGUYEN
I NILO. I OCHOA I PADILLA I
PORTANTINO I ROTH I RUBIO I SATO
I SKINNER I SMALL CUEVAS I STERN
I UMBERG I WAHAB I WIENER I WILK
I. ALL RIGHT. THAT'S ON A VOTE
OF 37 TO 0. THE CONSENT CALENDAR
NUMBER 34 PASSES AND ON THE SAME
VOTE 37 TO 0. CONSENT CALENDAR
NUMBER 35 PASSES.
MEMBERS. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE
BACK NOW TO FILE ITEM 18. THIS
IS SENATE BILL 40 TÍNH 11 BY
SENATOR OCHOA BOGUE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL 1411 BY
SENATOR BOGUE. AN ACT RELATING
TO CURRICULUM. SENATOR OCHOA
BOGH. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS, I'M PROUD TO PRESENT SB
1411, WHICH WILL APPOINT TWO
SUBJECT MATTER EXPERTS FROM EACH
OF CALIFORNIA'S PUBLIC HIGHER
EDUCATION SYSTEMS TO SERVE ON ON
THE INSTRUCTIONAL QUALITY
COMMISSION DURING THE LAST
REVISION OF CALIFORNIA'S MATH
CURRICULUM FRAMEWORK FROM 2020
TO 2023, MANY PROFESSORS AND
EXPERTS EXPRESSED CONCERNS ABOUT
THE DETRIMENTAL IMPACTS OF
FRAMEWORKS GUIDANCE COULD HAVE
ON STUDENTS WHO WOULD WANT TO
ATTEND COLLEGE. THE UCS BOARD OF
ADMISSIONS AND RELATIONS WITH
SCHOOLS AREA C WORKGROUP
RELEASED A REPORT IN FEBRUARY
DETAILING HOW SPECIFIC COURSES
EMPHASIZED BY THE NEW
MATHEMATICS FRAMEWORK DO NOT,
QUOTE UNQUOTE, EVEN COME CLOSE
TO MEETING THE REQUIRED
STANDARDS TO BE A MORE, QUOTE,
MORE ADVANCED COURSE. THEY
DETERMINED THESE COURSES WOULD
NOT BE ACCEPTABLE MATH COURSES
FOR PURPOSES OF èC ADMISSIONS
BEGINNING IN 2025 AND 26. AS A
RESULT, HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS WHO
ARE CURRENTLY ENROLLED IN
COURSES APPROVED BY THE NEW
MATHEMATICS FRAMEWORK WON'T BE
ABLE TO COUNT THEM TOWARD THEIR
ADMISSION TO COLLEGE. THESE SIX
HIGHER EDUCATIONAL PROFESSIONALS
WILL IMPROVE COMMITTEE DIVERSITY
AND PROVIDE INSIGHT TO MEMBERS
REGARDING K-12 CURRICULUM AND
COURSE CONTENT REQUIREMENT S
THAT ARE NECESSARY TO BETTER
PREPARE STUDENTS FOR THE RIGORS
OF COLLEGE COURSEWORK. I WOULD
LIKE TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
SAN FRANCISCO FOR WORKING WITH
ME ON THIS IMPORTANT POLICY AND
GIVE MY GIVE YOU MY COMMITMENT.
I'M NOT SURE WHERE HE WENT. OH,
THERE HE IS. MY COMMITMENT TO
CONTINUE FINE TUNING THE BILL AS
IT MOVES THROUGH THE ASSEMBLY. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. MEMBERS. IS THERE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
MEASURE? ANY DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE? IT IS ELIGIBLE FOR A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING NO
OBJECTIONS. AYES 37. NO ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES. WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM 22.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 987 BY
SENATOR MENGIBAR. SECRETARY
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL 987 BY
SENATOR MENGIBAR. AN ACT
RELATING TO PRETRIAL RELEASE.
SENATOR MENGIBAR, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
SB 987 WOULD EXPAND THE
DEFINITION OF CRIMINAL JUSTICE
AGENCIES TO INCLUDE PRETRIAL
RELEASE DEPARTMENTS AFTER RECENT
APPROPRIATION, AFTER RECENT
AMENDMENTS OUT OF APPROPRIATION.
THIS BILL ONLY APPLIES TO THE
COUNTIES OF LOS ANGELES, SANTA
CLARA, SAN FRANCISCO. WE TOOK
ADDITIONAL AMENDMENTS TO CLARIFY
THAT PROBATION WOULD WOULD NOT
BE PRECLUDED FROM WORK IN
PRETRIAL SERVICES, RESPECTFULLY
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE. MEMBERS,
ANY DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE,
ANY DISCUSSION ON IT, IS
ELIGIBLE FOR A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL. SEEING NO OBJECTION.
EXCUSE ME. THERE IS AN
OBJECTION. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALAN ALVARADO
GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS. AYE. BECKER BLAKE. SPEER
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO CORTEZ.
AYE. DALLY AYE. DODD AYE. OSO
EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER. AYE.
GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE. AYE. OTERO
JONES. AYE. LAIRD. AYE. LEMON.
LEMON. AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR AYE. MIN NEWMAN. NGUYEN
AYE. NILO OKOBO. PADILLA. AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SATO. AYE. SKINNER AYE.
SMILED. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN
UMBERG. AYE WAHAB. AYE. WIENER.
AYE. WILK AYE. STERN. AYE PLEASE
CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN.
ARCHULETA BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER. AYE CABALLERO. AYE DORADO
. HURTADO AYE. MIN NEWMAN. NILO
AYE. AYE. EYES 35. NO ZERO. THE
MEASURE PASSES. NOW, MEMBERS,
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE BACK INTO
FILE TO FILE ITEM 13. SENATOR
GLAZER, HE'S PREPARED.
SECRETARY, YOU MAY READ. SENATE
BILL 1181 BY SENATOR GLAZER. AN
ACT RELATING TO THE POLITICAL
REFORM ACT OF 1974. SENATOR
GLAZER, THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. THIS BILL WOULD
REQUIRE THAT ANY PARTY INVOLVED
IN A PROCEEDING BEFORE AN
AGENCY, PARTICULARLY RELATED TO
CONTRACTS, LICENSES AND PERMITS
TO DISCLOSE THEIR CAMPAIGN
CONTRIBUTIONS EXCEEDING $250 TO
THE AGENCY BEFORE THE FINAL
DECISION IS MADE IN THE
PROCEEDING, REQUIRING SUCH
NOTICE WOULD FURTHER FACILITATE
PROPER CONFORMANCE WITH OUR
CONFLICT OF INTEREST LAW. I'D
LIKE TO MENTION THAT THIS
MEASURE HAS PLACEHOLDER LANGUAGE
IN IT TO ALLOW FOR FURTHER
DISCUSSION ON THE LEVINE ACT
RELATING TO CONFLICT OF
INTEREST. AND WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE, ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE? HEARING.
SEEING NONE MEMBERS IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. IS
THERE ANY OBJECTION TO USING A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL? ARE WE? ICE
37.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
ON FALL ITEM 13. ALAN ALVARADO.
GILL. AYE. ARCHULETA ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE.
SPEER AYE. BRADFORD. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLI AYE. DODD. AYE. DURAZZO
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. AYE
HURTADO. JONES. AYE. LAIRD AYE.
LIMÓN AYE. MCGUIRE AYE. MENGIBAR
AYE. MIN AYE. NEWMAN. NGUYEN
AYE. NILO OKOBO AYE. PADILLA
AYE. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE.
RUBIO AYE. SATO AYE. SKINNER
SMALL. CUEVAS STERN. AYE. UMBERG
WAHAB. AYE. WIENER. AYE WILK.
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN. ARCHULETA
HURTADO. AYE NEWMAN. SKINNER
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. UMBERG WILK.
AYE. LET'S CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ONE LAST TIME. ALLEN.
ARCHULETA NEWMAN. SKINNER
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE. UMBERG
AYE. LET'S CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS. ONE FINAL. LAST TIME.
ALLEN. ARCHULETA NEWMAN.
SKINNER. AYE AGE 37. NOES ZERO.
SO THE MEASURE PASSES. NOW.
MEMBERS WE'RE MOVING TO FILE
ITEM 28 AGAIN. SENATOR NEWMAN
GLAZIER. I'M SORRY. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL 1494 BY
SENATOR GLAZER. AN ACT RELATING
TO LOCAL GOVERNMENT. SENATOR
GLAZER THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
COLLEAGUES, THIS IS NOT THE
FIRST TIME MANY OF YOU HAVE
HEARD A BILL LIKE THIS. IN FACT,
I WAS TALKING WITH MY STAFF AT
THE BEGINNING OF THE YEAR AS TO
WHETHER I SHOULD TRY THIS BILL
AGAIN. AND IT WAS QUITE A
SPIRITED CONVERSATION, AND I
THINK YOU'LL UNDERSTAND WHY,
WHEN THIS DEBATE IS DONE TODAY.
BUT THE GOAL OF THIS BILL AND
I'LL EXPLAIN IT IN A MOMENT. BUT
THE GOAL IS TO HAVE AN HONEST
AND FAIR TAX SYSTEM. NOBODY
LIKES TO PAY TAXES. BUT IF
YOU'RE GOING TO HAVE TO PAY
TAXES, YOU WANT TO HOPE THAT
IT'S A FAIR SYSTEM, RIGHT? AND
YOU'RE TREATED FAIRLY AND THE
REST. BUT UNDER OUR TAX SYSTEM
TODAY, IF YOU BUY SOMETHING FROM
THE CORNER STORE OR THE MALL,
IT'S VERY CLEAR THAT THE TAX
MONEY THAT'S COLLECTED AND THIS
MEASURE DOESN'T CHANGE WHETHER
YOUR TAXES GO UP OR DOWN, THIS
HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH IT. BUT
WHEN YOU HAVE TO PAY THAT TAX,
WHEN YOU BUY IT AT THE LOCAL
STORE, YOU KNOW WHERE THAT MONEY
IS GOING. IT'S GOING TO THE
JURISDICTION IN WHICH YOU MADE
THAT PURCHASE AND THAT THAT TAX
MONEY GOES TO SUPPORT THE ROADS.
IT SUPPORTS YOUR PUBLIC SAFETY
AND ALL THE REST. RIGHT. BUT BUT
WITH THE ADVENT OF ONLINE SALES,
NOW THE RULES CHANGE. AND HOW DO
THEY CHANGE THE TAX RULES IN
PLACE TODAY WHICH THIS BILL
SEEKS TO CHANGE. BUT THE TAX
RULES IN PLACE TODAY IS THAT
WHERE YOUR TAX MONEY GOES NOW,
WHEN YOU BUY SOMETHING ON THE
INTERNET IS NOT DETERMINED BY
WHERE YOU LIVE, WHERE THAT
DELIVERY TRUCK DELIVERS YOUR
PACKAGE. IT'S A DESIGNATION THAT
THE COMPANIES THEMSELVES GET TO
DECIDE A DESIGNATION OF WHERE
THE WAREHOUSE IS OR THE
DISTRIBUTION CENTER OR, OR THE
SALES OFFICE. WE REFER TO IT AS
A POINT OF SALE DESIGNATION. SO
THAT'S THE THAT'S THE DEAL. SO
IF YOU BUY IF YOU BUY AN APPLE
COMPUTER FROM YOUR HOME TODAY,
YOU THINK YOU'RE SUPPORTING YOUR
LOCAL JURISDICTION, YOUR CITY
FROM WHERE YOU LIVE. BUT THAT'S
NOT THE CASE. AND I'LL EXPLAIN.
AS I EXPLAINED, APPLE GETS TO
MAKE A CHOICE AS TO WHERE THAT
TAX MONEY GOES. AND SO WHAT WHAT
HAS HAPPENED IS, IS THAT THESE
COMPANIES HAVE BAITED CITIES
AROUND OUR STATE TO ENCOURAGE
THEM TO BE THAT POINT OF SALE
FOR THAT TRANSACTION. AND HOW
HAVE THEY EVADED THE CITIES?
THEY SAID, LISTEN, IF WE MAKE
YOUR CITY THE POINT OF SALE,
YOU'RE GOING TO GET ALL THE TAX
MONEY FROM ANY INTERNET SALE
ANYWHERE IN CALIFORNIA. WOULD
YOU LIKE THAT? AND I'M SURE THE
CITY MANAGER AND THE MAYOR AND
THE COUNCIL SAYS, YEAH, WE LOVE
THAT IDEA. YOU SHOULD DESIGNATE
US. AND THEN THERE'S A LITTLE
BIT OF A YEAH, BUT HERE'S THE
DEAL. IF I DO THAT COMPANY A, I
WANT YOU TO GIVE ME HALF THE
MONEY BACK. HOW ABOUT THAT?
YOU'RE GOING TO GET HALF OF IT,
AND I WANT YOU TO GIVE HALF OF
IT BACK TO ME. AND A CITY SAYS,
WELL, THAT THAT STILL SOUNDS
LIKE A PRETTY GOOD DEAL FOR US,
BECAUSE WE WERE ONLY GOING TO
GET A LITTLE INCREMENT OF THAT
TAX MONEY BEFORE, AND NOW WE'RE
GOING TO GET ALMOST ALL OF IT.
YET WE'RE GOING TO GIVE YOU HALF
BACK. OKAY. SO THAT'S WHAT'S
HAPPENED. NOW THIS THAT'S WHAT'S
HAPPENED TO OUR TAX CODE. NOW
WHEN YOU BUY SOMETHING ON THE
INTERNET. SO TO ADDRESS THIS
PROBLEM SB 1494 WOULD DO THREE
THINGS. FIRST, IT WOULD PROHIBIT
A LOCAL AGENCY FROM ENTERING
INTO RENEWING OR EXTENDING A TAX
REBATE AGREEMENT. YOU JUST CAN'T
DO ANY NEW ONES. SECONDLY, IT
WOULD GIVE CITIES UNTIL 2030 TO
PHASE OUT EXISTING AGREEMENTS.
SO IT GIVES THEM SIX YEARS TO
ADJUST FROM THAT GOLD MINE THAT
SUDDENLY REAPPEARED IN THEIR
TOWN TO GO AWAY AND TO ADJUST
FOR THAT. AND THIRD, IT REQUIRES
CITIES TO POST EXISTING
AGREEMENTS ON THEIR WEBSITE
UNTIL THEY EXPIRE. NOW, WE KNOW
THAT THESE REVENUE SHARING
AGREEMENTS ARE CREATE A PERVERSE
ECONOMIC INCENTIVE AND ARE A BIG
PROBLEM. BOTH OUR STATE AUDITOR
WHO WORKS FOR US, AND THE
LEGISLATIVE ANALYSTS HAVE ISSUED
REPORTS SHOWING THAT THE USE OF
THESE AGREEMENTS DO NOT RESULT
IN A NET BENEFIT TO THE BROADER
ECONOMIC REGION WITHIN OUR
STATE. IT SIMPLY SHIFTS EXISTING
SALES TAX DOLLARS FROM ONE
JURISDICTION TO ANOTHER. BUT
THERE'S AND THERE'S A COST TO
THAT. A STUDY WAS DONE TO
UNDERSTAND WHO WERE THE WINNERS
AND LOSERS UNDER THESE
AGREEMENTS THAT EXIST TODAY. IT
WAS DONE BY THE CALIFORNIA
DEPARTMENT OF TAX AND FEE
ADMINISTRATION, AND THEY ISSUED
A REPORT THAT IDENTIFIED THE
WINNERS AND THE LOSERS UNDER
THIS TAX SCHEME. THAT'S IN LAW
TODAY. AND WHAT THEY FOUND IS
THAT 7% OF THE CITIES IN
CALIFORNIA ARE WINNERS. GOOD FOR
THEM. AND WE MAY HEAR FROM SOME
OF THEIR REPRESENTATIVES HERE
THIS AFTERNOON. BUT 90, 93% OF
THE CITIES ARE LOSERS. IS THAT
TAX MONEY THAT WOULD HAVE GONE
TO THEM ARE NOW GOING TO THAT 7%
OF THE CITIES. AND SO WHEN YOU
WANT TO KNOW WHO ARE THE WINNERS
AND LOSERS, YOU MAY GET A SENSE
OF THAT A LITTLE BIT TODAY. BUT
I CAN TELL YOU THAT IF YOU LIVE
IN CITIES LIKE LOS ANGELES,
YOU'RE A LOSER. SAN FRANCISCO,
OAKLAND, YOU'RE A LOSER, SAN
DIEGO, YOU'RE A LOSER. AND 93%
OF THE CITIES IN OUR STATE UNDER
THIS LAW TODAY ARE LOSERS. AND
WE'VE ALSO LEARNED THAT THE
CITIES THAT DO BENEFIT FROM
THESE AGREEMENTS, THEY DO SO AT
THE EXPENSE OF THE CITIES RIGHT
AROUND THEM. SO THE CITY Ã AND
I WON'T NAME NAMES, ALTHOUGH I
COULD YOU MAY SAY THIS IS GOOD.
I REPRESENT THE CITY AND THEY'RE
GOING TO GAIN. WE'LL JUST LOOK A
FEW BLOCKS A FEW MILES AWAY, AND
YOU'RE GOING TO FIND A CITY THAT
LOSES. AND FOLKS, WHEN WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT HOW MUCH YOU'RE
LOSING OF TAX DOLLARS, LET ME
TELL YOU, IT'S OVER $1 BILLION
ARE GIVEN BACK TO THESE
COMPANIES, $1 BILLION THAT WOULD
GO TO PUBLIC SERVICES IN ALL OF
OUR JURISDICTIONS. WE'RE GIVING
BACK TO THESE COMPANIES IN THAT
IN THAT REBATE SCHEME THAT I
THAT I TALKED ABOUT AND YOU SAY,
WELL, WHO ARE THESE COMPANIES?
THEY ARE THE BIGGEST AND RICHEST
COMPANIES IN THE WORLD. WE'RE
TALKING APPLE, NIKE, WALMART,
BEST BUY, AMAZON. IT'S A QUITE A
LARGE LIST, WHO HAVE THE
SOPHISTICATED TAX ACCOUNTANTS TO
KNOW THAT THEY CAN BAIT THESE
CITIES TO MAKE THESE SCHEMES, TO
MAKE THESE DEALS AND TO TAKE
MONEY FROM 93% OF OUR OTHER
CITIES TO GET TO THE BENEFIT OF
THOSE 7. AND THAT'S WHAT THIS
MEASURE DOES BEFORE YOU TODAY.
IT SAYS, NO MORE SCHEMES, NO
MORE ROBBING THE PUBLIC PURSE.
WE WANT TO HAVE FAIRNESS IN OUR
TAX CODE. WE WANT TO HAVE
HONESTY. SO IF WE HAVE TO PAY
TAXES, IT'S GOING TO BE TREATED.
WE'RE ALL GOING TO BE TREATED
FAIRLY. THIS ENDS THOSE SCHEMES
AND WITH THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE TODAY. THANK
YOU. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
DEBATE ON THIS ITEM. SENATOR
SKINNER? THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL AS THE
PERSON WHO CARRIED THE BILL THAT
WAS SUCCESSFULLY SIGNED INTO LAW
THAT REQUIRED OUR INTERNET
COMPANIES TO COLLECT SALES TAX.
AND THIS WAS BACK IN 20. SEE, IT
WAS SIGNED IN, 11, I BELIEVE,
2011, UP UNTIL THAT POINT, IT.
EVERYBODY THOUGHT THEY WERE JUST
GETTING SOME DISCOUNT WHEN THEY
BOUGHT GOODS, SAY, OFF OF AMAZON
OR OTHER PLACES. AND CALIFORNIA
WAS LOSING THAT REVENUE. SO AND
OF COURSE, THE PERCENT OF SALES
ON INTERNET VERSUS BRICK AND
MORTAR IN THOSE DAYS WAS FAR,
LOWER THAN IT IS TODAY. NOW NOW,
THE PERCENT OF SALES ON THE
INTERNET IS IT CONTINUES TO GROW
EACH YEAR. AND THE, EXCUSE ME, I
WAS ALMOST LOST MY TRAIN OF
THOUGHT, BUT IN PASSING THAT
BILL, THERE WERE SOME DEALS. CUT
THAT. SO LET ME STEP BACK. THE
PURPOSE OF THE BILL WAS, OF
COURSE, TO HELP CALIFORNIA'S
REVENUES. WE WERE IN THE MIDDLE
OF A RECESSION. WE HAD TERRIBLE
DEFICIT, FAR HIGHER THAN WE DO
TODAY. AND IT DID HELP OUR
REVENUES. BUT JUST LIKE WHAT'S
HAPPENING NOW IN THE MIDDLE OF
THAT RECESSION, WE HAD OUR
DOWNTOWN TOWNS. WE OUR MAIN
STREETS WERE DECIMATED, BRICK
AND MORTAR STORES WERE CLOSING
EVERYWHERE. NOW MANY OF THOSE
BRICK AND MORTAR STORES CAME
BACK. BUT NOW IN THE PANDEMIC,
WE'VE SEEN ONCE AGAIN THEY'RE
CLOSING. AND WE OF COURSE, FOR A
VARIETY OF REASONS, BECAUSE OF
INTERNET SALES, BECAUSE OF SO
MANY OTHER THINGS, WE SEE OUR
MALLS EMPTYING. AND THIS IS NOT
ONLY A LOSS TO THE STATE AND OUR
STATE REVENUES, BUT TO OUR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND THE PURPOSE OF
THE ORIGINAL BILL WAS TO HELP
NOT ONLY OUR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS,
BUT ALSO THE STATE TAX REVENUES.
BUT IN THE NEGOTIATIONS, IN THE
ULTIMATE NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE
GOVERNOR'S OFFICE, FOR THE
GOVERNOR TO SIGN THE BILL, IT IT
ALLOWED FOR CERTAIN
JURISDICTIONS TO BE ABLE TO GET
THESE BIG INCENTIVES AND, IN
EFFECT, GIVE BACK TO THOSE HUGE
MEGA ENTITIES LIKE AMAZON. AND
THEN, IN EFFECT, AS OUR AUTHOR
IS DESCRIBED, DENY NOT ONLY THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA, THE
REVENUE, BUT THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND THIS BILL IS
DIFFERENT THAN PAST ATTEMPTS. I
HAVE SUPPORTED EVERY ATTEMPT TO
TRY TO RECTIFY THAT BECAUSE I
BELIEVE THAT IT THE LOCAL
GOVERNMENT SHOULD GET THE SALES
TAX FROM THE POINT OF SALE,
WHICH, IF I'M SITTING AT HOME
AND I PURCHASE SOMETHING AND
THAT'S DELIVERED TO MY HOUSE,
THEN MY LOCAL GOVERNMENT SHOULD
GET THAT SALES TAX. NOW, THIS
BILL DOES NOT QUITE DO THAT, BUT
THIS BILL AT LEAST PROTECTS OUR
REVENUES, BOTH FOR LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS AND FOR THE STATE.
AND IT'S A FAR IMPROVEMENT OVER
WHAT WE HAVE NOW. AND WITH THAT,
I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK
YOU. SENATOR DALLI. THANK YOU,
MR. PRESIDENT. AND MEMBERS, I
RISE AS A CO AUTHOR TO THIS BILL
AND I JUST WANT TO MAYBE GIVE A
LITTLE PERSPECTIVE. YOU KNOW, I
KNOW THAT THE SENATOR HAS TRIED
THIS BILL MANY TIMES. AND WHEN
SOMETHING'S RIGHTEOUS, IT'S
RIGHTEOUS. AND THIS IS RIGHTEOUS
. AND WHY DO I SAY THAT? ALL OF
US, MAYBE NOT ALL OF US, BUT
MANY OF US MAY REMEMBER THE
GREAT CAL WORTHINGTON WHO HAD
HIS. HE WROTE A COW AND HE SOLD
CARS, AND HE WAS IN SACRAMENTO
COUNTY, I THINK HE WAS IN LA. HE
WAS ALL OVER THE PLACE, BUT HE
BASICALLY MOVED HIS CAR LOT OUT
TO ROSEVILLE AND DID AN AUTO
MALL AND BASICALLY TOOK THE TAX
BASE WITH HIM FROM THE CITY OF
SACRAMENTO. AND HE DID WELL OUT
THERE, AND IT WASN'T. THE PEOPLE
IN SACRAMENTO WERE LIKE, NOT TOO
HAPPY ABOUT LOSING THOSE BIG
SALES FOR TAXES. SO EVENTUALLY
THE STATE GOT SMART AND WE CAME
IN. AND WHAT DID WE DO? WE DID
POINT OF SALE. SO WHEREVER YOU
BUY YOUR VEHICLE DOESN'T MATTER.
WHEREVER YOU REGISTER THAT
VEHICLE IS WHERE THAT TAX BASE
GOES BECAUSE MANY CITIES AND
COUNTIES WANT TO SEE THOSE TAXES
IN THEIR LOCAL NEIGHBORHOODS.
THIS IS SIMILAR TO WHAT THE
SENATOR IS TRYING TO DO HERE IS
IF YOU THINK ABOUT 93% OF THE
CITIES AND COUNTIES ARE LOSING
THIS TAX DOLLARS GOES TO YOUR
PARKS, TO YOUR ROADS, TO YOUR
LAW ENFORCEMENT AND YOUR
COMMUNITY. AND NOW IT MAY BE
GOING TO, YOU KNOW, A
DISTRIBUTION CENTER THAT'S ALONG
A FREEWAY, TYPICALLY I-5 99 AND
THOSE AREAS. BUT WHAT I WANT TO
TALK ABOUT MORE IMPORTANTLY ON
THIS BILL IS THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
OPPOSING THE BILL. CAL TAX IS
OPPOSING THIS BILL. WHY? THIS IS
NOT ABOUT A TAX. THIS IS ABOUT A
DISTRIBUTION OF A TAX. I WAS IN
THE COMMITTEE WHEN THE SENATOR
PRESENTED HIS BILL. I'M THE VICE
CHAIR OF THAT COMMITTEE. AND
HOWARD JARVIS, TAXPAYERS CAME
OPPOSING THE BILL. THIS IS NOT
ABOUT RAISING TAXES. THIS IS NOT
ABOUT LOWERING TAXES. THIS IS
ABOUT DISTRIBUTION OF TAXES. I
WANT TO GET THAT VERY CLEAR.
NOW, I'D LIKE TO TALK ABOUT THE
COMPANIES THAT ARE GAMING THE
SYSTEM. AND WE HEAR EVERY DAY ON
THIS FLOOR ABOUT DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES AND PEOPLE NOT
GETTING A FAIR BREAK IN
CALIFORNIA. AND THE RICH GETTING
RICHER AND THE POOR GETTING
POORER. THINK ABOUT THIS. THIS
IS NOT A TAX INCREASE OR
DECREASE. THIS IS ABOUT
DISTRIBUTION. THESE
MULTI-BILLION DOLLAR COMPANIES
IN CALIFORNIA ARE ROBBING YOUR
COMMUNITY AND PUTTING THAT TAX
BASE THAT I PAY IN BIEBER AND
THEIR POCKETS, GETTING EVEN MORE
RICH OFF THE BACKS OF ATTACKS
AND MÐI. AND 93% OF COMMUNITIES
IN CALIFORNIA ARE SUFFERING THAT
THEY SHOULD HAVE THAT TAX. THAT
I THINK IS THE MOST IMPORTANT
PART ABOUT THIS BILL. IT'S ABOUT
EQUITY. IT'S ABOUT WHAT'S DOING
RIGHT NOW. LOOK YES, THERE ARE A
LOT OF WINNERS AND THERE'S A LOT
OF FOLKS WHO COMMUNITIES DO DO
BETTER AND DO GET THAT TAX. BUT
AT THE END OF THE DAY, ARE WE
GOING TO DO WHAT'S RIGHT? ARE WE
GOING TO DISTRIBUTE THE TAX
RIGHT, OR ARE WE GOING TO ALLOW
THE POWERFUL LOBBY OF THESE
BILLION DOLLAR COMPANIES? THE
LITTLE STORE IN MY TOWN DOESN'T
HAVE A LOBBY. THEY HAVE ME, AND
I'M A REPUBLICAN AND A DEMOCRAT
CONTROLLED ENVIRONMENT, AND I DO
MY BEST TO TRY TO GIVE THEM A
BREAK. AND I'M ALSO A SMALL
BUSINESS OWNER AND I GET
DESTROYED BY BIG BUSINESSES. SO
ALL THOSE LITTLE BUSINESSES THAT
ARE OUT THERE, THE CORNER
MARKETS THAT ARE STAYING ALIVE,
THAT ARE SUPPORTING YOUR PARKS,
YOUR YOUR ROADS AND YOUR LAW
ENFORCEMENT. IF YOU VOTE AGAINST
THIS BILL, YOU'RE SAYING, WELL,
THE BIG GUY IS GOING TO WIN
AGAIN. SO FOR THAT, FOR THOSE
REASONS, I JUST WANT TO LAY THE
RECORD STRAIGHT. THIS ISN'T
ABOUT A TAX INCREASE OR
DECREASE. THIS IS ABOUT TAX
DISTRIBUTION. I THINK THE GOOD
SENATOR, FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD, AND I ASK YOU TO REACH
DOWN IN YOUR HEART AND DO WHAT'S
RIGHT FOR THAT. 93% OF YOUR
COMMUNITIES THAT ARE LOSERS AND
THE 7% THAT ARE WINNERS. A LOT
OF THOSE WINNERS YOU MAY
REPRESENT A TOWN OR A CITY NEXT
DOOR THAT'S LOSING. AND THAT
ONE, ONE ENTITY IS WINNING. SO
AGAIN, I SUPPORT SB 1493, AND I
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR BRINGING IT
BACK AGAIN. HOPEFULLY THIS TIME
WE'LL GET IT TO THE GOVERNOR AND
IT'LL GET SIGNED. THANK YOU,
SENATOR EGGMAN. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS I RISE WITH
AN ALTERNATIVE PERSPECTIVE, AND
I'M NOT GOING TO VORACIOUSLY
ARGUE AGAINST THIS BILL, BUT I'M
GOING TO MAKE A POINT. AND THE
POINT I'M GOING TO MAKE IS TO
SAY THIS BILL IS NOT ABOUT THE
BIG GUYS, RIGHT? THIS BILL IS
ABOUT WHAT LOCAL GOVERNMENTS CAN
DO WITH THE RESOURCES THEY HAVE.
SO I'LL TELL YOU SOME OF THE
WINNERS AND YOU TELL ME IF
THEY'RE THE BIG GUYS OR NOT,
CITY OF DINUBA. CITY OF FRESNO.
CITY OF MERCED. CITY OF LA
PALMA. CITY OF TRACY. CITY OF
STOCKTON. YOU KNOW WHO THOSE
FOLKS ARE? THE LITTLE GUYS THAT
LIVE ON THAT CORRIDOR, THAT
BREATHE, THAT DIESEL, THAT
SMELL, THAT GAS, THAT HAVE A LOT
OF OUR JOBS TAKEN. AND BECAUSE
WE'VE MOVED TO A DIFFERENT
ECONOM ECONOMY, THAT HAS TO DO
WITH DISTRIBUTION CENTER AND
PEOPLE BUYING THINGS ONLINE AND
GETTING IT DELIVERED TO THEIR
HOUSE, WELL, YOU KNOW WHERE THAT
STUFF COMES THROUGH THE LITTLE
TOWNS UP AND DOWN THE VALLEY ON
THE I-5 AND 99 CORRIDOR. THAT'S
WHERE THEY COME FROM. AND THAT'S
WHO'S GETTING THOSE TAX BREAKS.
ARE WE GETTING A TON? NO BUT THE
CITY OF STOCKTON IS GETTING
ABOUT A MILLION AND A HALF, $2
MILLION A YEAR, AND THAT'S
BETTER THAN WE'D GET OTHERWISE.
I'M NOT SAYING IT'S A PERFECT
SYSTEM, BUT I'M SAYING IN THE
SYSTEM THAT WE HAVE, IT GIVES
SOME OF THESE SMALLER
COMMUNITIES WHO BREATHE THE
REPERCUSSIONS OF THIS MODEL THAT
WE'VE ALL CREATED AND, AND TRY
TO GET A LITTLE BIT FOR OUR
COMMUNITIES TOO. SO IF THAT'S
ARGUING FOR THE BIG GUYS, I'M
SORRY, BUT THE LITTLE GUYS WHO
BREATHE THE NASTY AIR AND HAVE
ALL THE HEALTH REPERCUSSIONS
THAT COME ALONG WITH THAT, SOME
OF THE LOWEST EDUCATION LEVELS
IN THE STATE, SOME OF THE LOWEST
LEVELS OF ATTAINMENT IN THE
STATE. I SERVED ON THE CITY OF
STOCKTON IN 2012, WHEN WE WERE
THE LARGEST MUNICIPALITY IN THE
COUNTRY, TO GO INTO BANKRUPTCY
BECAUSE OF A LOT OF THE POLICIES
, THE LACK OF HOUSING POLICIES
FOR MY FRIEND AND FROM ORINDA,
OR MY FRIEND FROM BERKELEY, OR
MY FRIEND WHO CAN'T VOTE FOR
BILLS THAT HAVE TO DO WITH CLEAN
AIR BECAUSE THEY'RE SO CLEAN, WE
ALL HAVE DIFFERENT SORTS OF
PRIVILEGES, BUT I CAN'T SUPPORT
THIS BILL TODAY. THANK YOU,
SENATOR ROTH. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I'M I'VE RANTED AND
RAVED ON THIS FLOOR ON THIS
ISSUE BEFORE. BUT I'M NOT GOING
TO DO IT TODAY. AND I HAVE ALL
THE GREATEST RESPECT FOR THE
AUTHOR AND ANYBODY WHO COULD
STAND UP AND PRESENT THIS,
AGAIN, DESERVES OUR RESPECT, AND
FRANKLY, THIS MAY BE THE RIGHT
APPROACH, BUT, YOU KNOW, I HAVE
TO I HAVE TO SAY THAT THE
ABILITY OF THOSE OF YOU TO SIT
ON THE COUCH IN YOUR LIVING ROOM
AND PICK UP YOUR CELL PHONE OR
YOUR IPAD AND ORDER WHATEVER IT
IS THAT YOU WANT TO ORDER FROM
AMAZON OR WHEREVER ELSE THAT YOU
ORDER IT AND RECEIVE THAT ORDER
AT YOUR FRONT DOOR. IT'S
FACILITATED BY WAREHOUSING AND
DISTRIBUTION FACILITIES LOCATED
IN, IN MANY CASES IN OUR SMALL
COMMUNITIES AND DISADVANTAGED
AREAS OF OUR STATE, OFTEN NEAR
FREEWAYS FOR SURE, WHERE TRUCKS
AND OFTEN NEAR RAILROAD TRACKS
WHERE TRAINS, YOU KNOW, SPEW
POLLUTION ON A DAILY BASIS.
THOSE THOSE COMMUNITIES BEAR THE
BURDEN OF MAKING SURE THAT WE
ALL ARE ABLE TO ORDER FROM OUR
COUCHES, WITH OUR CELL PHONES
AND OUR IPADS AND HAVE THE STUFF
AT OUR FRONT DOOR OFTEN WITHIN
24 HOURS. BUT THE BURDEN IS, AS
MY COLLEAGUE FROM STOCKTON SAID,
THE BURDEN, MAY BE FINANCIAL IN
OTHER AREAS WHERE YOU LIVE AND
YOU'RE ORDERING FROM YOUR COUCH,
BUT THE BURDEN TO THESE
COMMUNITIES IS MORE THAN JUST
MONEY. IT'S A BURDEN TO THE
ROADS. IT'S A BURDEN TO THE
ENVIRONMENT. IT'S A BURDEN TO
THE SCHOOLS AND THE KIDS THAT
ATTEND THERE, WHICH ARE OFTEN
LOCATED. UNFORTUNATELY NEXT TO
THESE WAREHOUSES AND THESE
DISTRIBUTION CENTERS. AND IT'S A
BURDEN THAT OFTEN THESE
COMMUNITIES AND THE RESIDENTS IN
THEM CANNOT, CANNOT HAVE TROUBLE
BEARING. I MEAN, THE CITY OF
PARIS AND INLAND SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA TRIED VALIANTLY TO
PUT A MEASURE AND GET IT PASSED
ON THEIR LOCAL BALLOT TO HAVE,
WAREHOUSING PAY FOR THE COSTS OF
REPAIRS TO THE STREETS THAT THE
TRUCKS HAVE DESTROYED. AND THE
BALLOT MEASURES, THROUGH THE
EFFORTS OF SOME WAS ROUNDLY AND
SOUNDLY DEFEATED. SO WHILE THIS
MAY BE THE PROPER WAY TO HANDLE
IT, AND THE INEQUITABLE
DISTRIBUTION OF TAX REVENUE,
WE'RE GOING TO HAVE TO FIGURE
OUT AS WE DO THIS, WE'RE GOING
TO HAVE TO FIGURE OUT SOME OTHER
WAY TO COVER THE COST OF THIS
BURDEN TO THOSE COMMUNITIES THAT
MAKE OUR LIFESTYLE THE LIFESTYLE
. WE WANT TO LIVE IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA, IN THE TECHNOLOGY
SATURATED ERA WHERE WE CAN GET
WHATEVER WE WANT TO GET,
WHATEVER IT COSTS WITHIN 24
HOURS. THANK YOU. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
ISSUE? SENATOR NGUYEN?
PERMISSION TO ASK A QUESTION?
MR. PRESIDENT? SENATOR GLAZER,
WILL YOU ACCEPT A QUESTION? YES.
THROUGH THE CHAIR. SENATOR. SO,
I WAS TALKING TO SOME OF MY
CITIES AND A LITTLE BIT
CONFUSING. SO ONE IS JUST TO ASK
FOR CLARIFICATION WHEN YOU
TALKED ABOUT BANNING AND NOT
ALLOWING ANY MORE REBATE
CONTRACTS, DOES THAT INCLUDE
AUTO DEALERSHIPS? DOES THAT
INCLUDE HOTELS? DOES THAT
INCLUDE PARKING STRUCTURES?
BECAUSE MY UNDERSTANDING WAS
VERY NARROW. BUT NOW THAT WHAT
THE DISCUSSION HERE TODAY, I'M A
LITTLE CONFUSED BECAUSE OUR MY
DISTRICT IS VERY I MEAN, LIKE
MOST OF OURS IS VERY LARGE, BUT
WE'VE GOT THE COAST, WHICH, YOU
KNOW, DEALS WITH A LOT OF
PARKING STRUCTURES, SO THEY
WOULD HAVE TO ASK COMPANIES TO
COME IN AND BUILD THE PARKING
STRUCTURES AND GIVE AN INCENTIVE
AND OR HOTELS. AND THEN WE'RE UP
IN KNOTT'S BERRY FARM AREA,
WHERE HOTELS AND, SO I JUST WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT THIS DOESN'T
COMPLETELY BAN CITIES FROM
ENTERING INTO ANY REBATE
CONTRACTS IN THE FUTURE. THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION, SENATOR.
IT'S A GOOD ONE. NO, I DON'T
BELIEVE THIS BILL WILL AFFECT
ANY OF THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES IN
WHICH YOU JUST DESCRIBED BECAUSE
THEY'RE THERE, THEY OCCUR IN A
JURISDICTION. SO THE EXISTING
TAX LAWS ARE THOSE TAX MONIES GO
TO THAT JURISDICTION, THEY CAN
REBATE, THEY CAN NEGOTIATE
NOTHING AFFECTS THEIR ABILITY TO
CREATE ECONOMIC INCENTIVES FOR
FOLKS TO COME IN AND LOCATE IN
THEIR COMMUNITIES. SO NOTHING IN
THIS BILL AFFECTS, AS I
UNDERSTAND IT, ANY OF THOSE
AGREEMENTS OR REBATES IN WHICH
YOU'VE INQUIRED. I HAVE ONE MORE
QUESTION, MR. PRESIDENT. THE
NEXT QUESTION IS, IF I HAVE A
STORE, LET'S JUST SAY, I DON'T
KNOW, HUNTING BEACH OR GARDEN
GROVE WHATEVER IN MY DISTRICT.
AND I'M NOT AN AMAZON. I'M NOT A
BIG DISTRIBUTION CENTER. I'M
JUST A SMALL JANET NGUYEN CRAFT
SHOP. IF SOMEONE BOUGHT ONLINE
HÌNH, DOES THAT AFFECT THAT
BUSINESS OR DOES IT? I MEAN, ARE
WE WHAT KIND OF BUSINESS ARE WE
TALKING ABOUT IN TERMS OF THESE
DISTRIBUTION IN MOST CASES, IT
WILL NOT AFFECT THAT BUSINESS.
THEY'RE LOCATED IN THAT
COMMUNITY. THAT POINT OF SALE IS
THEIR SINGLE, STOREFRONT,
WHATEVER THAT IS, JANET NGUYEN
CRAFTS. AND SO, NO, IT WOULDN'T
AFFECT THAT. THAT TYPE OF A
BUSINESS. AND THAT'S ONLINE
PURCHASE. THAT'S CORRECT.
BECAUSE YOU HAVE TO DESIGNATE A
POINT OF SALE IF THAT'S YOUR
ONLY LOCATION, YOU'RE NOT GOING
TO SAY TO BAKERSFIELD, I'M GOING
TO ASSIGN IT TO BAKERSFIELD. IF
YOU GIVE ME HALF THE MONEY,
THAT'S NOT GOING TO WORK. SO IT
WOULD JUST COME BACK TO THAT
JURISDICTION IN WHICH YOU'VE
LOCATED YOUR CRAFT STORE. THANK
YOU. YOU'RE WELCOME. THANK YOU,
SENATOR NILO. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. MY STAFF AND I HAVE
HAD A ROBUST DISCUSSION ABOUT
THIS ISSUE, AND I CAN UNDERSTAND
BOTH SIDES OF IT. AND THE
ARGUMENT OVER CITIES BASED SALES
TAX DISTRIBUTION IS AS OLD AS
SALES TAX IS. I THINK IT WAS.
SENATOR STEINBERG WAS ADVOCATING
FOR A WHOLESALE CHANGE OF THE
PRACTICE, BACK WHEN I WAS IN THE
ASSEMBLY WOULD HAVE BEEN VERY
DIFFICULT TO DO ADMINISTRATIVELY
, LIKE AT A SHOPPING MALL WITH
SMALL SALES. BUT THE FACT OF THE
MATTER IS, THIS EXISTS AND
COMMUNITIES COMPETE FOR RETAIL
SALES TAX GENERATORS LIKE,
SHOPPING MALLS AND THE LIKE. AND
I WANT TO THANK MY, MY FRIEND
FROM BIEBER FOR USING A
DIFFERENT AUTO DEALER FOR HIS,
EXAMPLE, BUT WE CANNOT LIKE THAT
PRACTICE. AND WE CAN WE CAN
ARGUE PHILOSOPHICALLY OVER IT'S
REALLY, TRULY THE BEST USE OF
LOCAL RESOURCES FOR ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT. BUT IT IS WHAT IT
IS. IT'S THE RULES OF THE GAME.
AND I WAS OPPOSED TO SENATOR
STEINBERG'S NOTION BACK THEN,
BECAUSE IT'S THE RULES OF THE
GAME, AND YOU CAN'T CHANGE THE
RULES OF A GAME, ESSENTIALLY,
RETROACTIVELY. AND MY CONCERN
ABOUT THIS PROPOSAL IS IT DOES
JUST THAT. I REALIZE IT GIVES
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE EXISTING
AGREEMENTS, SIX YEARS, BUT IT
CHANGES THE RULES OF THE GAME
RETROACTIVELY. SIX YEARS FROM
NOW. IT IS AN ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT TOOL. LOVE IT OR
HATE IT, IT IS AN ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT TOOL. THAT IS THE
RULES OF THE GAME IN THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA. AND THAT'S WHY I
CAN'T SUPPORT THE PROPOSAL THAT
TO ME IS MORE UNFAIR THAN THE
UNFAIRNESS THAT, WAS STATED
PREVIOUSLY. THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ITEM AND SEEING NONE.
SENATOR GLAZER, WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE? YEAH. WELL, FIRST, LET
ME THANK THE SENATOR FROM
BERKELEY AND FROM BIEBER FOR
THEIR THOUGHTFUL REMARKS. LET ME
ALSO THANK THE CONTRIBUTIONS
FROM THE SENATORS FROM
RIVERSIDE, STOCKTON AND
CERTAINLY FAIR OAKS FOR ENGAGING
IN THIS SPIRITED DEBATE. WE HAVE
AT ALMOST EVERY YEAR, I DON'T
WANT TO NECESSARILY CALL IT FUN,
BUT IT'S SPIRITED AND LET ME LET
ME SPEAK TO SOME OF THE ISSUES
THAT HAVE BEEN RAISED, FIRST, IN
TERMS OF THE WAREHOUSE ISSUE,
THE COMMUNITIES IN WHICH THERE
ARE WAREHOUSES AND THEIR IMPACTS
IN EVERY ONE OF THOSE CASES, THE
COMMUNITIES CITE THOSE
FACILITIES AND THE ABILITY TO
IMPOSE IMPACT FEES. IT HAPPENS
IN EVERY DEVELOPMENT. IF THERE'S
GOING TO BE AN IMPACT, THE
COMMUNITY THAT'S GIVING THE
PERMITS AND THE AUTHORIZATIONS
AND THE ZONING OR WHAT HAVE YOU
CAN GO THROUGH WITH THAT COMPANY
AND SAY, HEY, HERE ARE THE
IMPACTS. AND THEY HAVE EVERY
RIGHT UNDER THE LAW TO MAKE SURE
THAT WHATEVER THOSE IMPACTS ARE,
THAT THEY CAN BE COMPENSATED FOR
THEM. SO I RECOGNIZE THE
SENSITIVITY OF THIS, OF THIS
ISSUE OF SHIPPING AND
DISTRIBUTION CENTERS TO
COMMUNITIES IN OUR STATE. BUT I
WOULD SAY IT'S IRRELEVANT AS
REGARD TO THIS BILL, BECAUSE
THAT'S WITHIN THE CONTROL OF THE
CITY. AND PRESUMABLY THEY'RE
MAKING GOOD AND THOUGHTFUL
CHOICES IN THAT REGARD. AND I
WANT TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF THE
SMALL COMMUNITIES THAT ARE
AFFECTED AND I MENTIONED
EARLIER, HOW ABOUT HOW THEY CAN
BE BAITED BY THESE COMPANIES TO
SAY, HEY, WE GOT A DEAL FOR YOU.
COME ON OVER. AND AS I WAS
COMING OVER HERE TODAY, I, I WAS
TRYING TO THINK OF A GOOD
METAPHOR TO SUM UP THIS BILL AND
THE CIRCUMSTANCES IN WHICH THOSE
SMALL CITIES FIND THEMSELVES.
AND I CAME UP WITH A THOUGHT OF
PATTY HEARST. AND NOW I DON'T
KNOW IF EVERYBODY ON THE FLOOR
HERE KNOWS WHO PATTY HEARST IS,
BUT SHE WAS THE MEDIA HEIR OF
THE HEARST FORTUNE. AND IN 1974,
SHE WAS KIDNAPED. SHE WAS
KIDNAPED BY THE SYMBIONESE
LIBERATION ARMY. THEY WENT TO
HER APARTMENT WITH GUNS BLAZING,
BLINDFOLDED HER, THREW HER IN
THE CAR, AND THEY CALLED HER A
PRISONER OF WAR. AND THEY THREW
HER IN A CLOSET, I GUESS, AS THE
NEWS MEDIA REPORTS FOR A NUMBER
OF MONTHS AND, ASKED FOR RANSOM
AND ALL THE REST. SO WHAT
HAPPENED TO PATTY HEARST? WELL A
FEW MONTHS AFTER SHE WAS
KIDNAPED, SHE APPEARED IN A
PHOTOGRAPH WITH MEMBERS OF THE
SYMBIONESE LIBERATION ARMY
ROBBING A BANK, HOLDING A GUN,
ROBBING A BANK. SHE JOINED THE
GANG THAT HAD KIDNAPED HER. AND
WHEN I THINK ABOUT THE SMALL
COMMUNITIES OF CALIFORNIA, YOU
KNOW, WE HAVE BEEN ROBBED, THE
PUBLIC BANK HAS BEEN ROBBED BY
THESE COMPANIES, AND WE HAVE
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE BEEN
BAITED AND COERCED TO JOIN IN
THAT ROBBERY. THEY'RE COMPLICIT
TO THAT ROBBERY. THEY HAVE THEY
HAVE MADE THE DEAL WITH THE
DEVIL. AND YES, ARE THEY GAINING
? THEY'RE GAINING. BUT IT
HAPPENED UNDER IN MANY WAYS,
DURESS, THEIR OWN ECONOMIC
CIRCUMSTANCES OR WHATEVER YOU
WANT TO CALL IT. AND, YOU KNOW,
THERE ARE SYNDROMES THAT THEY
TALK ABOUT FOR FOLKS LIKE THIS.
AND I THINK IT APPLIES TO SOME
OF OUR SMALLER COMMUNITIES.
WHAT, WHAT WHAT COULD THEY DO?
WHAT COULD THEY DO BUT JOIN THE
GANG, JOIN THE ROBBERS AND
UNDERSTAND THE CONSEQUENCES OVER
$1 BILLION OF PUBLIC MONEY GO
INTO THE ROBBERS BECAUSE OF
THOSE DEALS. THIS MEASURE
CORRECTS A WRONG. YES, IT IS THE
TAX SYSTEM. WE WISH IT WASN'T
THAT WAY, BUT WE CAN CORRECT IT.
WE CAN MAKE IT BETTER. SO WE CAN
GO BACK TO OUR COMMUNITIES AND
SAY, YEAH, NOBODY LIKES PAYING
TAXES, BUT AT LEAST WE'RE GOING
TO DO OUR BEST TO MAKE SURE IT'S
FAIR AND HONEST. AND THAT'S WHAT
THIS BILL DOES. AND I HOPE IT
DESERVES YOUR SUPPORT TODAY.
THANK YOU ALL. DEBATE HAVING
CEASED SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL ON ITEM 28. ELLEN
RODA-GIL NÓ ARCHULETA. ASHBY.
AYE. ATKINS NØ. BECKER. BLAKE.
SPEER AYE. BRADFORD CABALLERO.
NØ. CORTEZ AYE. DALLY I DODD.
DURAZZO. AYE. EGGMAN NÓ. GLASER
AYE. GONZALEZ. GROVE NO.
HURTADO. NO. JONES NO. LAIRD.
AYE LIMON. AYE. MCGUIRE MENGIBAR
. MEN AYE. NEWMAN. NGUYEN NILO.
NO CHOBOQ. PADILLA. AYE
PORTANTINO. AYE. ROTH RUBIO.
SATO NO. SKINNER AYE. SMILED.
CUEVAS. AYE. STERN. AYE UMBERG.
AYE. WAHAB WIENER. AYE. WILK
SENATOR MOVES TO CALL. ARE YOU
COMING BACK? OKAY. THEY TOLD ME
TO RUN IT. ALL RIGHT. SO NOW
WE'RE.
YEAH. OKAY, MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING
TO MOVE NOW TO FILE ITEM 27.
THIS IS SENATE BILL CHAU. FILE
ITEM 27. THIS IS SENATE BILL
1348 BY SENATOR BRADFORD. HE IS
PREPARED. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL 1348 BY SENATOR
BRADFORD. AN ACT RELATING TO
POST-SECONDARY EDUCATION.
SENATOR BRADFORD, THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. THIS BILL WOULD
CREATE A STATE LEVEL DESIGNATION
RECOGNIZING COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES IN CALIFORNIA THAT
MAKE SIGNIFICANT COMMITMENTS TO
ENHANCING BLACK STUDENT SUCCESS
AND ENROLLMENT. HISTORICALLY,
BLACK STUDENTS ARE
UNDERREPRESENTED ON COLLEGE
CAMPUSES, AND THE STATISTICS FOR
BLACK COLLEGE STUDENTS
ACHIEVEMENTS ARE CONCERNING.
NATIONAL DATA SHOWS BLACK
STUDENT ENROLLMENT DECLINED BY
22% OVER THE FROM 2010 TO 2020.
DATA ALSO SHOWS THAT BLACK
STUDENTS ARE MORE LIKELY TO
DELAY ATTENDING COLLEGE AFTER
HIGH SCHOOL. THEY EITHER GO PART
TIME, THEY USUALLY DO NOT EARN A
DEGREE, ARE MORE LIKELY TO TAKE
ON GREATER STUDENT DEBT THAN
THEIR COUNTERPARTS. BUT THE NEWS
IS NOT ALL BAD. THERE ARE
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES IN
CALIFORNIA THAT ARE
DISTINGUISHING THEMSELVES
THROUGH THEIR INVESTMENT AND
COMMITMENT TO BLACK STUDENT
SUCCESS. SB 1348 WILL CREATE A
METHOD TO RECOGNIZE THOSE
INNOVATIVE COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES BY AWARDING THEM A
SPECIAL SPECIAL DESIGNATION OF
SERVING BLACK STUDENTS. THIS
RECOGNITION WOULD BE SIMILAR TO
THE DESIGNATION CURRENTLY
AWARDED TO FEDERAL GOVERNMENT
FOR MINORITY SERVING
INSTITUTIONS, SUCH AS THE
HISPANIC SERVING INSTITUTIONS
AND THE ASIAN AMERICAN AND
NATIVE AMERICAN PACIFIC ISLANDER
SERVING INSTITUTIONS. BLACK
STUDENTS SERVING INSTITUTIONS
WILL FOCUS ON EXPANDING
EDUCATIONAL OPPORTUNITIES AND
IMPROVING THE ACADEMIC OUTCOMES
FOR BLACK STUDENTS. THIS
RECOGNITION WOULD ALSO HELP
STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES IN
IDENTIFYING COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES IN CALIFORNIA THAT
DELIVER A HIGH LEVEL OF SERVICES
TO THOSE STUDENTS. THIS BILL IS
SUPPORTED BY THE UCS AND CSUS
AND THE CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR BRADFORD. DOES ANY
SENATOR WANT TO BE HEARD ON THIS
MEASURE? SENATOR NILO? THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. SAC STATE
HAS A HAS ESTABLISHED A PROGRAM
SIMILAR TO WHAT YOU'RE TALKING
ABOUT. AND I'M GOING TO BE
MEETING WITH, LUKE WOOD, WHO IS
THE I LOSE TRACK OF WHERE THEIR,
CHANCELLORS VERSUS PRESIDENTS.
SO AT THE STATE COLLEGES, HE'S A
PRESIDENT. SO I'M GOING TO BE
MEETING WITH PRESIDENT WOOD
ABOUT THIS BECAUSE I'M VERY
INTERESTED IN IT. AND THE REASON
I'M INTERESTED IN IT IS WHEN ON,
THE RESOLUTION WAS INITIALLY,
PRESENTED A COUPLE OF MONTHS
AGO, I ROSE AND WAS FRUSTRATED
THAT THE RESOLUTION DIDN'T STATE
ANYTHING WITH REGARD TO
EDUCATION AND IN MY OPINION,
THAT IS THE LARGEST CHALLENGE TO
OUR AFRICAN AMERICAN COMMUNITY
BECAUSE THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP IS
SO HUGE. THE LOWEST ACHIEVING
COHORT IN CALIFORNIA ARE AFRICAN
AMERICAN STUDENTS, AND IT'S NOT
THEIR FAULT WE DISSERVE THEM
TREMENDOUSLY. AND I THINK THE
KEY TO THE FUTURE IS EDUCATION.
AND SO WHILE THIS BILL MAY NOT
BE PERFECT, I LIKE THE IDEA I AM
GOING TO VOTE FOR THIS BILL AND
I URGE YOU TO JOIN ME. MEMBERS,
ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE, ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
OR DEBATE, SEEING NONE. SENATOR
BRADFORD, YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK
YOU. AND I WANT TO THANK THE
SENATOR FROM SACRAMENTO FOR
HIGHLIGHTING SAC STATE, BECAUSE
AS PRESIDENT, WOOD IS A STRONG
SUPPORTER OF THIS MEASURE, AS
WELL AS PRESIDENT PARHAM AT CAL
STATE DOMINGUEZ HILLS AND A
COMMUNITY COLLEGE PRESIDENT, AS
WELL, SUCH AS KEITH CURRY. AND
IT'S IMPORTANT AGAIN, OAN, TO
CHANGE THE PARADIGM OF AFRICAN
AMERICAN SUCCESS RATE IN
COLLEGES. MANY PEOPLE DON'T
UNDERSTAND THAT THE TURN OF THE
CENTURY AFRICAN AMERICANS WAS
MORE HBCU UNIVERSITIES THAN ANY
OTHER COLLEGE IN THIS COUNTRY,
AND WE WERE GRADUATING MORE
INDIVIDUALS FROM COLLEGE FROM
THE EARLY 1900S UNTIL THE MID 50
S THAN ANY OTHER COLLEGE. BUT
THAT HAS QUICKLY CHANGED BECAUSE
OF INTEGRATION. SOME OF THOSE
UNIVERSITIES AREN'T AS WELCOMING
OR EMBRACING AS THEY COULD BE,
SO THIS HELPS US IDENTIFY THOSE
COLLEGES THAT CLEARLY ARE
EMBRACING TO CULTURAL DIVERSITY,
WHETHER IT'S OUR HISPANIC
BROTHERS AND SISTERS, OUR NATIVE
AMERICANS, OUR AFRICAN
AMERICANS. AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AYE VOTE MEMBERS. WE DO
HAVE A SENATOR OFF THE FLOOR. SO
WE'RE GOING TO GO THROUGH THE
ROLL JUST ONCE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ELLEN
ALVARADO GILL I Ã ARCHULETA.
ASHBY I ATKINS I BECKER BLAKE
SPUR I BRADFORD I CABALLERO I
CORTEZ I DALLY I DODD I THOUGHT
OSO I EGGMAN I GLASER I GONZALEZ
I GROVE I HURTADO I JONES LAIRD
I LEMON I MCGUIRE MENGIBAR I MEN
I NEWMAN NGUYEN NILO I OCHOA.
PADILLA I PORTANTINO I ROTH I
RUBIO I SATO. SKINNER I SMILED.
CUEVAS I STERN, I UMBERG I WAHAB
I WIENER I WILK. SENATOR
BRADFORD MOVES THE CALL. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM
30. THIS IS SENATE BILL 962 BY
SENATOR PADILLA. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ. SENATE BILL 962 BY
SENATOR PADILLA. AN ACT RELATING
TO THE PUBLIC EMPLOYEE PENSION
BENEFITS AND DECLARING THE
URGENCY THEREOF TO TAKE EFFECT
IMMEDIATELY. SENATOR PADILLA,
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT AND
COLLEAGUES. SB 962 ALLOWS THE
PORT OF SAN DIEGO TO ELIMINATE
THE FIVE YEAR WAITING PERIOD ON
AN EXISTING PLAN ON A
PROSPECTIVE BASIS AND PROVIDE
EXISTING AND NEW EMPLOYEES WITH
PRE 2013 RECIPROCITY. THE
OPPORTUNITY TO ACCRUE SERVICE
CREDIT UPON IMPLEMENTATION OF
THE MEASURE WHILE STILL
REMAINING EMPLOYER. MAINTAINING
EMPLOYER COSTS BELOW THAT OF THE
STANDARD PEPPER PLAN. 2008 THE
PORT AND TEAMSTERS LOCAL 911
DEVELOPED A NEW PLAN FOR THE
PORT OF SAN DIEGO, CREATING A
HYBRID RETIREMENT PLAN INCLUDING
BOTH DEFINED CONTRIBUTION AND
SMALLER DEFINED BENEFIT PLANS AS
A WAY TO SHARE COSTS AND RISKS
BETWEEN EMPLOYEES AND EMPLOYER.
THE PLAN INCLUDED A WAITING
PERIOD EMPLOYEE WOULD ACCRUE
SERVICE CREDIT ONCE FIVE YEARS
OF EMPLOYMENT WAS COMPLETED.
UNFORTUNATELY THIS REQUIREMENT
TO ACCRUE CREDIT AFTER FIVE
YEARS HAS RENDERED THE PLAN LESS
COMPETITIVE WHEN COMPARED TO
OTHER REGIONAL PUBLIC AGENCIES,
MAKING IT DIFFICULT TO ATTRACT
AND RETAIN EMPLOYEES BY ENACTING
THIS CHANGE, EMPLOYEES WILL
BEGIN PARTICIPATING AND
RECEIVING CREDIT SERVICE CREDIT
UPON THEIR FIRST DAY OF
EMPLOYMENT. INSTEAD OF WAITING
FIVE YEARS. THE CHANGE WILL MAKE
THE PORT'S RETIREMENT BENEFITS
MORE COMPETITIVE WITH OTHER
AGENCIES IN THE REGION AND
ENHANCE RECRUITMENT AND
INTENTION RETENTION FOR THESE
PUBLIC SERVICE JOBS. IT'S
COMPLETELY PEPPER COMPLIANT ON
BOTH AXES, AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR PADILLA. DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE? SENATOR FROM BIEBER A
QUESTION TO THE AUTHOR, IF I
MAY. WE TAKE A QUESTION. WELL,
OKAY. PLEASE. IN READING THE
BILL, I JUST WANT THE QUESTION I
HAVE IS THAT OUR OTHER AGENCIES
THAT ARE CLOSE BY THAT THAT ARE
COMPETING FOR THESE JOBS, ARE
THEY AT A FIVE YEAR OR ARE THEY
AT YEAR ONE? I'M WHAT MY CONCERN
WOULD BE THEY WOULD DRAW THEM
AWAY FROM THE OTHER AGENCIES.
THEY'D BE IN THE SAME BOAT THAT
YOU'RE IN NOW. MR. PRESIDENT, IF
I MAY, IF I UNDERSTAND MY
COLLEAGUES QUESTION, IT'S TERMS
OF A CASCADING EFFECT. I'M NOT
AWARE OF THAT DYNAMIC AT PLAY,
AND I THINK THE HYBRID MODEL IS
DISTINCT HERE. THAT WAS AGREED
UPON BEHIND THE BETWEEN THE
PARTIES. AS OF NOW. THANK YOU. I
WILL BE SUPPORTING THE BILL.
THANK YOU. SENATOR DARLING, ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE?
SEEING NONE. SENATOR PADILLA,
YOU MAY CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE. SECRETARY,
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ELLEN
ALVARADO. AYE. ARCHULETA ASHBY.
AYE. ATKINS AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BLAKE. SPEER. AYE. BRADFORD
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ. AYE.
DALLI AYE. DODD. AYE. DURAZZO
EGGMAN. AYE. EGGMAN. GLASER AYE.
GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE AYE AYE.
JONES AYE. LAIRD. AYE. LIMON.
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR. AYE MINH.
NEWMAN. NGUYEN NILO. AYE.
CHROBOG. AYE. PERDUE PORTANTINO.
PADILLA. AYE PORTANTINO. AYE.
ROTH. AYE. RUBIO RUBIO. AYE.
SATO AYE. SKINNER AYE. SMILED.
CUEVAS AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG
WAHAB. AYE. WIENER. AYE. WILK
AYE. PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ALLEN. ARCHULETA
BRADFORD. AYE EGGMAN. AYE LIMÓN.
AYE. MCGUIRE MINH. AYE. NEWMAN
NGUYEN. UMBERG. AYE. AYE 35. NO.
ZERO ON THE URGENCY. I'S 35. NO.
ZERO. MEASURE PASSES. UP NEXT WE
HAVE FIVE. ITEM 31, FOLLOWED BY
32 AND 33. SENATOR BLAKE SPEERS
PREPARED SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL 1077 BY SENATOR
BLAKE SPEER, AN ACT RELATING TO
COASTAL RESOURCES. SENATOR
BREAKSPEARE THANK YOU, PRESIDENT
AND COLLEAGUES. I RISE TO
PRESENT SB 1077, WHICH WILL
REQUIRE THE COASTAL COMMISSION
TO COORDINATE WITH THE
DEPARTMENT OF HOUSING AND
COMMUNITY DEVELOPMENT, HCD TO
COURT TO DISCUSS THE ISSUE OF
GUIDANCE ON HOW COASTAL LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS SHOULD UPDATE THEIR
ACCESSORY DWELLING UNIT
ORDINANCES TO CONFORM WITH STATE
LAW. I HAVE WORKED WITH THE
OPPOSITION ON EARLIER VERSIONS
OF THIS BILL, NAMELY THE COASTAL
COMMISSION, TO ADDRESS THEIR
CONCERNS WITH AMENDMENTS, AND
THEY ARE NOW NEUTRAL. THIS BILL
DIRECTS HCD AND THE COASTAL
COMMISSION TO DEVELOP GUIDANCE
FOR LOCAL GOVERNMENTS TO UPDATE
THEIR ADU ORDINANCES AND THEIR
LCP IN A WAY THAT RESOLVES
CONFLICTS IN MANDATES BETWEEN
THE COASTAL COMMISSION AND HCD.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE COLLEAGUES. DO YOU HAVE ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE? SEEING
NONE. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. ALAN ALVARADO. GILL. AYE.
ARCHULETA ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS
AYE. BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER
AYE. BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO.
AYE CORTEZ. AYE. DALLI AYE. DODD
I. OSLO. AYE EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER
AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE. AYE
ADORNO. AYE. JONES AYE. LAIRD.
AYE. LEMON. AYE MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR. AYE MINH. AYE. NEUMAN.
NGUYEN NILO. AYE. OKOBO PADILLA.
AYE. PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH. AYE.
RUBIO AYE. SATO. AYE. SKINNER
AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS STERN. AYE.
UMBERG AYE. WAHAB. AYE. WIENER
AYE. WILK. AYE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALAN ARCHULETA.
MCGUIRE NEWMAN. NGUYEN. OKOBO.
AYE SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS. AYE.
AYES 35. NO ZERO. MEASURE
PASSES. SEN. PADILLA ARE YOU
PREPARED FOR ITEM 32? HE IS
READY. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1070 BY SENATOR
PADILLA. AN ACT RELATING TO
STATE GOVERNMENT. THANK YOU,
MADAM PRESIDENT AND COLLEAGUES.
ACCESS TO INTELLECTUAL TALENT,
ESPECIALLY IN EMERGING SCIENCE
AND TECHNOLOGY FIELDS, IS
CRUCIAL FOR CALIFORNIA'S
GOVERNMENT AND THE ECONOMIC
GROWTH OF OUR STATE. CALIFORNIA
HAS TAKEN IMPORTANT STRIDES TO
KEEP OUR TECHNOLOGY WORKFORCE
COMPETITIVE, BUT THERE CONTINUE
TO BE CHALLENGES BY ONE RECENT
COUNT. WHILE 60% OF NEW PHD
GRADUATES SPECIALIZING IN
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE CHOSE TO
WORK IN INDUSTRY AND ABOUT A
QUARTER ENTERED ACADEMIA, LESS
THAN 2% DECIDED TO WORK IN
GOVERNMENT. IN 2023, NEARLY 8 IN
10 STATE CHIEF INFORMATION
OFFICERS SAID THEY LACK THE
WORKFORCE NECESSARY TO MEET
THEIR CURRENT NEEDS. IN SHORT,
TECHNOLOGICAL EXPERTISE IS
CONCENTRATED IN OUR UNIVERSITIES
AND OUR COMPANIES AND NOT IN OUR
GOVERNMENT. SB 1070 WOULD
ADDRESS THIS EXPERTISE GAP BY
LEVERAGING AN EXISTING MODEL OF
TALENT EXCHANGES BETWEEN
GOVERNMENT AND HIGHER
INSTITUTIONS OF EDUCATION TO
PROVIDE STATE AGENCIES WITH
ACCESS TO THE DEEP WELLS OF
EXPERIENCE BASED IN CALIFORNIA'S
WORLD CLASS UNIVERSITIES AND
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. THIS BILL
WOULD CLARIFY THAT BOTH PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES AND NONPROFIT
PRIVATE INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER
EDUCATION ARE ELIGIBLE FOR
PARTICIPATION IN THESE TALENT
EXCHANGES, AND I WOULD
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR.
SENATOR CUEVAS, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MADAM
PRESIDENT. I WANT TO THANK THE
GOOD SENATOR FROM IMPERIAL
VALLEY FOR RAISING THAT. I GOT
THAT RIGHT. RIGHT. AND SAN DIEGO
IN SAN DIEGO, FOR, FOR THIS
BILL, IT CAME THROUGH COMMITTEE.
AND IT'S SO IMPORTANT IN TERMS
OF ADDRESSING SOME OF OUR
SHORTAGES, MY QUESTION, IF I MAY
ASK A QUESTION. WOULD THE AUTHOR
TAKE A QUESTION? YES. IN
COMMITTEE, WE TALKED ABOUT
POTENTIAL AMENDMENTS FOR US TO
HAVE A DISCLOSURE PROCESS FOR
THESE INDIVIDUALS WHO WILL BE
COMING LARGELY FROM ACADEMIA AND
STEPPING INTO TO THIS PUBLIC,
CIVIL SERVICE ROLE, ARE YOU,
CONTINUE WILLING TO CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH ME ON ENSURING THAT
THERE IS A DISCLOSURE FOR US TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT UNIVERSITY
RESEARCH UNITS THEY'RE COMING
FROM AND WHETHER WE CAN SEE SOME
OF THE ANNUAL REPORTS THAT ARE
PRODUCED BY THOSE PARTICULAR
RESEARCH UNITS, SO THAT WE KNOW
THAT WE ARE BUILDING THE
WORKFORCE, BUT WE'RE BUILDING
THE WORKFORCE WITH EXPERTISE
THAT WANTS TO ENSURE THAT WE
HAVE A STRONG CIVIL SERVICE
PROGRAM AND PUBLIC SECTOR
OVERALL. MADAM PRESIDENT AND
SENATOR, ABSOLUTELY. I KNOW THAT
OUR OFFICES HAVE BEEN ENGAGED IN
AN ONGOING DIALOG AT THE STAFF
LEVEL WITH DIFFERENT VERSIONS OF
BROADER LANGUAGE THAN IS
CURRENTLY REQUIRED BY LAW, SOME
OF THE MOST BROAD THAT COULD BE,
AND I AM COMMITTED TO CONTINUING
TO WORK TOGETHER TO TRY TO GET
AT THAT CONCERN. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. WE WANT TO MAKE SURE WE'RE
NOT OUTSOURCING JOBS, BUT THAT
WE'RE BRINGING IN FOLKS WHO WANT
TO CONTINUE TO BUILD THE PUBLIC
SECTOR. AND THANK YOU. WITH
THAT, I'LL I DON'T KNOW WHAT I
SAY AT THIS POINT. THANK YOU.
WE'LL WORK TOGETHER WITH THE
SENATOR ON THAT. THANK YOU.
SENATOR, IS THERE ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON FILE
ITEM 32? A SEEING NONE. SENATOR
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NIVO.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALAN ALVARADO GILL. THIS ITEM IS
ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
. DO WE HAVE ANY OBJECTION? AYES
36. NO. ZERO. MEASURE PASSES. AS
WE HEARD BEFORE, THERE ARE
CERTAIN ITEMS THAT HAVE A
SPECIFIC TIME STAMP. WE HAVE
DONE ALL THAT WE WERE ABLE TO DO
SO FAR. SO AFTER THIS, WE WILL
BE RECESSING UNTIL FOR 15, WE
ARE IN RECESS UNTIL 415. PLEASE
STAY ON THE FLOOR. WE ARE NOT
ABLE TO LEAVE. THERE IS PIE IN
THE BREAK ROOM. YEAH, I WAS TOLD
THAT THERE IS FIVE, BUT I WAS
TOLD TO SAY IT. THANK YOU FOR
THE NINE MINUTES.
MEMBERS. THE SENATE IS BACK IN
SESSION. OUR FIRST BILL UP IS A
BILL BY SENATOR STERN, THIS
WOULD BE FILE ITEM 33, SENATE
BILL 1283. SECRETARY PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL 1283 BY SENATOR
STERN. AN ACT RELATING TO PUPILS
. SENATOR STERN, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. MEMBERS, PLEASE GIVE
SENATOR STERN YOUR ATTENTION.
FOR THOSE OF YOU HERE, A FEW
MEMBERS OF YOU HERE CAN CONSULT
THE VIDEO FOOTAGE IF YOU'D LIKE.
THIS IS A REALLY IMPORTANT PIECE
OF LEGISLATION, SOCIAL MEDIA USE
AMONG YOUNG PEOPLE IS NEARLY
UNIVERSAL. NOW, IF YOU'RE NOT ON
IT, YOU'RE LEFT OUT. YOU'RE NOT
A PART OF THE CONVERSATION. NOW,
THERE MIGHT NOT BE ACTUAL
PHYSICAL CONVERSATIONS GOING ON
IN REAL LIFE, BUT THE
CONVERSATION IS ALL HAPPENING ON
SNAPCHAT, ON YOUR MESSENGER APP,
ON DISCORD, AND IT'S BEGUN TO
COMPLETELY DISPLACE HUMAN
RELATIONSHIPS. WE KNOW THE
STATS, BUT I'LL REPEAT THEM TO
YOU. THE US SURGEON GENERAL, IN
HIS 2023 SOCIAL MEDIA HEALTH
ADVISORY, CITES THE CHILDREN AND
ADOLESCENTS WHO SPEND MORE THAN
THREE HOURS A DAY ON SOCIAL
MEDIA. THEY FACE TWICE THE RISK
OF THE MENTAL HEALTH PROBLEMS
THAT A KID WHO DOESN'T
DEPRESSION, ANXIETY, SUICIDE ALL
SKYROCKETING. 2022 SURVEY FOUND
THAT AMERICAN TEENAGERS SPENT AN
AVERAGE OF 3.5 HOURS A DAY ON
SOCIAL MEDIA, NOT JUST ON THEIR
PHONE, BUT ON SOCIAL MEDIA. WHAT
THAT DOES TO BRAIN DEVELOPMENT,
BODY IMAGE, PERSONAL GROWTH,
LITERACY. IT'S TRULY AN
EPIDEMIC. AND FRANKLY, IT GOT A
LOT WORSE DURING THE PANDEMIC
WHERE WE JUST GAVE EVERYONE A
SCREEN AND LEFT THEM AT HOME AND
SAID, GOOD LUCK. THIS BILL, I
ACTUALLY WISH IT IT DID BAN
SOCIAL MEDIA IN SCHOOLS, BUT IT
DOESN'T, THIS BILL MERELY TELLS
SCHOOL BOARDS ACROSS THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA THAT THEY MAY
ADOPT A SOCIAL MEDIA POLICY.
NOW, THAT COULD INCLUDE A
RESTRICTION OF SOCIAL MEDIA
ALTOGETHER. IT COULD INCLUDE A
BAN. IT COULD JUST SAY RULES OF
THE ROAD FOR HOW YOU HAVE TO
BEHAVE ON SOCIAL MEDIA COULD BE
THE DISABLING OF CERTAIN APPS.
WHEN YOU'RE ON CAMPUS, IT DOES
NOT REQUIRE THEM TO TAKE AWAY
STUDENTS PHONES, AND WE KNOW FOR
SOME PARENTS THAT'S VERY
IMPORTANT. AND FOR SOME
CONSIDERED A LIFELINE. SO THIS
BILL IS PRETTY SIMPLE IN THAT IT
MERELY MAKES CLEAR TO EVERY
SCHOOL BOARD IN YOUR DISTRICTS
THAT THEY CAN ADOPT A SOCIAL
MEDIA POLICY. THE BILL ALSO
MAKES CLEAR THAT SHOULD A SCHOOL
BOARD DECIDE TO ADOPT A POLICY
THAT DOES RESTRICT THAT SOCIAL
MEDIA USE, THAT THAT DOESN'T
GIVE THE SCHOOL PRINCIPAL, THE
TEACHER, CARTE BLANCHE TO SEARCH
EVERY KID'S PHONE, THAT THEY
STILL HAVE CERTAIN PRIVACY
RIGHTS. UNDER THE CALIFORNIA
ELECTRONIC COMMUNICATIONS
PRIVACY ACT DOESN'T ALLOW THEM
TO SURVEIL YOUR KID. OR DIG INTO
PLACES. WE'VE TALKED A LOT ABOUT
OUTING OF YOUNG PEOPLE AND THAT
BEING AN ONGOING ISSUE. THIS
DOESN'T ALLOW SCHOOLS TO DO ANY
OF THAT, BUT AT LEAST HAS THAT
DISCLOSURE THAT YOUNG PEOPLE DO
HAVE CERTAIN RIGHTS. BUT BUT THE
MOST IMPORTANT THING THEY CAN
POSSIBLY DO AT SCHOOL IS LEARN.
AND NOT JUST LEARN FROM A BOOK,
BUT LEARN FROM EACH OTHER. AND
IT'S VERY, VERY HARD TO BE THAT
STUDENT WHOSE PARENT SAYS, OH,
YOU DON'T HAVE A FACEBOOK
ACCOUNT. YOU'RE NOT THE ONE ON
INSTAGRAM. EVERYONE ELSE IN YOUR
SCHOOL IS, BUT YOU'RE NOT.
YOU'RE THE ODD PERSON OUT. YOU
HAVE TO FEEL THAT OUTSIDER OR
THAT PARIAH FEELING THAT ARE
THEY TALKING ABOUT ME BEHIND MY
BACK ON SNAPCHAT? WHY ARE THEY
ALL LAUGHING AND LOOKING AT ME?
I'M NOT EVEN ON THE APP. THAT
FOMO THOSE THOSE FEELINGS THAT
THAT PEER PRESSURE THAT EMERGES.
WE WANT TO REMOVE THAT FROM THE
FORMULA, FROM THE EQUATION IN
SCHOOLS. AND REALLY, WHAT WE'VE
SEEN IN SCHOOLS THAT HAVE TAKEN
THIS LEAP IS INITIALLY THERE'S A
LOT OF CONCERN. STUDENTS AREN'T
HAPPY, THEY CAN'T TAKE A VIDEO
OF THEIR CLASSMATE AND POST IT
ON SNAP OF SOMETHING THEY WERE
DOING IN CLASS, OR MAKE A LITTLE
COMMENT ON A SIDE MESSAGING CHAT
ABOUT THEIR TEACHER, THE PARENTS
ARE WORRIED. HOW WILL I KEEP
TRACK OF MY KID IF I DON'T SEE
WHAT THEY'RE POSTING, BUT WHAT
WE FOUND IN SOME OF THESE BRAVE
PILOT PROGRAMS THAT ARE GOING ON
BECAUSE EXISTING LAW REALLY DOES
ALLOW THIS, JUST THAT SCHOOLS
AREN'T TAKING THAT LEAP. BUT
WHAT WE FOUND IS THAT PEOPLE
PICK THEIR HEADS UP, HOLD THEIR
HEADS AWAY FROM THAT SCREEN.
YOUNG PEOPLE START TO LOOK AT
EACH OTHER, START TO GO THROUGH
ALL THOSE UNCOMFORTABLE MOMENTS.
WE ALL NEED TO FEEL AS YOUNG
PEOPLE GROWING UP OF, YOU KNOW,
FEELINGS OF REJECTION OR
FEELINGS OF PRAISE, AS DOES THAT
THAT PERSON I LIKE IN CLASS WANT
TO TALK TO ME OR NOT. ALL THOSE
TOUGH PARTS OF GROWING UP THAT
KIND OF MAKE YOU INTO A MORE
DURABLE AND REAL PERSON, AS
OPPOSED TO SOMEONE WHO CAN JUST
HIDE BEHIND THAT SCREEN AND HAVE
IT DISPLACE ALL SOCIAL
RELATIONSHIPS. SO I HOPE WITH
THIS VERY SIMPLE BILL, WE GET
THAT CONVERSATION STARTED IN A
HURRY, AND I HOPE SCHOOL BOARDS
ACROSS THE STATE BEAT US TO THE
PUNCH AND GET GOING. BUT I DO
APPRECIATE CALIFORNIA TEACHERS
ASSOCIATION FOR SIGNING ON TO
THE MEASURE. I APPRECIATE OUR
WORK WITH THE LGBTQ CAUCUS AND
ACLU TO MAKE SURE THAT, AGAIN,
THIS WON'T BE USED AS A TOOL FOR
OUTING YOUNG PEOPLE OR VIOLATING
PRIVACY RIGHTS. BUT MORE THAN
ANYTHING, WE WANT OUR SCHOOLS,
OUR TEACHERS, TO BE EMPOWERED TO
DO THE WORK THAT WE KNOW THEY
NEED TO DO. AND THAT'S VERY
HARD, IS TO DIG OUR KIDS OUT OF
THIS MENTAL HEALTH CRISIS.
THAT'S THE PANDEMIC. AFTER THE
PANDEMIC AND START TO BE
STUDENTS AGAIN. SO WITH THAT, I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I VOTE
. THANK YOU, SENATOR STERN.
OPPORTUNITY FOR DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE. I SEE THREE MICROPHONES
UP, SENATOR DOLLY, SENATOR
BECKER, SENATOR RUBIO, WE'LL
BEGIN WITH SENATOR DOLLY. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL. I WANTED TO
JUST TAKE A FEW SECONDS JUST TO
MAYBE GIVE A LITTLE PERSPECTIVE.
AND THIS THIS BILL BASICALLY
GIVES, YOU KNOW, THE LEAS THE
OPPORTUNITY AND I AND I WILL SAY
THAT I HAVE TWO OLDER SONS, 24
AND 22, AND I HAVE A TEN YEAR
OLD DAUGHTER. AND THE DIFFERENCE
IN THAT TEN YEARS, AND WHAT
WE'VE SEEN WITH THE SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORMS IN THE AND EVERYBODY
HAS ONE AND WE HAD A POLICY AT
OUR HOUSE THAT YOU COULDN'T HAVE
A PHONE UNTIL YOU WERE AT LEAST
13, OR YOU COULD READ A BOOK AND
GIVE ME A BOOK REPORT ON IT AND
GIVE A SPEECH TO MY
SATISFACTION, AND THEN MAYBE WE
MIGHT GIVE YOU A PHONE. BUT THAT
CHANGED WITH OUR DAUGHTER,
BECAUSE LITERALLY EVERYBODY HAD
A DEVICE AND WE WANTED TO BE
ABLE TO COMMUNICATE AS WELL. BUT
AT SCHOOL I THINK THIS IS A IS A
GOOD BILL TO SAY. AND IN SOME
SCHOOLS, SOME TEACHERS REQUIRED
THEM TO PUT IT IN THE, YOU KNOW,
CUBBY HOLE OR WHATEVER AND GET
IT AFTER CLASS AND SOME DON'T.
AND FOR ME, I WANT MY CHILD TO
GET EDUCATED WHEN THEY'RE THERE.
AND THAT MEANS PAYING ATTENTION
TO THE TEACHER ALSO WORKING IN
GROUPS WITH THEIR WITH THEIR
PEERS. SO FOR THOSE REASONS, I'M
GOING TO SUPPORT THIS BILL. I
THINK IT'S A GOOD COMMONSENSE
BILL. I THINK IT ALLOWS THE
SCHOOL BOARDS TO ENGAGE AND MAKE
SOME GOOD POLICY AROUND AT THE
LOCAL LEVEL AS WELL. SO THANK
YOU FOR BRINGING THE BILL
FORWARD, AND I'LL BE SUPPORTING
IT AS WELL AND URGE THAT I VOTE
ON IT. THANK YOU, SENATOR DOLLY.
SENATOR BECKER. YEAH, I'LL JUST
BE BE QUICK. I YOU KNOW, I HAVE
A SON IN HIGH SCHOOL AND I JUST
ASSUME THAT PHONES WERE BANNED
IN, IN SCHOOL. I JUST ASSUME AND
I TEXTED LIKE, HE TEXTED ME
RIGHT BACK AND THEN, LIKE, ASK
HIM ABOUT A BASEBALL GAME, AND
HE'S TELLING ME, OH, YEAH, I SAW
THE SCORE. LIKE, WAIT, I JUST
WAS VERY CONFUSED. I THOUGHT
THEY WERE BANNED. SO I DO HAVE A
COUPLE SCHOOLS IN MY DISTRICT
THAT ARE USING THE LOCK AWAY
DEVICES THAT HAVE BEEN
SUCCESSFUL SO FAR, MY BOOK CLUB,
WE JUST READ THE ANXIOUS
GENERATION, JONATHAN HAYDEN'S
NEW BOOK, AND I REALLY HOPE THAT
WE DO, FIND A WAY TO DO, YOU
KNOW, EVEN GO THE NEXT STEP. BUT
I'LL CERTAINLY SUPPORT THIS
BILL. I APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU, SENATOR.
SENATOR RUBIO, THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE, I ALSO
RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT OF SB
1283. I THINK IT'S CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT BECAUSE STUDENTS
SHOULD BE FULLY FOCUSED IN THE
CLASSROOM, AND WE'RE FINDING
THAT THEY'RE JUST NOT. AND I
BELIEVE THE GREAT SENATOR JUST
STATED THAT THAT, YOU KNOW, KIDS
ARE ANSWERING IN REAL TIME. SO
WHAT DOES THAT TELL YOU? THAT
INSTEAD OF FOCUSING ON THE
LESSON AT HAND, THEY'RE TEXT
MESSAGING THEIR FRIENDS, THEIR
PARENTS AND THAT'S NOT HOW
STUDENTS LEARN. AND I HAVE TO
SAY, WHEN IT COMES TO
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES, THAT
IS A REAL CONCERN BECAUSE SOME
OF THESE STUDENTS GO HOME AND
THEY PERHAPS DON'T HAVE PARENTS
AT HOME THAT COULD SIT WITH
THEM, DO HOMEWORK WITH THEM,
TUTOR THEM. THEY DON'T HAVE THE
FINANCIAL MEANS TO LATER ON GET
A TUTOR WHEN THEY'RE FALLING
BEHIND. THAT IS THE ONLY
EDUCATION THEY'RE GOING TO GET.
THEY NEED TO BE FULLY ENGAGED
AND IT'S GETTING HARDER AND
HARDER. I'M A CLASSROOM TEACHER.
I KNOW WHAT THAT LOOK LIKE. YOU
KNOW, I USED TO ENCOURAGE MY
STUDENTS TO PUT IT THEIR PHONES
IN THE BACKPACK BECAUSE THEY
WERE GOING OFF EVERY SINGLE
MINUTE OF THE DAY. AND THAT ALSO
TAKES AWAY FROM SOME OTHER CHILD
THAT WANTS TO FOCUS ON WHAT'S
GOING ON IN THE CLASSROOM. SO I
THINK THAT THIS IS A VERY SIMPLE
BILL THAT JUST ALLOWS SCHOOL
DISTRICTS TO ADOPT POLICIES. AND
THE MORE THAT WE SEE ON THE
INTERNET, THE WORSE IT'S GOING
TO GET. YOU KNOW, THE SENATOR
FROM SANTA MONICA, I THINK, OR
CALABASAS JUST MENTIONED THAT,
YOU KNOW, HE TALKED ABOUT THE
HOURS THAT STUDENTS SPEND ON
SOCIAL MEDIA. AND THAT IS A
CONCERN. WE'RE SEEING MORE AND
MORE, YOU KNOW, WHAT'S HAPPENING
IN SOCIAL MEDIA. I'VE BEEN
TACKLING HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND
OTHER, YOU KNOW, CRIMES AGAINST
CHILDREN. AND THIS IS THE
PLATFORMS WHERE SOMETIMES THESE
PREDATORS KEEP LURING OUR
CHILDREN INTO DOING THINGS THAT,
YOU KNOW, AGAINST THEIR WILL.
AND SOME OF THEM DISAPPEAR AND
ARE NEVER SEEN. I'M JUST
EXPRESSING HOW DANGEROUS SOCIAL
MEDIA IS, AT THE VERY LEAST,
SCHOOL DISTRICTS SHOULD BE ABLE
TO PUT SOME POLICIES IN PLACE
WHERE WE'RE KEEPING OUR KIDS
SAFE. AT LEAST DURING SCHOOL
HOURS, AND THAT THEY'RE FOCUSED
ON WHAT SCHOOL IS ALL ABOUT, AND
THAT IS TO LEARN. AND AGAIN, I
WILL ARGUE THAT YOU KNOW, I KNOW
THERE WAS CONCERNS BY SOME
ORGANIZATIONS ABOUT, YOU KNOW,
LOW INCOME COMMUNITIES. AND I
WOULD ARGUE THAT THOSE ARE THE
ONES THAT SUFFER THE MOST
BECAUSE THEY DON'T HAVE ALL THE
RESOURCES THAT MORE AFFLUENT
COMMUNITIES HAVE. AND WE NEED TO
MAKE SURE THAT KIDS ARE
LEARNING. THEY GO HOME AND
UNDERSTAND THE MATERIAL. AND I
JUST WOULD URGE EVERYONE TO
CONSIDER THAT THIS IS GOING TO
CONTINUE TO BE AN EVEN BIGGER
PROBLEM AS SOCIAL MEDIA
CONTINUES TO EVOLVE. I REMEMBER
AS A TEACHER GOING TO THE
PLAYGROUND AND WATCHING KIDS
GATHER AROUND A PHONE, YOU KNOW
SOMETHING'S HAPPENING RIGHT?
WELL, THEY WERE VIEWING AN
INAPPROPRIATE PICTURE OF ANOTHER
STUDENT AND I HAD TO TAKE THE
PHONE AWAY. THIS HAPPENS ALL THE
TIME. I HAPPEN TO CATCH THAT
MOMENT. BUT WE DON'T ALWAYS SEE
THAT. SO I HOPE THAT PEOPLE
REALLY CONSIDER THAT THIS IS
IMPORTANT FOR THE SAFETY OF OUR
STUDENTS, FOR THE EDUCATION OF
OUR STUDENTS. AND THOSE THAT
DON'T HAVE FINANCIAL MEANS ARE
THE ONES THAT SUFFER THE MOST.
WITH THAT, I ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
SENATOR. ANY OTHER MEMBER
WISHING TO BE HEARD ON THIS BILL
SEEING NONE. SENATOR STERN, YOU
MAY CLOSE. THANKS FOR THE ROBUST
CONVERSATION, COLLEAGUES. I
THINK BEFORE I WAS A DAD, I
DIDN'T FULLY UNDERSTAND. BUT NOW
WITH A TWO AND A ONE YEAR OLD
FEELING A DUTY TO SOMEHOW FIX
THE INTERNET BEFORE IT'S TIME
FOR THEM TO JUMP INTO JUMP INTO
SCHOOL, I MAY BE TOO HIGH OF A
BAR, BUT FOR EVERY PARENT AND
STUDENT TEACHER SCHOOL BOARD,
OFFICIAL ADMINISTRATOR OUT
THERE, WE'RE HOPING THAT THIS IS
THE NUDGE AND THE AUTHORIZATION
TO GET STARTED. IT'S NOT OKAY TO
JUST SAY IT'S NOT OUR PROBLEM
AND THAT THIS ISN'T OUR ISSUE.
IT'S ALL OF OUR ISSUE. IN THAT
RESPECT, I. MEMBERS, WE'RE GOING
TO GO ONE TIME THROUGH THE ROLE
AND THEN PUT IT ON CALL. WE HAVE
MEMBERS OFF THE FLOOR. SO
SECRETARY ALL DEBATE HAVING
CEASED. PLEASE CALL THE ROLE
OAN ALVARADO GILB. AYE.
ARCHULETA ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS.
AYE. BECKER AYE. BLAKE. SPEER.
AYE. BRADFORD. AYE CABALLERO.
AYE. CORTEZ DALLI. AYE. DODD.
DURAZZO. AYE EGGMAN. AYE.
GLAZER. AYE. GONZALEZ AYE.
GROVE. AYE. HURTADO AYE. JONES.
AYE LAIRD. AYE. LIMON AYE
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR. AYE MINH.
AYE. NEWMAN. NGUYEN NILO. AYE.
JOAO I NGUYEN AYE. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SATO. AYE SKINNER. AYE.
SMALL. CUEVAS STERN. AYE.
UMBERG. AYE WAHAB. AYE. WIENER
WILK. AYE. SENATOR STERN MOVES A
CALL. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT
TO FILE ITEM 23. THIS IS SENATE
BILL 936 BY SENATOR SATO.
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL 936 BY SENATOR SATO. AN ACT
RELATING TO TRANSPORTATION,
SENATOR SATO. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I STAND HERE TO
PRESENT SB 936. SO, AS WE ALL
KNOW, CAR CRASHES ARE
CONSISTENTLY A TOP CAUSE OF
UNINTENTIONAL INJURY OR DEATH
FOR CALIFORNIANS. AND EACH YEAR,
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE LOSE THEIR
LIVES OR SUFFER LIFE CHANGING
INJURIES IN AUTOMOBILE
COLLISIONS. CALIFORNIA'S TRAFFIC
FATALITIES SURGED 22% FROM 2019
TO 2022, WHILE SEVERE AND FATAL
TRAFFIC ACCIDENTS HAVE RESULTED
IN $166 BILLION IN ECONOMIC AND
QUALITY OF LIFE COSTS FOR
CALIFORNIANS IN 2022 ALONE.
RECENTLY, A DEVASTATING CRASH
INVOLVED A DRUNK DRIVER SPEEDING
AT 104 MILES AN HOUR IN A 45
MILE PER HOUR ZONE, CLAIMING THE
LIVES OF FOUR PEPPERDINE
UNIVERSITY STUDENTS ON THE
PACIFIC COAST HIGHWAY. ALSO
INFAMOUSLY INFAMOUSLY KNOWN AS
DEAD MAN'S CURVE, MY BILL
REQUIRES THE OFFICE OF PLANNING
AND RESEARCH IN COORDINATION
WITH THE DEPARTMENT OF
TRANSPORTATION, TO CONDUCT A
STUDY THAT WILL, MOST
IMPORTANTLY, IDENTIFY THE TOP 15
LOCATIONS WITH THE HIGHEST RATES
OF VEHICLE COLLISIONS AND
IDENTIFY PROJECTS THAT WOULD
IMPROVE ROAD SAFETY AT EACH OF
THE IDENTIFIED SIDE LOCATIONS
WITH THIS REPORT, THE
LEGISLATURE CAN EXAMINE MEANS OF
ADDRESSING THESE LOCATIONS AND
HOW TO BEST EXPEDITE ROAD SAFETY
IMPROVEMENTS. SB 936 WILL
PROVIDE A PLAN TO ADDRESS OUR
MOST DANGEROUS HIGHWAYS, WHILE
GIVING THE LEGISLATURE CRUCIAL,
CRUCIAL INFORMATION NEEDED TO
HELP SAVE LIVES. THIS BILL HAS
EARNED BIPARTISAN SUPPORT. I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
MEASURE, ANY SENATOR WISHING TO
BE HEARD. SEEING NONE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ELON I'LL RODA-GIL. AYE.
ARCHULETA ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS.
AYE BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPERM. I
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO AYE.
CORTEZ. AYE. DALLY AYE. DODD.
DURAZZO. AYE EGGMAN. GLASER.
AYE. GONZALEZ AYE. GROVE. AYE OR
DATO. AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD
AYE. LEMON AYE. MCGUIRE.
MENGIBAR. AYE MINH. AYE. NEWMAN.
NGUYEN AYE. NILO. AYE. OKOBO
AYE. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO
AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO. AYE SATO
AYE. SKINNER AYE. SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS AYE. STERN. AYE. UMBERG
AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER. AYE.
WILK AYE. WE HAVE A FULL HOUSE
NOW, SO WE'RE GOING TO GO
THROUGH THE RULE ONE MORE TIME.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN ARCHULETA,
DODD EGGMAN. AYE. MCGUIRE NEWMAN
. AYES 35. NÓ ZERO. THE MEASURE
PASSES. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE NEXT
TO FILE ITEM 34. THIS IS SENATE
BILL 1075 BY SENATOR BRADFORD.
SECRETARY PLEASE READ SENATE
AN ACT RELATING TO CREDIT
UNIONS. SENATOR BRADFORD, THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. 1075 WILL
ESTABLISH A BASIC CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS FOR CALIFORNIANS WHO
ARE MEMBERS OF STATE CHARTER
CREDIT UNIONS. 1075 WILL CREATE
NEW AND NECESSARY SAFEGUARDS
FROM OVERDRAFT AND
NON-SUFFICIENT FUNDS FEES BY
CAPPING THOSE FEES AT $14, OR
THE AMOUNT SET BY THE CONSUMER
FINANCIAL PROTECTION BUREAU,
WHICHEVER IS LOWER. THE BILL
ALSO REQUIRES CREDIT UNIONS TO
IMPLEMENT A GRACE PERIOD OF
THREE BUSINESS DAYS FOR
CONSUMERS TO PAY BACK ANY
OVERDRAFT AMOUNT BEFORE FEES IS
CHARGED. THIS BILL HAS BEEN
AMENDED AND AMENDED TO ADDRESS
CONCERNS FROM THE CREDIT UNIONS
BY REDUCING THE GRACE PERIOD
FROM FIVE DAYS TO THREE BUSINESS
DAYS, REMOVING THE LIMIT OF THE
AMOUNT OF FEES THAT CAN BE
CHARGED PER MONTH, AND DELAYING
IMPLEMENTATION FOR SMALLER
CREDIT UNIONS, OVERDRAFT AND
NONSUFFICIENT FUND FEES
DISPROPORTIONATELY AFFECT THOSE
WHO CAN AFFORD THEM. THE LEASE
AND THE CFPB ESTIMATES 80% OF
OVERDRAFT FEES COME FROM JUST 9%
OF THE ACCOUNT HOLDERS. INDUSTRY
WIDE DATA FROM THE FIRST EVER
ANNUAL REPORT OF INCOME FROM
NON-SUFFICIENT FUNDS AND
OVERDRAFT FEES WAS RELEASED IN
MARCH OF LAST YEAR. THANKS TO MY
COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA BARBARA'S,
BILL SB 1415 FROM 2022. THIS
REPORT REVEALED THAT 28 STATE
CHARTERED CREDIT UNIONS GENERATE
40% OR MORE OF THEIR NET INCOME
FROM THESE FEES. ADDITIONALLY,
SIX CREDIT UNIONS GENERATE MORE
THAN 100% OF THEIR NET INCOME
FROM THESE FEES. CURRENTLY,
THERE'S NO LIMITS ON HOW MUCH A
CREDIT UNION CAN CHARGE FOR
THESE FEES, AND RIGHT NOW, SOME
CREDIT UNION MEMBERS CAN
OVERDRAFT BY $1 AND GET A $35
CHARGE. ALTHOUGH OVERDRAFT IS
VIEWED AS A FINANCIAL TOOL BY
CREDIT UNIONS, ITS FEES ARE
INHERENTLY PREDATORY AND
TARGETED FINANCIALLY VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIANS AS FORMER CHAIR OF
SENATE BANKING A NUMBER OF YEARS
AGO, ONE OF THE BIGGEST ISSUES
WE DEALT WITH WAS ONLINE LENDING
AND PAYDAY LOANS AND THE
EXORBITANT FEES. THESE ARE JUST
AS HIGH, IF NOT HIGHER. WHILE
THE INDUSTRY SAYS OVERDRAFT, IT
IS A BENEFIT TO THEIR MEMBERS.
IT'S REALLY A BENEFIT TO THE
COMPANY'S BOTTOM LINE. AND WE'RE
NOT ALONE IN TACKLING THIS
ISSUE. AGAIN, THE CFPB IS
CONSIDERING A RULE TO CAP THESE
FEES BETWEEN $3 AND $14, BUT
ONLY FOR INSTITUTIONS THAT HAVE
A $10 BILLION IN ASSETS OR MORE,
WHICH TO DATE WOULD ONLY AFFECT
ONLY TWO CREDIT UNIONS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA. BUT
CALIFORNIA SHOULD NOT WAIT FOR
THE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT TO TAKE
ACTION. THAT MAY NOT HAPPEN WHEN
WE CAN TAKE ACTION AND TO LEAD,
TO ESTABLISH, I SHOULD SAY,
BASIC CONSUMER PROTECTIONS FOR
MEMBERS OF ALL STATE CHARTERED
CREDIT UNIONS, NOT JUST THE
LARGE ONES. SO ON THAT NOTE, I
THANK YOU FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY
AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR I VOTE.
SENATOR LAIRD, A QUESTION OF THE
AUTHOR. WILL THE AUTHOR TAKE A
QUESTION? YES YOU WILL, YOU
MENTIONED THAT A COUPLE OF THE
AMENDMENTS WERE TAKEN AT THE
REQUEST OF THE CREDIT UNION
LEAGUE. DID THEY THEN REMOVE
THEIR OPPOSITION? NO, THEY
HAVEN'T. OKAY. THANK YOU.
SENATOR RUBIO, YOU'RE RECOGNIZED
. A QUESTION TO THE AUTHOR,
PLEASE. WILL THE AUTHOR TAKE
ANOTHER QUESTION? YES, I JUST
HEARD THE QUESTION FROM THE
SENATOR FROM MONTEREY BAY. I
HOPE I GOT IT RIGHT, AND THEY
DID. AND CAN YOU SHARE SOME OF
THOSE AMENDMENTS THAT YOU'VE
TAKEN? SO WE KNOW WHAT THOSE
ARE? YES. WE ELIMINATED WE
REDUCED THE GRACE PERIOD, A
WAITING PERIOD, I SHOULD SAY,
FROM FIVE DAYS TO THREE DAYS. WE
REMOVED THE LIMITS ON THE FEES
THAT CAN BE CHARGED, AND WE ARE
DELAYING THE IMPLEMENTATION ON
THE SMALLER FEES. AND WE'RE
STILL IN NEGOTIATIONS ON
REMOVING THE GRACE PERIOD
ALTOGETHER. SO IS IT THE GRACE
PERIOD? IS IT SOMETHING THAT YOU
INTEND TO REMOVE OR YOU'RE STILL
? WHEN I HEAR NEGOTIATIONS, IT
FEELS LIKE YOU'RE NOT QUITE
THERE YET. WE'RE GETTING CLOSE.
OKAY. SO, YOU KNOW, I APPRECIATE
THE SENATOR, JUST BEING OPEN TO
DISCUSSION AND CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH THE BILL. I KNOW THAT HE'S
ALREADY DONE A LOT OF WORK ON
THIS, WHICH REALLY, YOU KNOW,
I'M IMPRESSED BY. SO THANK YOU
FOR THAT CLARIFICATION. AND THAT
WOULD BE ALL. THANK YOU. ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
FILE ITEM 34? SENATOR BRADFORD,
YOU MAY CLOSE, AS STATED, WE'RE
COMMITTED TO WORKING ON THIS
BILL IS FAR FROM A WORKING,
COMPLETED WORK. IT'S A WORK IN
PROGRESS, THE, WE'RE WORKING
WITH THE CREDIT UNIONS TO FIND A
WORKABLE SOLUTION THAT WILL,
ESPECIALLY PROTECT THE SMALL
CREDIT UNIONS AND ON THAT NOTE,
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALI. AYE, RODRIGO. ARCHULETA.
ASHBY. AYE AYE. ATKINS. AYE.
BECKER BLAKE. AYE. BRADFORD AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLI NØ. DODD. DURAZZO AYE.
EGGMAN. AYE. GLASER GONZALEZ.
AYE AYE. GROVE HURTADO. AYE.
JONES NO. LAIRD. LIMÓN AYE.
MCGUIRE JABBAR I MEN I NEWMAN.
NGUYEN. NO. NILO NO. AQUEBOGUE.
NO. PADILLA AYE. PORTANTINO ROTH
. RUBIO SATO. NO. SKINNER AYE.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS AYE. STERN
AYE. UMMER. AYE. WAHAB WIENER.
AYE. WILK, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN. ALVARADO.
GILL ARCHULETA. BECKER AYE.
DODD. GLASER GROVE. LAIRD.
GROVE. NO LAIRD. MCGUIRE NEWMAN.
PORTANTINO ROTH. RUBIO. WAHAB
AYE. WILK.
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME.
ALLEN. AYE. RODRIGO ARCHULETA.
DODD GLASER. LAIRD. MCGUIRE.
NEWMAN PORTANTINO. ROTH RUBIO.
AYE WILK. AYE AYES 23. NO SEVEN.
THE MEASURE PASSES. NEXT UP, WE
HAVE SENATOR RUBIO. RAFEAL. ITEM
24. IS THE SENATOR PREPARED
SECRETARY, PLEASE READ. SENATE
BILL 1054 BY SENATOR RUBIO, AN
ACT RELATING TO ENERGY. SENATOR.
THANK YOU, MADAM PRESIDENT.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN OF THE
SENATE, TODAY I RISE TO PRESENT
SENATE BILL 1054. THIS BILL
REQUIRED UTILITY PROCEEDS TO BE
USED EXCLUSIVELY FOR THE BENEFIT
OF CONSUMERS. I AM COMMITTED TO
CONTINUING TO WORK WITH
STAKEHOLDERS AND MY COLLEAGUES
TO FIND THE BEST APPROACH IN
PROVIDING SUPPORT FOR
COMMUNITIES THAT HAVE
HISTORICALLY BEEN LEFT BEHIND AS
WE TRANSITION TO A ZERO CARBON
EMISSION BUILDING FUTURE, OUR
GOAL IS TO KEEP COMMUNICATIONS
OPEN AND CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
BUILDING DECARBONIZATION
COALITION, NATURAL RESOURCE
DEFENSE COUNCIL, CALIFORNIA
ENVIRONMENTAL VOTERS AND MANY
MORE TO GET THIS BILL THROUGH
AND ACHIEVE OUR SHARED GOALS.
THIS BILL IS CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT AS WE UNDERSTAND THAT
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES WHO
MOST OF THE TIME SUFFER FROM THE
MOST POOR AIR QUALITY, SHOULD BE
PRIORITIZED IN ORDER TO
TRANSITION TO ZERO CARBON
EMISSION APPLIANCES, WE NEED TO
PROVIDE THAT SUPPORT TO ENSURE
THAT THEY'RE NOT LEFT BEHIND.
AND WITH THAT, I ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
SENATOR RUBIO. DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE. SENATOR STERN, THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I JUST WANT
TO THANK THE AUTHOR. I DO HAVE
CONCERNS ABOUT THE BILL AS IT AS
IT'S CURRENTLY IN PRINT, BUT IN
LIGHT OF HER HER COMMITMENTS,
BOTH IN HER HER FLOOR STATEMENT
AS WELL AS TO THE ORGANIZATIONS,
WE JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
THIS LEGISLATION DOESN'T
UNDERCUT THE MOMENTUM. WE'VE GOT
TO FIND MORE EQUITY WHEN IT
COMES TO THE DECARBONIZE ATION
EFFORT THAT'S GOING ON IN OUR
BUILDING SECTOR, I THINK THERE'S
A FAIR BALANCE TO BE STRUCK HERE
. AND I'M HOPING THAT THAT COMES
TOGETHER IN THE ASSEMBLY. I WILL
BE GIVING A COURTESY VOTE IN
THAT IN LIGHT OF THAT COMMITMENT
TODAY, AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
HAVING IT COME BACK WITH FULL
COALITION SUPPORT AND IN A
CONDITION THAT I CAN ACTUALLY
SUPPORT. SO COURTESY VOTE TODAY,
BUT DO APPRECIATE THE AUTHOR'S
COMMITMENT WORKING FOR IT,
SENATORS, ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
ON THIS MATTER ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION? SEEING NONE. SENATOR
RUBIO, YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU.
YES, I WANT TO THANK THE SENATOR
FROM LOS ANGELES, AND I WILL
CONTINUE THE CONVERSATION TO
ENSURE THAT EVERYONE, THAT WE
ALL GET TO A POINT THAT THEY CAN
SUPPORT. WITH THAT, I ASK FOR AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU ALL. DEBATE
HAVING CEASED. SECRETARY, PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ELLEN Þ RODA-GIL.
AYE ARCHULETTA. ASHBY. AYE.
ATKINS AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BLAKESBERG AYE. BRADFORD
CABALLERO. AYE. CORTEZ AYE.
DALLI. AYE. DODD DURAZZO. AYE.
EGGMAN AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
GONZALEZ GROVE. AYE. HURTADO
AYE. JONES. AYE. LAIRD AYE.
LIMÓN MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR AYE.
MIN. NEWMAN. NGUYEN AYE. NILO.
AYE. OKOBO AYE. PADILLA AYE.
PORTANTINO AYE. ROTH AYE. RUBIO
AYE. SATO AYE. SKINNER AYE.
SMALL. CUEVAS AYE. STERN AYE.
UMMER AYE. WAHAB. AYE. WIENER
WILK. AYE AYE. WE HAVE A FULL
HOUSE, SO WE'RE GOING TO GO
THROUGH THE ROLL ONE MORE TIME.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN ARCHULETA.
BRADFORD. AYE DODD GONZALEZ.
LIMÓN AYE. MCGUIRE. MIN NEWMAN.
WIENER AYE.
ON A VOTE OF 33 TO 0, THE
MEASURE PASSES. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM 26. THIS
IS SENATE BILL 1414 BY SENATOR
GROVE. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL 1414 BY SENATOR
GROVE. AN ACT RELATING TO CRIMES
. SENATOR GROVE. THANK YOU, MR.
CHAIR. COLLEAGUES TODAY I RISE
TO PRESENT SB 1414 REGARDING THE
SOLICITATION OF CHILDREN
MEMBERS. AS YOU MAY KNOW, THREE
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE FORCED AMENDMENTS
WITHOUT MY CONSENT AND WATERED
DOWN SB 1414 BY TAKING OUT
STRICTER PENALTIES FOR THOSE WHO
TRY TO BUY SEX FROM KIDS. SINCE
THAT COMMITTEE HEARING, THERE'S
BEEN A LOT OF MISINFORMATION
SHARED REGARDING THIS BILL, SO I
WOULD LIKE TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO CLARIFY A FEW OF
THOSE POINTS. MY BILL LANGUAGE
IN SB 1414 ATTEMPTED TO MAKE THE
SOLICITATION ENGAGING, AGREEING
TO ENGAGE IN OR ENGAGING IN ANY
ACT OF COMMERCIAL SEX WITH A
MINOR BY AN ADULT, A PRISON
FELONY, AND A SEX OFFENDER.
REGISTRATION ON THE SECOND
OFFENSE. TO BE CLEAR, I BELIEVE
THAT ANY ADULT WHO ATTEMPTS TO
OR ACTUALLY ENGAGES IN TO BUY
CHILDREN FOR SEX IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA SHOULD GO TO PRISON
ON A FELONY CHARGE.
DISAPPOINTINGLY THE HOSTILE
AMENDMENTS WATERED DOWN THE
LANGUAGE AND EXCLUDED 16 AND 17
YEAR OLD CHILDREN FROM THESE
ADDITIONAL PROTECTIONS. THE
PUNISHMENT WAS REDUCED TO A
WOBBLER FOR THOSE WHO WOULD
PURCHASE SEX FROM KIDS THAT ARE
15 YEARS OLD AND YOUNGER AT A.
AS A POINT OF CLARIFICATION, A
WOBBLER CAN BE CHARGED AS A
LOCAL JAIL FELONY OR A
MISDEMEANOR FOR MEANING A RICH
MAN COULD PURCHASE SEX FROM A
POOR GIRL AND JUST PAY A FINE UP
TO $10,000 TO BUY THEIR WAY OUT
OF A CRIME. ALL AMENDMENTS
FORCED ON THIS BILL ARE
UNACCEPTABLE, BUT THE NOTION
THAT 16 AND 17 YEAR OLD CHILDREN
ARE SOMEHOW LESS DESERVING OF
ADDITIONAL PROTECTIONS IS
ABSOLUTELY ABSURD. OPPONENTS OF
THE BILL, INCLUDING THE PUBLIC
SAFETY CHAIR, HAVE STATED THAT
THIS BILL HAS NOTHING TO DO WITH
HUMAN TRAFFICKING COLLEAGUES,
THE ACT OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING, OR
THE ACT OF HUMAN TRAFFICKING
INCLUDES SEX TRAFFICKING. IN
ORDER TO BE SEX TRAFFICKED, ONE
MUST BE SOLD FOR SEX. IN ORDER
TO BE SOLD, A PRICE HAS TO BE
NEGOTIATED AND SERVICES HAVE TO
BE SOLICITED. THE ONE THING ALL
SEX TRAFFICKING CASES IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAVE IN
COMMON IS THEY ARE ALL INVOLVED.
THE SOLICITATION OF SERVICES.
LET'S BE CLEAR ABOUT
SOLICITATION. WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT PROPOSITIONING SOMEONE AND
NEGOTIATING TERMS. IN THE CASE
OF SB 1414, WE'RE ADDRESSING
ADULTS THAT ARE NEGOTIATING TO
HAVE SEX WITH CHILDREN.
OPPONENTS OF THE BILL STATE, AND
I QUOTE THE CRIME IN THIS BILL
IS ABOUT SOLICITATION, MEANING
WORDS ONLY, NOT ABOUT COMMITTING
THE ACTUAL ACT. I'D LIKE TO
CLARIFY THIS MISTRUTH. THE BILL
ABSOLUTELY ADDRESSES THE
PHYSICAL ACT OF ADULTS ENGAGING
WITH KIDS FOR SEX. IF YOU READ
THE LANGUAGE, IT SPECIFICALLY
SAYS ENGAGING IN ANY ACT OF
COMMERCIAL SEX WITH A MINOR.
PLEASE BEAR IN MIND THAT IF YOU
DON'T INCLUDE STRICTER
PUNISHMENTS FOR THE NEGOTIATION
PHASE DURING THE SOLICITATION,
THE NEXT OPPORTUNITY THAT WE
HAVE TO LEVY HARSH PENALTIES IS
AFTER THE ACT HAS ALREADY BEEN
COMPLETED AND THE CHILD'S
INNOCENCE HAS BEEN SHATTERED AND
THEY HAVE BEEN COMPLETELY
SCARRED FOR LIFE. HOWEVER, LET'S
TALK ABOUT WORDS THAT WERE USED
IN SOLICITATION. COLLEAGUES I
HAVE A LOT OF WORDS TO CHOOSE
FROM THAT WAS PROVIDED TO ME
FROM MY LAW ENFORCEMENT
PARTNERS. LOTS OF WORDS. AFTER
CAREFUL CONSIDERATION AND
CONSULTING WITH SOME OF MY
FRIENDS ON THIS FLOOR AND MY LAW
ENFORCEMENT PARTNERS REGARDING
THESE EXAMPLES OF MEN SOLICITING
CHILDREN FOR SEX, I WOULD
ABSOLUTELY LOVE TO USE THESE
WORDS TO GIVE YOU A COMPLETE
DESCRIPTION OF THE THINGS THAT
WE'VE HAD TO READ THROUGH TO
RESEARCH AND PRESENT THIS BILL,
BUT I HAVE NO DOUBT WITHIN THE
FIRST EXCHANGE I WOULD BE SHUT
DOWN FOR INAPPROPRIATE LANGUAGE
USED ON THIS FLOOR. AND I HAVE
NO DOUBT THAT IF ANY MEDIA
COVERAGE TOOK PLACE TODAY, IT
WOULD BLEEP OUT EVERY OTHER WORD
THAT I SAY. YET CHILDREN HAVE TO
ENGAGE NOT ONLY IN THESE
CONVERSATIONS, BUT IN THE ACTS
THEMSELVES. THESE EXCHANGES ARE
GRAPHIC, THEY'RE SICKENING,
THEY'RE EVIL, AND USUALLY THEY
ARE THE LAST STEP BEFORE A CHILD
THAT IS SEXUALLY EXPLOITED OR
ASSAULTED BY AN ADULT. RECENTLY,
THE SACRAMENTO COUNTY SHERIFF'S
SHERIFF'S DEPARTMENT PERFORMED
OPERATION SPRING CLEANING, IN
WHICH THEY WENT AFTER ONLINE
PREDATORS ATTEMPTING TO MEET OR
ENGAGE IN SEX WITH CHILDREN. ONE
ADULT MAN THOUGHT HE WAS
SOLICITING A TEN YEAR OLD FOR
SEX. HE SHOWED UP AT A HOTEL
EXPECTING TO MEET A SMALL CHILD.
HE HAD STRAPS IN HIS POCKET TO
TIE THE CHILD DOWN. HE HAD CHILD
SIZED LINGERIE, SEX TOYS AND
LUBRICATION. MEMBERS AGAIN, I
REITERATE, WE HAVE TO ATTEMPT TO
STEP, STEP IN AND STOP THESE
PREDATORS BEFORE THEY ACTUALLY
COMPLETE THE ACT AND DEVASTATE
THE CHILD'S LIVES FOREVER. IT'S
UNBELIEVABLE THAT WE FIGHT IN
THIS BUILDING, PROTECT MINORS,
SOMETIMES UP TO THE AGE OF 21
YEARS OLD FROM TOBACCO USE,
VAPING, ALCOHOL, AND EVEN
TANNING BEDS. BUT SOME
LEGISLATORS DON'T WANT TO
INCLUDE ADDITIONAL PROTECTIONS
FOR 16 AND 17 YEAR OLDS OF
SOLICITATION OF SEX TRAFFICKING
MEMBERS, INDIVIDUALS THAT TRY TO
BUY SEX FROM KIDS DESERVE TO GO
TO PRISON. THEY DESERVE TO SIT
THERE AND THINK ABOUT WHAT
THEY'VE DONE AND HOPEFULLY
CHANGE THEIR LIFE. BUT MOST
IMPORTANTLY, WE SHOULD DO
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO KEEP THOSE
INDIVIDUALS AWAY FROM OUR
CHILDREN THAT HAVE A RIGHT TO GO
TO SCHOOL, TO EXIST IN PEACE.
THE REALITY IS, EVEN IF WE
RECLASSIFY THIS AS A PRISON
FELONY, THE DEFENDANT IS STILL
INELIGIBLE, IS STILL ELIGIBLE
FOR PROBATION MEMBERS. I'M
ATTEMPTING TO MOVE THIS BILL
FORWARD TODAY IN THE HOPES TO
WORK ON LANGUAGE IN THE
ASSEMBLY, BUT I TRULY HOPE AND
PRAY THAT IN THIS INSTANCE, WHEN
TALKING ABOUT THIS VERY SERIOUS,
VERY PREVALENT ISSUE OF ADULTS
PURCHASING SEX FOR CHILDREN OR
ENGAGING IN THE PURCHASE, OF
NEGOTIATING SEX FOR CHILDREN,
THAT WE WOULD FOCUS LESS ON
PROTECTING THE CRIMINALS AND
MORE ON THE VICTIMS. WE CANNOT
SIT IDLY BY WHILE CHILDREN ARE
BOUGHT AND SOLD IN CALIFORNIA
LIKE PIECES OF MEAT IN AN
UNDERGROUND GROCERY STORE. WE
MUST DO EVERYTHING IN OUR POWER
TO STOP THE HORRIFIC ABUSES THAT
ARE BEING PERPETRATED ON
CHILDREN EVERY SINGLE DAY,
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SENATOR. ANY
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
MEASURE? DISCUSSION OR DEBATE?
SENATOR RUBIO. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AND LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE, TODAY I
RISE AS A JOINT AUTHOR TO SB
1414 ALONGSIDE MY COLLEAGUE FROM
BAKERSFIELD AND MERCED.
CURRENTLY, THERE IS A LOOPHOLE
IN OUR SYSTEM WHERE A PERSON
ENGAGES IN UNLAWFUL SEXUAL
INTERCOURSE WITH A MINOR. AND
EVEN THOUGH MONEY IS EXCHANGED
AND NEGOTIATED, THE CONSEQUENCES
ARE MINIMAL. RECENTLY, THERE
WERE MORE THAN 500 ARRESTS AT
STATEWIDE ANTI-HUMAN TRAFFICKING
OPERATIONS COMPARED TO THE REST
OF THE NATION. CALIFORNIA RANKS
FIRST IN THE NUMBER OF HUMAN
TRAFFICKING CASES REPORTED TO
THE NATIONAL HUMAN TRAFFICKING
HOTLINE, ALTHOUGH AS THE STATE,
CALIFORNIA IMPLEMENTS
PROTECTIONS AND PENALTIES TO
COMBAT HUMAN TRAFFICKING, Ã
PERPETRATORS STILL FIGURE OUT
HOW TO VIOLATE OUR CHILDREN AND
WE WON'T STAND FOR OUR MINORS
GETTING HURT. YOU KNOW, I FILED
A LAW TO PROTECT CHILDREN AND
MAKE SURE THAT NOT ONLY ARE THEY
SAFE FROM FROM VIOLENCE, BUT
SAFE FROM THESE SEXUAL PREDATORS
. AND SO THIS IS AN IMPORTANT
BILL THAT I FEEL WE COULD ALL
GET BEHIND. THESE PERPETRATORS
ARE GETTING AWAY WITH ABUSING
OUR MOST VULNERABLE POPULATIONS.
THEY'RE AWARE WHAT THEY'RE
DOING, AND THEY FIGURE OUT HOW
TO DO IT QUIETLY. AND AGAIN, THE
CHILDREN ARE THE ONES THAT
SUFFER THE CONSEQUENCES. IN
RECENT MONTHS, THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL ANNOUNCED THAT OVER A
FOUR DAY OPERATION, 12 SUSPECTS
WERE ARRESTED AND CHARGED WITH
CONTACTING A MINOR FOR SEXUAL
PURPOSES. LET'S HIGHLIGHT THE
FACT THAT SOCIAL MEDIA HAS MADE
IT VERY, VERY DIFFICULT FOR
PARENTS TO KNOW WHAT THEIR
CHILDREN ARE DOING, AND WE HAVE
THESE PREDATORS THAT CONTINUE TO
LURE OUR KIDS, I KNOW OF A CASE
RECENTLY WHERE A YOUNG LADY WAS
LURED FROM CHICAGO AND BROUGHT
OVER, AND SHE THOUGHT SHE WAS
MEETING A BOYFRIEND AND WAS IN
CAPTIVITY FOR SEVERAL DAYS AND
FORCED TO DO SOME SOME VERY
INAPPROPRIATE THINGS THAT I WANT
TO STATE RIGHT NOW. BUT THIS IS
HAPPENING OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
SO I THINK THAT IF WE DON'T SEND
A MESSAGE THAT CALIFORNIA WILL
NOT STAND AND SEE THIS HAPPEN,
IT WILL CONTINUE TO HAPPEN IN
RECORD NUMBERS. THERE'S SO MUCH
WORK TO DO IN THIS SPACE AND
WITH THIS BILL. SO I DO HOPE
THAT WE CONTINUE TO HAVE A
CONVERSATION AND CONTINUE TO
MOVE THE BILL FORWARD, I AM
REALLY THANKFUL THAT MY
COLLEAGUE CONTINUES TO MOVE THIS
BILL FORWARD AND CONTINUES TO
HAVE CONVERSATIONS, BUT IT IS
NOT AN EASY CONVERSATION TO
HAVE. BUT OUR CHILDREN NEED US.
OUR YOUTH NEED US, AND IT'S UP
TO US TO PROTECT THEM. SO I HOPE
THAT WE SUPPORT THIS BILL TODAY.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU SENATOR. I
SEE MICROPHONES UP FROM SENATOR
ASHBY. SENATOR EGGMAN, SENATOR
NGUYEN, WE'LL BEGIN WITH SENATOR
ASHBY. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
I RISE TODAY AS A COAUTHOR TO SB
1414. I KNOW MUCH CONTROVERSY
HAS SURROUNDED THIS BILL AS IT'S
MADE ITS WAY THROUGH THE SENATE.
BUT I'D LIKE TO URGE MY
COLLEAGUES TO SUPPORT IT TODAY
ON THE FLOOR. I KNOW THERE'S
MORE WORK THAT NEEDS TO BE DONE,
AND I'M SURE MORE WORK WILL BE
DONE AND MORE CONVERSATIONS WILL
BE HAD IN THE ASSEMBLY. I'D LIKE
TO TELL YOU WHY I'M A COAUTHOR,
WHY I'M SUPPORTING, AND WHY I'M
GRATEFUL TO THE SENATOR FROM
BAKERSFIELD FOR BEING SUCH A
CHAMPION FOR OUR YOUNGEST FOLKS,
NOT TOO FAR FROM HERE. IN AN
UNDISCLOSED LOCATION, BUT NOT IN
MY DISTRICT. OUR THREE LITTLE
GIRLS, THE SAME AGE AS MY
DAUGHTER. EXCEPT ALL THREE OF
THEM. BY THE WAY, MY DAUGHTER'S
11. SHE'S IN FIFTH GRADE. ALL
THREE OF THEM ARE PREGNANT FROM
BEING SEX TRAFFICKED. ALL THREE
OF THEM ARE FROM DIFFERENT
PLACES AROUND THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. LUCKILY, THEY HAVE
MADE IT INTO THE ARMS OF TWO.
REALLY AMAZING NONPROFITS THAT
KNOW THIS WORLD WELL, ONE RUN BY
ONE OF MY BEST FRIENDS. BUT
EVERY DAY I GET LITTLE UPDATES
ABOUT THESE GIRLS. NEXT WEEK,
COLLEAGUES, I WON'T BE HERE WITH
YOU ON TUESDAY BECAUSE I'M GOING
TO WATCH MY DAUGHTER PROMOTE OUT
OF FIFTH GRADE, AND I'M REALLY
EXCITED. BUT NEXT TUESDAY, EACH
OF THOSE GIRLS WILL ENTER THEIR
SECOND TRIMESTER. THEY'RE THE
SAME AGE, I URGE, AND I VOTE
PLEASE. THANK YOU. SENATOR.
SENATOR EGGMAN, THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. AND MEMBERS, I'D LIKE
TO SAY AS A AS A PROGRESSIVE,
PROUD MEMBER OF THIS BODY FOR
THE LAST 12 YEARS, I'M DONE. I'M
DONE WITH US PROTECTING PEOPLE
WHO WOULD BUY AND ABUSE OUR
CHILDREN. I'M DONE. I DON'T WANT
TO SEND MORE BLACK AND BROWN MEN
TO PRISON. I DON'T WANT MORE
PEOPLE IN PRISON. BUT I DON'T
WANT PEOPLE BUYING GIRLS. I
DON'T WANT PEOPLE BUYING LITTLE
GIRLS ANYMORE. AND I'M TIRED OF
SAYING IT'S OKAY AND THAT WE
HAVE TO PROTECT THE MEN WHO DO
IT. AS A MENTAL HEALTH
PROFESSIONAL AND AS A SOCIAL
WORKER, I CAN TELL YOU I'VE
SPENT MY ENTIRE CAREER WORKING
WITH PEOPLE WHO HAVE BEEN
WOUNDED. I'M NOT GOING TO SAY
BEYOND REPAIR, BUT THEY HAVE
BEEN WOUNDED TO THEIR CORE BY
THE ABUSE THAT'S BEEN HEAPED ON
THEM, OFTENTIMES BY THOSE THAT
THEY LOVE AND LOOK TO PROTECT
THEM. AND IF THEIR PARENTS WON'T
DO IT, THEN BY GOD, WE SHOULD.
AGAIN, I AM NOT ARGUING THAT WE
OPEN THE GATES TO FLOOD OUR
PRISONS WITH PEOPLE, BUT I AM
ARGUING WE HAVE A MORAL
RESPONSIBILITY TO SAY ENOUGH,
ENOUGH. WE HAVE GIVEN AWAY
ENOUGH ON THIS AREA AND WE'VE
GOT TO MOVE BACK INTO THE
CENTER, OR WE ALL LOOK LIKE
FOOLS AND LAUGHINGSTOCKS AND
WHAT DO WE STAND FOR? I ASK ALL
OF YOU TO WATCH THE DOCUMENTARY
THAT SENATOR GROVE WAS IN.
SENATOR FROM KERN COUNTY, WHO
WAS JUST IN THAT TALKED ABOUT
THIS VERY PLACE IN SACRAMENTO
WHERE GIRLS ARE BEING BOUGHT AND
SOLD. MEN ARE BEING GIVEN A SLAP
IN THE HAND OR A COUPLE OF DAYS,
AND THEN THEY'RE BACK OUT AGAIN
AND THEY DO THE SAME THING. THEY
GET CAUGHT OVER AND OVER AND
OVER AGAIN, AND SOMEHOW THAT'S
OKAY. IT'S NOT OKAY. IT IS NOT
OKAY ANYMORE. AND NO MORE AM I
WATCHING. LIKE I SAID, I'M
LEAVING. BUT THE REST OF YOU WHO
ARE GOING TO BE HERE FOR A
WHILE, LET'S GET OUR STUFF
TOGETHER AND REALLY START
FOCUSING ON SOME OF THE
IMPORTANT THINGS. WE TALK ABOUT
LEARNING, AND WE TALK ABOUT
BEING SAFE. THIS IS LIKE AT THE
CORE OF IT, AND A LOT OF THESE
KIDS CAN BE THROWAWAY KIDS.
THEY'RE POOR KIDS, THEY'RE KIDS
OF COLOR. BUT THEY SHOULDN'T
HAVE TO LIVE A LIFE DETERMINED
BY WHAT HAPPENS TO THEM, BY
OTHERS AT A VERY YOUNG AGE, AND
BY HAVING THE DEMOCRATIC PARTY
OF CALIFORNIA SAY, IT'S OKAY,
IT'S NOT OKAY, AND I'M NOT DOING
IT ANYMORE. AND I HOPE NONE OF
YOU DO, TOO. WE HAVE TO BE ABLE
TO DRAW A LINE. AND FOR ME, I'M
DRAWING A LINE. I URGE YOUR I
VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR EGGMAN.
SENATOR NGUYEN. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I TOO RISE IN SUPPORT
OF SB 1414 ESPECIALLY. ACTUALLY
THE ORIGINAL ONE THAT PROTECTS
ALL CHILDREN. AND WHEN I SAY ALL
CHILDREN, WE DEFINE CHILDREN AS
UNDER 18. WE DON'T DEFINE THEM
AS UNDER 15. UNDER FIVE. HUMAN
TRAFFICKING IS THE GREATEST EVIL
IN OUR SOCIETY. K¾T. IT'S EVEN
WORSE WHEN IT COMES TO OUR
CHILDREN AND THE GOOD SENATOR
FROM KERN COUNTY STATED THAT
THESE INDIVIDUALS SHOULD GO TO
JAIL. I'M SORRY TO ME, THEY
SHOULD GO TO HELL BECAUSE THEY
CAN'T. WE CANNOT AS A SOCIETY,
ALLOW THEM TO TRAFFIC OUR
CHILDREN REGARDLESS OF WHERE
THEY ARE FROM, WHERE THEY COME
FROM, WHO THEIR FAMILIES ARE.
AND IT CONTINUES TO HAPPEN IN
CALIFORNIA AND ACROSS THE WORLD.
THE AMENDMENT THAT WAS FORCED
TAKEN, I HOPE THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE THIS CONVERSATION AND
MAKE SURE THAT WE ADD THAT BACK
IN, BECAUSE THE 18 YEAR OLD, THE
16 YEAR OLD, THE 17 YEAR OLD AND
THE 15 YEAR OLD SHOULD ALSO BE
PROTECTED BY US NO MATTER WHAT
WE ARE. THEIR PARENTS AND LIKE
THE PREVIOUS SENATOR MENTIONED,
THEY HAVE LOOKED TO US TO
PROTECT THEM. AND IF THE PARENTS
CAN'T, WE AS LEGISLATORS SHOULD
STEP IN AND HELP. AND SO I URGE
FOR AN AYE VOTE AND THAT WE
CONTINUE THIS CONVERSATION, BUT
NOT JUST FOR THOSE CHILDREN THAT
ARE STATED IN THIS AMENDED BILL,
BUT CONTINUE THAT CONVERSATION.
AND I THANK AGAIN THE SENATOR
FROM KERN COUNTY FOR CONTINUING
HER FIGHT FOR OUR CHILDREN AND
PROTECTING THESE YOUNG GIRLS. I
ASK FOR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, SENATOR. REMINDER
THAT WE'RE SPEAKING ON THE BILL
IN QUESTION IN FRONT OF US
TODAY. SENATOR CIERTO. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT, MEMBERS, I
URGE YOU TO VOTE AYE ON SB 1414.
I WAS IN PUBLIC SAFETY. I'M ON
PUBLIC SAFETY. AND, WAS THERE
WHEN THE BILL WAS AMENDED. I
SUPPORTED THE ORIGINAL, LANGUAGE
IN THE BILL, AS A FATHER OF
THREE DAUGHTERS AND A SURVIVOR
OF RAISING THOSE THREE
DAUGHTERS, I CAN ASSURE YOU THAT
AT NO TIME WHEN THEY WERE 16 OR
17 DID I DISCOUNT THAT, THEIR,
THEIR BEING A MINOR AND THEIR
NEEDING THE PROTECTION OF THEIR
MOM AND THEIR DAD. UNFORTUNATELY
FOR MY DAUGHTERS, THEY HAD A DAD
WHO HAD SOME EXPERIENCE OUT
THERE AND UNDERSTOOD THAT THIS
WAS ACTUALLY HAPPENING, AT THE
LEVEL THAT WE ARE BEING TOLD
IT'S HAPPENING NOW AND IT'S
FINALLY BEING EXPOSED. THIS IS
HAPPENING YEARS AND YEARS AGO.
AND PEOPLE JUST THOUGHT IT WAS
ISOLATED AND ISOLATED INCIDENT
IN THE INNER CITY AREAS. IT WAS
NOT A LOT OF WHAT YOU HAVE HEARD
IS ALL TRUE. WE HAVE YOUNG
PEOPLE THAT ARE BEING EXPLOITED.
MY DAUGHTERS HAD THE BENEFIT OF
HAVING A MOM AND A DAD AND LIKE
I SAID, A DAD THAT UNDERSTOOD
AND A MOM THAT WAS WATCHING OUT
FOR THEM WHEN I WAS AT WORK, AND
THEY HAD THE BENEFIT OF ME
GIVING THEM THE KNOWLEDGE TO
WATCH OUT. SITUATIONAL AWARENESS
FOR THEM TO THE POINT OF WHICH
THEY THOUGHT THEIR DAD WAS
PARANOID AND I WAS, BECAUSE I
WASN'T PARANOID ABOUT MAYBE
SOMEBODY GOING TO JAIL FOR
EXPLOITING MY CHILDREN. I WAS
PARANOID THAT THEY WOULDN'T. SO
I WOULD TELL YOU THAT 16 AND 17
YEAR OLDS NEED THEIR PARENTS,
AND NOT EVERYONE IS BLESSED WITH
PARENTS THAT HAVE THE KNOWLEDGE
AND THE ABILITY TO WATCH AFTER
THEM. THAT'S OUR JOB IS TO WATCH
OUR WATCH OUT FOR THOSE THAT
DON'T. SENATOR, JUST A MOMENT. I
JUST WANT TO REMIND YOU THAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT THE BILL IN
QUESTION BEFORE US. THIS BILL IN
QUESTION IS ALL ABOUT THAT. THE
ISSUE THAT I'M TALKING ABOUT IS
THAT 16 AND 17 YEAR OLDS WERE
EXCLUDED FROM THIS BILL. THEY
WERE DIMINISHED. I JUST WANT TO
REMIND ALL MEMBERS THAT IT'S THE
BILL BEFORE US TODAY. THAT'S
THAT'S UP FOR DEBATE. SO JUST
ANOTHER GENTLE REMINDER THAT'S
ALL. UNDERSTOOD. THANK YOU. SO
THIS BILL TODAY, LACKS SOME
ELEMENTS, BUT IT NEEDS TO GO
FORWARD. SO WE CAN PUT THE
ELEMENTS THAT WERE TAKEN OUT
BACK IN. AND, AND WE CAN DO OUR
JOB, WHICH IS TO ENSURE THE
SAFETY OF MINORS. AND THIS BILL
IN ITS CURRENT FORM, WAS WAS
MUTILATED TO NOT DO THAT. SO I
WOULD ASK THAT YOU VOTE YES ON
THIS BILL TO MOVE IT FORWARD SO
THAT THE AUTHOR CAN CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH THE NEXT HOUSE TO
ENSURE THAT THAT LANGUAGE GETS
PUT BACK INTO THIS BILL. SO I
DIDN'T WANT TO DO HOSTILE
AMENDMENTS ON HOSTILE AMENDMENTS
. SO THAT'S WHY WE'RE DOING IT
THIS WAY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
SENATOR. SENATOR JONES, YOU'RE
RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, I JUST WANT
TO STAND IN SUPPORT OF SB 1414.
ALSO AND JUST BE BRIEF AND
SHARING WITH THE BODY THAT I'M
VERY PROUD OF, SENATOR, FROM THE
SENATOR FROM BAKERSFIELD, AND
THEN ALL THE OTHER SENATORS THAT
ALSO WORKED SO DILIGENTLY ON
THIS BILL. THIS HAS BEEN AN
EMOTIONAL JOURNEY, THESE LAST
COUPLE OF MONTHS ON THIS BILL.
AND I ESPECIALLY APPRECIATE THE
SPEAKERS THAT SPOKE THIS
AFTERNOON IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. THANK YOU, AND I HOPE THAT
EVERY, EVERY WORD THAT WAS SAID
ON THIS FLOOR, THIS AFTERNOON
WILL BE TAKEN SERIOUS AND INTO
CONSIDERATION AS WE ALL VOTE AYE
TODAY AND CONTINUE TO PLEDGE OUR
SUPPORT TO SENATOR GROVE AND THE
COAUTHORS THAT ARE WORKING ON
THIS BILL, AND THAT WE WILL MAKE
SURE THAT WE HAVE THE VERY BEST
BILL WE CAN HAVE WHEN IT COMES
BACK ON THE SENATE FLOOR. I ASK
FOR AN AYE VOTE ON 1414. THANK
YOU. SENATOR. SENATOR DOLLY,
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS, I TOO RISE AS A
COAUTHOR OF THIS BILL. AND JUST
WANT TO ADD ONE THING I DO HAVE
A 14 YEAR OLD DAUGHTER, AND I
ACTUALLY WATCHED THE DOCUMENTARY
LAST NIGHT AS WELL AND REALIZED
THAT IN THIS CITY RIGHT HERE,
WHERE MY DAUGHTER GOES TO SCHOOL
IS ONE OF THE ROADS THAT WHERE
SEX TRAFFICKING AND ABDUCTIONS
HAPPEN. AND JUST LAST NIGHT WAS
THE GRADUATION FOR THE SCHOOL
THAT SHE ATTENDS, AND SHE WAS
ACTUALLY THERE AT THE AT THE
GRADUATION AND STAYED THE NIGHT
WITH A FRIEND AND WAS GOING TO
WALK TO THE STORE. AND I SAID
NO, BECAUSE OF THE ABDUCTIONS
FOR SEX TRAFFICKING THAT
HAPPENED IN THIS AREA. SO FOR
THOSE REASONS, I WANT TO APPLAUD
THE AUTHOR FOR NEVER GIVING UP
AND WORKING TOWARDS PROTECTING
OUR CHILDREN. AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE ON SB 1414.
THANK YOU SENATOR. ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION ON THIS MEASURE, ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION? SENATOR
CABALLERO, THE HIDDEN MICROPHONE
BACK THERE. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MR. PRESIDENT, AS A COAUTHOR, I
FELT COMPELLED TO STAND UP AS
WELL, YOU KNOW, WHEN WE'RE
DEALING WITH LEGAL LANGUAGE AND
MAKING DIFFERENTIATING, BETWEEN
DIFFERENT CRIMES AND DIFFERENT
PUNISHMENTS GETS COMPLICATED. IT
GETS COMPLICATED. AND I WANT TO
MAKE SURE THAT I TELL THE GOOD
SENATOR FROM BAKERSFIELD HOW
PROUD I AM OF HER AND HOW MUCH I
APPRECIATE HER TENACITY. I'M
PROUD TO BE A COAUTHOR ON THIS
BILL FOR THE EXACT SAME REASONS
THAT MY GOOD FRIEND FROM
STOCKTON STATED, IT'S TIME. IT'S
TIME. AND YOU CAN HAVE YOUNG
CHILDREN IN FROM GOOD FAMILIES
ALL THE WAY TO ABSENT FAMILIES
THAT THAT HAVE THE POTENTIAL TO
BE ABDUCTED, TO BE TRICKED, TO
END UP GOING SOMEPLACE AND NOT
UNDERSTANDING HOW DANGEROUS IT
IS. I MEAN, I, I SHUDDER TO
THINK I WAS AN ADULT WHEN I WENT
AWAY TO COLLEGE, BUT I DID SOME
PRETTY STUPID THINGS, THAT COULD
HAVE GOTTEN ME IN TROUBLE. BUT I
HAD FRIENDS AROUND, AND I WAS
LUCKY IN THAT REGARD. SO IT IS
INCUMBENT ON US TO DO EVERYTHING
POSSIBLE TO PROTECT OUR
CHILDREN. OUR CHILDREN, AND THE
CHILDREN OF EVERYBODY ELSE, I, I
PLEDGE THAT I WILL CONTINUE TO
WORK WITH WITH THE GOOD SENATOR
FROM BAKERSFIELD. IF THIS MOVES
TO THE ASSEMBLY, BECAUSE IT
NEEDS WORK. AND SO I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. SENATOR.
SENATOR BRADFORD. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. PRESIDENT, I TOO WANT
TO RISE IN STRONG SUPPORT, BUT
MORE IMPORTANTLY, COMMEND THIS
AUTHOR FOR HER COMMITMENT AND
HER PASSION TO THIS ISSUE. THIS
IS NOT A DEMOCRATIC ISSUE. IT'S
NOT A REPUBLICAN ISSUE. IT'S A
HUMAN RIGHT ISSUE. IT'S ONE THAT
IMPACTS ALL OF US. AND JUST THIS
MORNING ON THE NEWS, IT WAS A
STORY OF AN INDIVIDUAL WHO WAS
ONLINE SOLICITING SEX WITH A TEN
YEAR OLD, AND HE HAD A MINIATURE
LINGERIE AND ALL THIS STUFF, ALL
PREPARED TO MEET HER. SO THESE
ARE INDIVIDUALS WHO ARE SICK,
SICK WHO DESERVE TO BE LOCKED
UP. AND I'M NOT A BIG PROPONENT
OF THROWING AWAY THE KEY, BUT
ANYBODY THAT PREYS ON CHILDREN
THÀNH NEED TO BE LOCKED UP.
THERE ARE ANIMAL AND THEY DON'T
DESERVE TO WALK THE STREETS AND
I'M COMMITTED TO MAKING SURE
THAT WE DO MAKE SOME REFORMS.
AND I THANK HER FOR THE SUPPORT
THAT SHE ASSISTED LAST YEAR AND
THE EBONY ALERT, BECAUSE WE SAW
HOW BLACK YOUNG KIDS WERE BEING
SEXUALLY EXPLOITED AND
TRAFFICKED AND LISTED AS
JUVENILE PROSTITUTES. WHEN WE
KNOW A JUVENILE CANNOT CONSENT
TO SEX, LET ALONE SELL SEX. SO I
COMMEND HER FOR HER PASSION. AND
I ALSO URGE I VOTE FOR THIS
MEASURE. SENATOR SKINNER, THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. MEMBERS, I
RISE ALSO IN SUPPORT OF SB 1414
AND THE DISCUSSION WE'VE HAD ON
THE FLOOR TODAY LEGITIMATELY
COVERS MANY MORE ISSUES THAN ARE
SOLELY THE SUBJECT OF THIS BILL.
AND IT IS CLEAR THAT WE HAVE
SEEN A RISE IN IN SEX
TRAFFICKING AND IN, I DON'T WANT
TO GET INTO THE DETAILS, BUT I
THINK WE'VE UNDERSTOOD, YOU
KNOW, I'VE SERVED ON THE PUBLIC
SAFETY COMMITTEE THE ENTIRE TIME
THAT I'VE BEEN ON IN THE SENATE.
AND, YOU KNOW, WE HEAR FROM
PROSECUTORS, FROM LAW
ENFORCEMENT, OTHERS ABOUT HOW
THIS REALITY OF THAT FOR MANY
PEOPLE, IT IS EASIER. THEY CAN
MAKE MORE MONEY OFF SELLING
PEOPLE FOR SEX THAN THEY CAN FOR
OTHER CRIMINAL ACTIVITIES. AND
THAT IS HORRENDOUS. AND WE HAVE
WE COLLECTIVELY HAVE ACTED IN
MANY WAYS TO ADDRESS THAT. AND
WE PROBABLY SHOULD DO MORE IN
TERMS OF EMPOWERING. I DON'T
MEAN EMPOWERING, BUT WE'RE IN A
DEFICIT RIGHT NOW. BUT IF WHEN
WE DO HAVE ADDITIONAL FUNDS,
BEING ABLE TO ENHANCE LAW
ENFORCEMENT TASK FORCES THAT ARE
DIRECTED AT TRYING TO GET AT
THESE ENTITIES THAT ARE PREYING
UPON OUR CHILDREN, BECAUSE NO
MATTER WHAT LAW WE PASS, IF WE
DO NOT HAVE ADEQUATE LAW
ENFORCEMENT RESOURCES TO REALLY
GET AT THIS ACTIVITY, THEN WE
CAN'T STOP IT. SO I THINK
THERE'S CLEARLY MORE WE CAN DO,
BUT TO THE POINT OF THE TO THE
QUESTION OF WHETHER AND THIS
BILL NEEDS MORE WORK, I THINK
WHAT WE NEED TO REMEMBER IS THAT
THIS BILL AND I APPRECIATE THE
AUTHOR'S, YOU KNOW, CONCERNS
THAT SOLICITATION, OF COURSE, AT
, IS THE PRECURSOR TO SOMETHING
ELSE. BUT YOU KNOW, LAWS ARE
FUNNY THINGS AND THEY ARE, THIS
BILL AFFECTS A VERBAL EXCHANGE.
THAT IS WHAT SOLICITATION IS. IT
AFFECTS A VERBAL EXCHANGE. AND
SO THE AMENDMENTS THAT WERE MADE
WERE TRYING TO MAKE APPROPRIATE
AND, AND INCREASE THE PENALTIES,
ABSOLUTELY INCREASE THE
PENALTIES FOR THAT VERBAL
EXCHANGE, BUT OF COURSE, IN
TERMS OF THE OTHER ACTS THAT
OCCUR AND THAT WE ALL KNOW ARE
NOT ONLY HORRENDOUS, BUT IN ANY
WAY, IN EVERY WAY NEED TO BE
STOPPED, THEN, YES, THOSE
ADDITIONAL THINGS CLEARLY CAN BE
SUBJECT TO DIFFERENT BILLS AND
OR TO INCREASING THE
EFFECTIVENESS OF, OR RATHER, THE
RESOURCE OF OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT
TO GET AT THE PERPETRATORS. BUT
WITH THAT I ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. ALL RIGHT, MEMBERS, ANY
FURTHER DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON
THIS ISSUE, ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE SEEING
NONE. SENATOR GROVE, YOU MAY
CLOSE. THANK YOU. MR. CHAIR. AND
MEMBERS, ACCORDING TO FEDERAL
LAW, ALL CHILDREN IN THE SEX
TRADE, REGARDLESS OF AGE, ARE
RECOGNIZED AS VICTIMS OF SEX
TRAFFICKING. TRAFFICKING DUE TO
THE VICTIMS OF TRAFFICKING
VIOLENCE PROTECTION ACT OF 2000.
UNDER THAT PROTECTION ACT,
CHILDREN ARE RECOGNIZED AS
VICTIMS IN THE SEX TRAFFICKING
INDUSTRY. AGAIN, THERE'S NO
REASON WHY 16 AND 17 YEAR OLDS
SHOULD NOT BE CONSIDERED
CHILDREN. IN THIS CASE. IF WE
TRULY WANT A SAFER CALIFORNIA
THAT WE DISCUSSED YESTERDAY, WE
SHOULD START BY PROTECTING ALL
OF OUR KIDS WITH THIS VERSION OF
SB 1414, WE'RE SENDING A MESSAGE
IN THE LEGISLATIVE BODY THAT
BUYING CHILDREN FOR SEX IS MORE
ACCEPTABLE OR EXCUSE ME, IS MORE
ACCEPTABLE FOR YOUNGER CHILDREN
THAN IT IS FOR OLDER CHILDREN.
AND WE NEED TO MAKE SURE THAT
THAT GETS FIXED. I, HAVE SOME OF
MY COLLEAGUES HAVE REFERENCED
THE DOCUMENTARY THAT WAS
RELEASED YESTERDAY. KCRA
SACRAMENTO, A LOCAL TV STATION,
HAS BEEN FOCUSED ON THIS
PARTICULAR SUBJECT MATTER.
ESCAPING THE BLADE, THERE'S A
BLADE IN LOS ANGELES WHERE MY
COLLEAGUE AND I DO WANT TO SAY
THANK YOU TO MY COLLEAGUE, AND
I'M GOING TO NAME HER AND,
SENATOR ELENA DURAZO, WHERE, I
HAD A MOM THAT CALLED ME BECAUSE
HER DAUGHTER WAS INVOLVED IN THE
SEX TRAFFICKING, INDUSTRY. THEY
TRIED FOR A COUPLE OF YEARS TO
GET HER OUT AND SHE ACTUALLY GOT
KILLED ON THE BLADE DOWN IN THE
GOOD SENATOR FROM LOS ANGELES
DISTRICT, THE PERPETRATOR THAT
KILLED THAT. THAT 20 YEAR OLD
GIRL WHO WAS INVOLVED IN SEX
TRAFFICKING FROM THE AGE OF 16,
WAS 14 YEARS OLD. AND IT
HAPPENED AT 4:00 IN THE MORNING.
THE SENATOR FROM LOS ANGELES WAS
VERY HELPFUL, ALONG WITH THE
SENATOR FROM GARDENA, TO HELP US
GET HER BODY BACK HOME SO THAT
SHE COULD BE PROPERLY BURIED.
THIS INDUSTRY AFFECTS ALL OF US
ALL ACROSS THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. KCRA DID THE, THE
DOCUMENTARY THAT HIGHLIGHTS JUST
WHAT HAPPENS RIGHT HERE IN
SACRAMENTO. IT HIGHLIGHTS THE
BLADE RIGHT HERE IN OUR CAPITAL
CITIES. YOU CAN DRIVE OVER
THERE, YOU CAN DO A DRIVE BY.
YOU CAN HAVE QUÊ TAKE YOU OUT.
EXCUSE ME. SHERIFF COOPER TAKE
YOU OUT ON A DRIVE BY AND YOU
CAN SEE THESE YOUNG GIRLS IN
LINGERIE JUST STANDING AROUND
WAITING, TO BE BOUGHT AND SOLD
NIGHT AFTER NIGHT. THEY HAVE
QUOTAS TO MEET. THEY CAN'T GO
HOME WITHOUT MEETING $1,000
QUOTA AND SO ON, THERE'S RULES
THAT THEY HAVE TO FOLLOW. AND A
LOT OF THESE ARE KIDS. NOW. THEY
MAY BE DRESSED UP WITH MAKEUP
AND DIFFERENT TYPES OF CLOTHES,
BUT THEY THEY'RE KIDS. YOU CAN
TELL THEY'RE KIDS. ONE INSTANCE
DURING THE DOCUMENTARY, IT WAS
REALLY INTERESTING THAT THE
DEFENDANT THAT WAS BEING
ARRESTED, CLEARLY BECAUSE OF SB
14, HE WAS THE SELLER OF THE
INDIVIDUAL OR THE CHILD ON THE
STREET. HE WAS THE SELLER. HE'S
BEING ARRESTED AND HE'S YELLING
AT LAW ENFORCEMENT AND HE'S
TELLING THEM, QUOTE, HE'S
TELLING THEM, HOW COME YOU'RE
ARRESTING ME WHEN ALL THESE
BUYERS ARE OUT HERE? IN ORDER TO
ADDRESS THIS ISSUE, WE HAVE TO
ADDRESS THE BUYERS. WE NEED TO
STAND UP FOR OUR CHILDREN. IN
CLOSING, I WANT TO THANK
EVERYBODY WHO SPOKE IN FAVOR OF
THE BILL AND IN FAVOR OF WORKING
WITH ME TO MAKE SURE THAT WE GET
THIS BILL RIGHT. I KNOW IT'S
GOING TO COME BACK TO THIS
HOUSE, AND I KNOW IT WILL
PROBABLY BE PULLED BACK INTO
COMMITTEE, BUT I THINK THERE'S
THINGS THAT HAPPENED IN PUBLIC
SAFETY THAT WE NEED TO FIX, I
WANT TO THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM
GARDENA. I USED A LOT OF HIS
DATA ON THE EBONY ALERT. HE DID
A LOT OF RESEARCH ON THE EBONY
ALERT. AND IT IS TRUE, SOME OF
THE STUFF THAT'S IN THIS BINDER
SPECIFICALLY GROWN, DOCTORS,
LAWYERS, BUSINESS PEOPLE, THEY
LIKE YOUNG BLACK GIRLS. AND I
HAVE THE MESSAGES IN THE
COMMUNICATIONS TO PROVE IT IN
HIS EBONY ALERT HIGHLIGHTED A
LOT OF THOSE THINGS. I WANT TO
THANK ALL MY JOINT AUTHORS THAT
HAVE STOOD WITH ME THROUGH THICK
AND THIN AND UPS AND DOWNS AND
DEAD BILLS AND LIVE BILLS AND
RESURRECTED BILLS AND EVERYTHING
THAT'S GONE ON, ON THIS INDUSTRY
AND TRYING TO FIX THIS SITUATION
BECAUSE IT'S MULTIFACETED, IT IS
WAY MULTIFACETED. MY JOINT
AUTHORS AND MY COAUTHORS, AGAIN,
MY COLLEAGUE FROM GARDENA,
MURIETTA, AND THE PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE, WHO OPERATED IN GOOD
FAITH AND HELPED ME WITH
AMENDMENTS THAT WE NEEDED TO
MAKE. BUT, DANG, SUZE. MY
COLLEAGUE FROM STOCKTON. MIKE
DROP GIRLFRIEND. MIKE DROP
BECAUSE YOU NAILED IT. WE ARE 40
ELECTED REPRESENTATIVES IN 40
MILLION PEOPLE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA. AND WE HAVE A
SERIOUS PROBLEM. AND I'M TELLING
YOU, THOSE PERPETRATORS ARE WAY
AHEAD OF US. YOU CAN GET THIS
BOOK. SOMEBODY GAVE ME THIS BOOK
BECAUSE NOW I'M THE HUMAN
TRAFFICKING LADY, RIGHT? GAVE ME
THIS BOOK. IT TELLS YOU SOME OF
THE THINGS IN THIS BOOK THAT WE
DON'T EVEN ADDRESS IT. AND
AGAIN, I'M NOT TRYING TO GET OFF
SUBJECT MATTER, BUT IT TELLS YOU
HOW TO BECOME AN EFFECTIVE
FOSTER PARENT AND HOW TO, BEAT
THE SYSTEM SO THAT YOU CAN
TRAFFIC THOSE KIDS. WE HAVE A
SERIOUS PROBLEM AND SB 1414 ONLY
ADDRESS ADDRESSES THE PURCHASER
WHO ENGAGES IN, SOLICITS, OR
ENGAGES IN SOLICITATION.
SOLICITATION FOR A MINOR CHILD
FOR SEX. AND IT'S AMENDED TO
ONLY INCLUDE A WOBBLER FOR 15
AND BELOW AND 16 AND 17 YEAR
OLDS DON'T MATTER. WE HAVE TO
FIX THIS. WE HAVE TO MOVE
FORWARD. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
THE HONOR OF CARRYING THIS BILL
TO THE ASSEMBLY, SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO WORK ON THIS BILL,
AND I WANT TO THANK ALL OF YOU
GUYS FOR YOUR SUPPORT. THANK
YOU, SENATOR, ALL DEBATE HAVING
CEASED, THIS BILL IS ELIGIBLE
FOR A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. ANY
OBJECTION TO USING A UNANIMOUS
ROLL CALL? SEEING NONE. AYES 36.
NO. ZERO. THE MEASURE PASSES.
CAUSE.
MEMBERS. A COUPLE OF A COUPLE OF
ANNOUNCEMENTS. NUMBER ONE, ON
BEHALF OF SENATOR WILK, WE HAVE
SOME SPECIAL GUESTS HERE IN OUR
GALLERY. COUNCIL MEMBER JASON
GIBBS AND HIS FAMILY, PLEASE
WELCOME THEM TO THE SENATE.
MEMBERS, WE HAVE ALMOST FINISHED
OUR BUSINESS TODAY. WE'RE GOING
TO NEED A FEW MINUTES TO DO SOME
PAPERWORK BEFORE WE CONTINUE
WITH OUR PROGRAM. WE'D LIKE TO
ASK ALL MEMBERS TO STAY HERE ON
THE FLOOR. PLEASE STAY HERE ON
THE FLOOR, AND WE'LL BE RIGHT
BACK WITH YOU IN JUST A COUPLE
MINUTES.
MEMBERS, I JUST WANT TO GIVE YOU
A HEADS UP. WE ARE EXPECTING TO
BEGIN OUR OUR SESSION IN ABOUT
TWO MINUTES, SO IN ABOUT TWO
MINUTES, WE'LL BEGIN AGAIN. SO
IF YOU CAN HEAR MY VOICE AND
YOU'RE OUTSIDE OF THE CHAMBERS,
PLEASE COME ON BACK.
OKAY, MEMBERS, WE ARE BACK FROM
OUR SHORT RECESS. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE. IF I DIDN'T SAY
IT AGAIN. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR YOUR PATIENCE. WE ARE GOING
TO MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM 36.
THIS IS SENATE BILL 989 BY
SENATOR ASHBY. SHE IS PREPARED
THE SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL 989 BY SENATOR
ASHBY. AN ACT RELATING TO
DOMESTIC VIOLENCE. SENATOR
ASHBY, THE FLOOR IS YOURS. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. I RISE TO
PRESENT SB 989. THE DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE DEATHS ACT. SB 989
ENHANCES INVESTIGATION PROTOCOLS
FOR DOMESTIC VIOLENCE RELATED
DEATHS. THIS BILL ALSO EXPANDS
RIGHTS TO IMMEDIATE FAMILY
MEMBERS TO OBTAIN INFORMATION
ABOUT THEIR DECEASED LOVED ONES,
PARTICULARLY WHEN THEY BELIEVE
THE DEATH TO BE UNDER SUSPICIOUS
CIRCUMSTANCES. EXPERTS ESTIMATE
THAT AROUND 1200 HIDDEN
HOMICIDES OCCUR ANNUALLY, OFTEN
DISGUISED AS STAGED CRIME
SCENES, LEADING TO INACCURATE
DEATH CERTIFICATES SUCH AS
SUICIDE AND ACCIDENTS. RESEARCH
HAS IDENTIFIED TEN EVIDENCE
BASED FACTORS THAT SHOULD
WARRANT THOROUGH INVESTIGATION
INTO SUSPICIOUS DEATH. THIS BILL
ENSURES LAW ENFORCEMENT TRAINING
INCLUDES THESE FACTORS. SOME OF
YOU MAY HAVE MET JOE OR PATRICIA
IN ONE OF THE COMMITTEE HEARINGS
, AS JOE IS THE BROTHER OF
JOANNA AND PATRICIA IS THE
MOTHER OF JOANNA. JOANNA IS ONE
OF THOSE 1200 HIDDEN DEATHS THAT
OCCUR EVERY YEAR. PATRICIA.
JOANNA'S MOM, HAS NEVER MISSED A
HEARING ON THIS BILL, INCLUDING
THIS ONE. TODAY I ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR ASHBY.
ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
MEASURE? SENATOR RUBIO? THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. AND LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE,
TODAY I RISE AS A PROUD JOINT
AUTHOR ON THIS CRUCIAL PIECE OF
LEGISLATION. ONE OF MY GOALS
WHEN I GOT ELECTED TO THE STATE
SENATE WAS TO SUPPORT
LEGISLATION THAT PROTECTS
VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE,
THAT PROTECTS CHILDREN AND
FAMILIES EXPERIENCING DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE IN THE HOME. AND I'M
REALLY HONORED TO PARTNER WITH
THE GREAT SENATOR SACRAMENTO TO
DO THIS, WE NEED TO DO BETTER
AND UPLIFT LEGISLATION LIKE THIS
THAT SUPPORTS SURVIVORS AND
THEIR FAMILY. MANY TIMES WHEN
VICTIMS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE ARE
GONE, THE FAMILY IS LEFT TO TRY
AND FIGURE OUT HOW TO PICK UP
THE PIECES. EXISTING LAW DOES
NOT ADEQUATELY, ADEQUATELY
ADDRESS SUSPICIOUS DEATH CASES
WITH A HISTORY OF DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE AS FAMILY MEMBERS AND
SUSPICIOUS DEATH CASES OFTEN
STRUGGLE TO OBTAIN INFORMATION,
EVEN ACCESS TO SERVICES, UNLESS
THE CASE IS DETERMINED TO BE A
HOMICIDE. THE LEGISLATION IS
INTENDED TO ADDRESS THIS GAP IN
SUSPICIOUS DEATH CASES IN
CALIFORNIA VÀ, AND SUPPORTS
SURVIVORS OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AND THEIR FAMILIES AFTER THE
FACT. SO TOGETHER WE CAN HELP
THESE VICTIMS. AND ONCE AGAIN, I
WANT TO THANK THE SENATOR FROM
SACRAMENTO, AND I AM A PROUD
JOINT AUTHOR ON THIS MEASURE.
AND WITH THAT, I ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
SENATOR. ANY FURTHER DISCUSSION
ON THIS MEASURE, ANY FURTHER
DISCUSSION SEEING NONE, SENATOR
ASHBY, YOU MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU.
I URGE AN AYE VOTE. MEMBERS.
THIS IS ELIGIBLE FOR UNANIMOUS
ROLLCALL. ANY OBJECTION TO USING
A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL? SEEING
NONE. AYES 36, NOES ZERO. THE
MEASURE PASSES. WE'RE GOING TO
MOVE NEXT TO FILE ITEM 38 BY
SENATOR MIN. THIS IS SENATE BILL
1078. SECRETARY, PLEASE READ
SENATE BILL 1078 BY SENATOR MIN.
AN ACT RELATING TO LANGUAGE
ACCESS. SENATOR MIN, THE FLOOR
IS YOURS. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I'M PROUD TO RISE TO
PRESENT SB 1078, WHICH WOULD
CREATE AN OFFICE OF LANGUAGE
ACCESS WITHIN CALIFORNIA'S
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES AGENCY
, HHS, TO PROVIDE OVERSIGHT,
ACCOUNTABILITY AND COORDINATION
ACROSS CAL HHS, DEPARTMENT AND
OFFICES WHEN IT COMES TO
EXISTING MANDATES RELATED TO
LANGUAGE ACCESS. THIS OFFICE OF
LANGUAGE ACCESS WOULD HELP
ENSURE THAT INDIVIDUALS WITH
LIMITED ENGLISH PROFICIENCY
WOULD RECEIVE MEANINGFUL ACCESS
TO PROGRAMS AND SERVICES FOR
NEARLY 6.4 MILLION CALIFORNIANS
WHO HAVE LIMITED ENGLISH
PROFICIENCY, LANGUAGE BARRIERS
POSE A SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGE TO
ACCESSING QUALITY HEALTH CARE
COVERAGE. STUDIES SHOW THAT THE
ABSENCE OF CULTURALLY AND
LINGUISTICALLY APPROPRIATE CARE
RESULTS IN NEGATIVE AND
INEQUITABLE HEALTH OUTCOMES FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WITH LIMITED
ENGLISH PROFICIENCY, RESULTING
IN INCREASED CLINICAL COSTS.
LONGER HOSPITAL STAYS, AND
HOSPITAL READMISSIONS. THIS IS
BAD FOR THEIR HEALTH BY
PROVIDING IMPROVED LANGUAGE
ACCESS THROUGH INTERPRETATION
AND TRANSLATION SERVICES, SB
1078 WOULD CLOSE THE GAP FOR
CALIFORNIANS SEEKING A BROAD
SPECTRUM OF HEALTH SERVICES AND
ALLOW THE STATE TO MEET ITS
STATUTORILY REQUIRED LANGUAGE
REQUIREMENTS. RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU,
SENATOR MIN. DOES ANY MEMBER
WANT TO BE HEARD ON THIS BILL?
ANY MEMBER WANT TO BE HEARD?
SEEING NONE. THIS IS ELIGIBLE
FOR UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AYES 36. NOES ZERO.
THE MEASURE PASSES. NEXT UP,
MEMBERS, IS FILE ITEM 25 BY
SENATOR SMALLWOOD CUEVAS. THIS
IS SENATE BILL 1282. SECRETARY,
PLEASE READ SENATE BILL 1282 BY
SENATOR SMALLWOOD. CHÁVEZ AN ACT
RELATING TO CRIMES. SENATOR
SMALLWOOD CUEVAS THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT, AND GOOD AFTERNOON,
COLLEAGUES. I RISE TO PRESENT SB
1282. THIS IS A CRUCIAL PIECE OF
LEGISLATION TO EXPAND.
PROSECUTOR INITIATED DIVERSION
FOR THEFT OFFENSES AND TO EXPAND
A JUDGE'S ABILITY TO OFFER
DIVERSION AND LIMITED FELONY
OFFENSES. THIS BILL IS SIMPLY
EXPANSIVE AND ORGANIZED. ASIANS
WHO CURRENTLY OFFER DIVERSION
PROGRAMS WILL CONTINUE TO BE
ABLE TO DO SO. WE HAVE TAKEN
AMENDMENTS AND SO MANY OF YOU
HAVE BEEN IN CONVERSATIONS WITH
ME ON THIS BILL TODAY. WE SIMPLY
WANT TO CLARIFY THAT JUDGES WHO
WE TRUST TO LEVY PUNISHMENT AND
CONVICTION ALSO HAVE THE POWER
TO CHOOSE DIVERSION. THAT IS
SIMPLY WHAT THIS BILL IS SAYING.
AND THAT JUDGES SHOULD CONSIDER
BEFORE DECIDING TO OFFER
DIVERSION. WHEN A PERSON'S
UNDERLYING CIRCUMSTANCES REYES
THE CRIMINAL HISTORY, THE FACTS
OF THE CASE AT HAND, AND THE
POTENTIAL RISKS TO SAFETY. THE
BILL ALSO REQUIRES JUDGES TO
PRIORITIZE DIVERSION PROGRAMS
WITH A HISTORY OF WORKING WITH
PEOPLE WITH CRIMINAL OFFENSES.
AND I WANT TO BE CLEAR, I WANT
TO BE VERY CLEAR WITH EVERYONE
THAT THE BILL IN PRINT TODAY
ALREADY EXCLUDES ALL SEX
OFFENSES. I WANT TO REPEAT THAT
IT ALREADY EXCLUDES ALL ALL SEX
OFFENSES AND ALL VIOLENT
FELONIES. AND I WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT YOU ALL KNOW THAT I AM
FULLY COMMITTED, THAT IF THERE
IS ANY AMBIGUITY VÆ IN TERMS OF
HOW IT AFFECTS ALL SEX OFFENSES,
ALL VIOLENT FELONIES AND HUMAN
TRAFFICKING AND HUMAN
TRAFFICKING, THAT I AM COMMITTED
TO MAKING SURE THAT IF THERE IS
AMBIGUITY, I WILL MAKE SURE THAT
IT IS CORRECTED AND THAT WE HAVE
A LAW THAT REPRESENTS OUR VALUES
. I HAVE ALSO COMMITTED TO
MAKING AMENDMENTS TO CLARIFY
THAT THIS BILL WOULD NOT ALLOW
DIVERSION FOR THEFT. OVER
$100,000 FOR VEHICULAR
MANSLAUGHTER, FOR DRIVE BY
SHOOTINGS, FOR FELONIES THAT
RESULT IN GREAT BODILY INJURY
AND ANY FELONY THAT INVOLVES THE
USE OF A FIREARM. SB 1282 DOES
NOT REQUIRE THAT ANY ELIGIBLE
OFFENSE BE DIVERTED, AND IT
SIMPLY PROVIDES JUDGES WHO ARE
ELECTED AND SWORN OFFICIALS
ANOTHER TOOL TO ADVANCE JUSTICE.
AND WE CAN HOLD FOLKS
ACCOUNTABLE AND WE CAN ADVANCE
JUSTICE AT THE SAME TIME BY
PROVIDING PEOPLE WITH MENTAL
HEALTH TREATMENT AND SUBSTANCE
ABUSE TREATMENT AND OTHER
NECESSARY SERVICES TO ADDRESS
THE ROOT DRIVERS OF CRIME FOR
OUR SAFER COMMUNITIES. REYES
THAT WE ALL BELIEVE IN. AND LET
ME REPEAT THAT DIVERSION IS
NEVER MANDATORY. JUDGES HAVE
COMPLETE DISCRETION TO DENY
DIVERSION. IN ANY CASE, THEY
DON'T THINK IT'S APPROPRIATE OR
SAFE, REGARDLESS OF ELIGIBILITY.
SO IF A JUDGE BELIEVES A PERSON
POSES A DANGER TO THEMSELVES,
OTHERS OR OUR COMMUNITY, THEY DO
NOT HAVE TO OFFER THAT PERSON
THÀNH DIVERSION. ADDITIONALLY
DIVERSION PROGRAMS ARE NOT THE
SAME AS DISMISSALS. VERY
DIFFERENT. THEY ARE A COURT
ORDERED PROGRAM WHICH REQUIRE A
PERSON TO ADHERE TO SPECIFIED
CONDITIONS OR RISK THEIR CASE
GOING TO TRIAL. PEOPLE IN
DIVERSION PROGRAMS ARE MONITORED
BY SOCIAL WORKERS, BY JUDGES,
AND BY COMMUNITY BASED
ORGANIZATIONS. JUDGES CAN AND
FREQUENTLY DO REQUIRE PEOPLE ON
DIVERSION TO APPEAR BEFORE THE
COURT AND TO DISPLAY HèA THEIR
PROGRESS. JUDGES CAN TERMINATE
THE DIVERSION PROGRAM AT ANY
TIME AND CARRY ON WITH A
CRIMINAL TRIAL IF THEY ARE NOT
ADHERING TO THE CONDITIONS OF
THE PROGRAM THAT THEY HAVE BEEN
COMMITTED TO. THESE INSTANCES,
HOWEVER, ARE FEW AND FAR
BETWEEN, AND THIS IS EVIDENCE
DRIVEN WORK THAT WE'RE DOING
HERE. AND WITH DIVERSION
PROGRAMS HAVING A COMPLETION
RATE OF AS HIGH AS 95% IN L.A.
COUNTY AND VIRTUALLY NO
RECIDIVISM, CURRENTLY, PEOPLE
CONVICTED THROUGH THE
TRADITIONAL CRIMINAL JUSTICE
PROCESS HAVE ABOUT A 60%
RECIDIVISM RATE. THIS IS
COMPARED TO RE-ARREST. RE-ARREST
RATES AS LOW AS 4% FOR DIVERSION
PROGRAMS. EVEN WITH OUR EXISTING
DIVERSION PROGRAMS, WHICH ALLOWS
JUDGES TO OFFER DIVERSION TO ALL
MISDEMEANORS, THE DECISION TO
OFFER DIVERSION IS NOT ONE THAT
IS MADE LIGHTLY. AGAIN, WE TRUST
JUDGES EVERY DAY TO MAKE HARD
DECISIONS TO DETERMINE SENTENCES
PUTTING THEMSELVES AND THEIR
REPUTATIONS AT RISK. JUDGES KNOW
THAT IF THEY MAKE THE WRONG
DECISION, THEY WILL BE
CHALLENGED AND RECALLED. BUT
WHEN THEY DECIDE THAT DIVERSION
IS NECESSARY, THE OUTCOME SAVES
LIVES AND ULTIMATELY DOLLARS. WE
KNOW THAT CRIME IS DRIVEN IN OUR
COMMUNITY BY HOMELESSNESS,
POVERTY AND UNEMPLOYMENT,
PARTICULARLY WHEN WE START
THINKING ABOUT NONVIOLENT
PROPERTY CRIME. THESE UNDERLYING
CIRCUMSTANCES ONLY BECOME WORSE
WHEN SOMEONE IS PUT BEHIND BARS.
PEOPLE IN OUR STATE ARE LEAVING
THE PRISON AND JAIL SYSTEM IN
DEEPER POVERTY, LESS LIKELY TO
BE EMPLOYED, LESS LIKELY TO
RECEIVE A QUALITY EDUCATION,
LESS LIKELY TO QUALIFY FOR
HOUSING. THE OUTCOMES WHICH
ULTIMATELY MAKE THEM MORE LIKELY
TO REOFFEND AND MORE EXPOSED TO
VIOLENCE, MORE EXPOSED. SO
DIVERSION IS ANOTHER TOOL IN OUR
JUSTICE SYSTEM'S TOOLBOX TO GET
TO THE ROOT DRIVERS OF CRIME,
WHICH WE KNOW THROUGH EVIDENCE,
LOWERS RECIDIVISM RATES AND FOR
BETTER OUTCOMES. AND AS WE
CONSIDER WAYS TO ADDRESS CRIME
IN OUR COMMUNITIES, WE MUST
EXPAND SOLUTIONS, AND WE MUST
GET TO THE ROOT CAUSE OF THE
PROBLEM. AND WE MUST KNOW THAT
WE CAN HOLD FOLKS ACCOUNTABLE,
BUT WE CAN ALSO ENSURE JUSTICE
CGRTS WHEN APPROPRIATE. AND WITH
THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
SENATOR, ARE THERE MEMBERS WHO
WANT TO BE HEARD ON THIS ISSUE?
ANY MEMBERS LIKE TO BE HEARD ON
THIS ISSUE? SENATOR UMBERG AND
THEN SENATOR. ALVARADO. GIL
SENATOR UMBERG, THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT,
I'D LIKE TO ASK THE AUTHOR A FEW
QUESTIONS. WITH YOUR PERMISSION.
AND WITH THE CONSENT OF THE
AUTHOR. SENATOR SMALLWOOD, WOULD
YOU TAKE A QUESTION? YES.
SENATOR UMBERG, THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. SENATOR SMALL AS WE JUST
PASSED A SB 1414 BY OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM BAKERSFIELD, AND
AS I UNDERSTOOD YOU TO SAY THAT
THIS IS ALREADY THAT SHOULD IT
BECOME LAW AS I EXPECT IT TO IT,
ANYONE CONVICTED WOULD NOT BE
ELIGIBLE FOR DIVERSION. IS THAT
YOUR UNDERSTANDING AS WELL? YES
IT IS. AND SHOULD THERE BE ANY
AMBIGUITY, IT IS YOUR COMMITMENT
IN THE ASSEMBLY TO MAKE SURE
THAT AMBIGUITY IS RESOLVED.
ABSOLUTELY. THIS LAW ALREADY
EXCLUDES SEX OFFENSES, VIOLENT
CRIMES AND HUMAN TRAFFICKING AND
SHOULD THERE BE ANY AMBIGUITY?
AS I PROMISED AND SAID EARLIER,
I ABSOLUTELY WILL WORK TO ENSURE
THAT THAT CRIME WOULD BE
EXCLUDED FROM DIVERSION. ALL
RIGHT. AND ANOTHER QUESTION ALSO
OTHER QUESTIONS. OKAY. YOU'RE
OKAY. AND IF I TAKE ANOTHER
QUESTION. ALL RIGHT. THANK YOU.
LET ME JUST THE BILL IN PRINT
DOES NOT HAVE SEVERAL PROVISIONS
HERE. YOU AND I HAVE HAD SOME
QUALITY TIME THIS WEEK ON
VARIOUS ISSUES. YES. WE HAVE, SO
LET ME JUST BE CLEAR. WE'RE
MAKING LEGISLATIVE HISTORY HERE,
THAT SOMEONE WHO STEALS IN
ESSENCE, OVER $100,000 WOULD NOT
BE ELIGIBLE FOR DIVERSION. IS
THAT RIGHT? THAT IS CORRECT. AND
SOMEONE WHO PERSONALLY INFLICTS
GREAT BODILY INJURY ON ANY
PERSON, WOULD NOT BE ELIGIBLE
FOR DIVERSION. IS THAT RIGHT?
CORRECT. AND SOMEONE WHO
ASSAULTS WITH A DEADLY WEAPON,
OR A FIREARM? I SUPPOSE THAT'S
THE SAME. IN SOME RESPECTS. THEY
WOULD NOT BE ELIGIBLE. DIVERSION
IS THAT RIGHT? AND, A PERSON WHO
MALICIOUSLY AND WILLFULLY, IF
YOU COULD SUMMARIZE ALL THOSE, I
DON'T WANT TO HAVE THE BACK AND
FORTH. ALL RIGHT. I WILL
SUMMARIZE ALL YOUR QUESTIONS IF
YOU CAN. THANK YOU. AND THEN
GIVE HER THE CHANCE TO ANSWER.
BUT I THINK THAT'S A BETTER
PROCESS. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. SO A PERSON WHO
MALICIOUSLY AND WILLFULLY
DISCHARGED A WEAPON AT AN
INHABITED BUILDING VEHICLE,
AIRCRAFT, OTHER KINDS OF
DWELLINGS WOULD NOT BE ELIGIBLE
FOR DIVERSION. IS THAT RIGHT?
CORRECT. AND SOMEONE WHO ENGAGES
IN A DRIVE BY SHOOTING. PLEASE
ASK ALL YOUR QUESTIONS. AND THEN
WE'RE GOING TO GIVE THE AUTHOR A
CHANCE TO ANSWER ALL OF THEM.
OKAY, I STAND CORRECTED. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT, AS WELL AS
SOMEONE WHO'S, WHO IS CHARGED
WITH VEHICULAR MANSLAUGHTER.
PLEASE ASK, IS THAT. THAT IS
CORRECT. I JUST WANT TO SAY I
SAID THAT IN MY EARLIER
STATEMENT. ANSWERS TO ALL OF
YOUR QUESTIONS. IS THAT THE
FINAL QUESTION, SENATOR UMBERG?
I JUST WANT TO SAY I THAT IS
CORRECT. YES. TO ALL OF THOSE
ANSWERS. AND AS I SAID IN THE
BEGINNING, THAT THIS BILL WILL
EXCLUDE ALL SEX OFFENDER
OFFENSES, ALL VIOLENT FELONIES
AND HUMAN TRAFFICKING. THANK
YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. ON MY OWN
TIME. YES, SENATOR UMBERG, THANK
YOU VERY MUCH, THERE HAVE BEEN A
NUMBER OF BILLS CONCERNING
DIVERSION, CONCERNING
COLLABORATIVE COURTS AND
COLLABORATIVE COURTS THAT
PROCESS OR THE DIVERSION PROCESS
IS CLEARLY IS CLEARLY IN THE
LONG RUN, IN A MUCH BETTER
PROCESS FOR PUBLIC SAFETY. AS
OUR COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES
POINTS OUT, RECIDIVISM RATES ARE
PHENOMENALLY LOWER WHEN
DIVERSION PROGRAMS ARE CONDUCTED
CORRECTLY. WHEN THERE'S A BENCH
OFFICER AND THERE'S A PROCESS
THAT FOCUSES ON MAKING SURE THAT
THOSE WHO ARE IN THE PROGRAM
RIGOROUSLY COMPLY WITH THE
PROGRAM, THEN THEY'RE VERY
EFFECTIVE. THERE ARE OTHER BILLS
THAT ARE PENDING BEFORE US THAT
THAT ADDRESS SOME OF THOSE
ISSUES, SOME CRIMES, HOWEVER,
ARE NOT AMENABLE TO DIVERSION.
SOME CRIMES FOLKS SHOULD NEVER
BE DIVERTED. SOME FOLKS SHOULD
STAY. MANY INSTANCES FOR THE
REST OF THEIR LIVES IN PRISON.
THIS BILL DOES NOT TAKE AWAY THE
DISCRETION OF A JUDGE
IRRESPECTIVE, IRRESPECTIVE OF
THOSE CRIMES THAT ARE ELIGIBLE.
A JUDGE MAY STILL DECIDE THAT
FOR WHATEVER REASON, A PERSON IS
NOT ELIGIBLE. THE BILL, I THINK,
AS AMENDED, ALSO WILL INCLUDE A
PROVISION THAT SAYS A COURT MUST
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT ANY OTHER
PRIOR DIVERSIONS, I THINK THAT
THAT WE'VE TRIED TO CLARIFY THE
RECORD AS TO WHAT'S IN AND
WHAT'S OUT, THIS IS PROBABLY NOT
THE BEST WAY TO DO BUSINESS TO
DISCUSS AMENDMENTS, SORT OF ON
THE FLY HERE. BUT I KNOW THAT
SEVERAL OF US WILL BE VIGILANT
AS THE BILL MOVES THROUGH THE
ASSEMBLY TO MAKE SURE THAT THE
INTENT OF THOSE WHO ARE
SUPPORTING THE BILL, AT LEAST AT
LEAST AS TO ONE, WILL BE
FOLLOWED AND COMPLIED WITH. AND
WITH THAT, I'LL BE VOTING. AYE.
THANK YOU SIR. SENATOR ALVARADO
GILL. THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT.
I RISE TODAY IN OPPOSITION TO
SENATE BILL 1282, AS PROPOSED BY
MY COLLEAGUE FROM LOS ANGELES.
ALTHOUGH I UNDERSTAND THE
INTENT, THIS BILL GOES TOO FAR
BY EXPANDING THE MISDEMEANOR
STATUTE OF MOST FELONIES. AND
WOULD ALLOW JUDGES TO EXERCISE
THEIR DISCRETION IN GRANTING
DIVERSION TO PERPETRATORS
CHARGED WITH SOME VERY, VERY
SERIOUS CRIMES. THERE IS ALSO AN
ASSUMPTION HERE THAT WE ARE ONE
CALIFORNIA, WHERE CRIMES AND
RESOURCES IN URBAN SETTINGS ARE
EXACTLY THE SAME AS CRIMES
OCCURRED, AND RESOURCES IN RURAL
SETTINGS THAT IS SIMPLY JUST NOT
THE CASE. THIS BILL WOULD NOT
TAKE INTO ACCOUNT ANY
REQUIREMENTS FOR INTERESTS OF
JUSTICE OR PUBLIC SAFETY. IN MY
DISTRICT. THIS MEANS THAT THE
FATHER, CONVICTED OF FELONY
CHILD ABUSE OF HIS THREE YEAR
OLD IN MADERA COUNTY LAST YEAR,
WHICH RESULTED IN NUMEROUS
BRUISES AND CUTS ACROSS HIS FACE
AND BODY, WILL NOW BE ELIGIBLE
TO ENTER A DIVERSION PROGRAM.
YES, HE WAS PHYSICALLY ABUSED,
NOT SEXUALLY ABUSED, SO IT WOULD
NOT FALL WITHIN THE EXCEPTIONS
OF THIS LAW. ACROSS CALIFORNIA,
THIS MEANS THAT THE 26 YEAR OLD
COSTA MESA WOMAN, WHO PLEADED
GUILTY LAST MONTH TO BEING AN
ACCESSORY IN THE MURDER OF A SIX
YEAR OLD AIDEN LEOS, WHO WAS
SHOT TO DEATH IN HIS CAR SEAT
WHILE ON HIS WAY TO KINDERGARTEN
, WOULD NOW BE ELIGIBLE TO ENTER
A DIVERSION PROGRAM. ADRIN WILL
NEVER MAKE IT TO KINDERGARTEN,
LET ALONE TO WALK THE STAGE AS A
GRADUATE. THIS ALSO MEANS THAT
THE 18 YEAR OLD UNLICENSED
DRIVER, WHO WAS CHARGED WITH
VEHICULAR MANSLAUGHTER AFTER
KILLING A 15 YEAR OLD GIRL IN
APRIL DURING A HIGH SPEED CHASE
IN A STOLEN CAR IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA, WOULD NOW BE
ELIGIBLE TO ENTER A DIVERSION
PROGRAM. I DON'T STAND UP HERE
TO PUT MORE BLACK AND BROWN
PEOPLE BEHIND BARS. NO, THIS IS
REALLY ABOUT CONSEQUENCES FOR
ACTIONS. ACTIONS THAT ENDANGER
AND HARM OTHER PEOPLE REGARDLESS
OF YOUR CREED, COLOR, CLASS,
RACE, OR ETHNICITY. UNDER SENATE
BILL 1282, ADDITIONAL SERIOUS
CRIMES THAT WOULD BE ELIGIBLE
FOR DIVERSION INCLUDE AGGRAVATED
ASSAULT, AND WE KNOW THAT
AGGRAVATED ASSAULT IS USUALLY
ACCOMPANIED BY THE USE OF A
WEAPON, AND THERE IS AN INTENT
TO CAUSE SEVERE BODILY INJURY.
INJURY GANG CRIMES, INCLUDING
DISCHARGING A FIREARM AT A HOME
OR IN A VEHICLE, ASSAULT WITH A
DEADLY WEAPON. AND I MENTIONED
VEHICULAR MANSLAUGHTER AND I
CAN'T TALK ABOUT BAKER
MANSLAUGHTER WITHOUT
ACKNOWLEDGING OUR VERY OWN LILY
BUTLER, WHO TRAGICALLY LOST HER
LIFE AFTER A NEGLIGENT DRIVER
COLLIDED WITH HER HEAD ON ON A
STATE HIGHWAY. OR THE
GRANDMOTHER AND HER ONE YEAR OLD
GIRL GRANDBABY WHO NEVER MADE IT
HOME THAT DAY. I WANT TO
EMPHASIZE THE DIVERSION PROGRAMS
ARE ONLY 24 MONTHS, AND THAT IS
ON A GOOD DAY. THAT WE CAN GET
ALL OUR ADMINISTRATIVE WORK IN
ORDER AT THE END OF THOSE 24
MONTHS OR LESS, THE CHARGES
WOULD BE DISMISSED. THE ACCUSED
WOULD BE FREE TO POSSESS
FIREARMS AND WOULD NO LONGER BE
SUBJECT TO A REQUIREMENT TO PAY
RESTITUTION. SO LET'S GET THIS
RIGHT. YOU'RE IN A GANG. YOU
MAKE THE CHOICE TO PARTICIPATE
IN A DRIVE BY SHOOTING. THE
JUDGE HAD DISCRETION TO SEND YOU
TO DIVERSION. AND YOU REGAIN
YOUR RIGHT TO OWN A FIREARM. WE
WANT TO VOTE ON DIVERSION AS A
SENATE BODY THAT HAS PUT MORE
REGULATIONS ON LAWFUL GUN OWNERS
IN THIS STATE THAN ANY OTHER
STATE IN THE US. YET WE DON'T
WANT TO HOLD PEOPLE ACCOUNTABLE
FOR HOW THEY USE THOSE UNLAWFUL
FIREARMS TO INTENTIONALLY HURT,
AND SOMETIMES EVEN TAKE THE LIFE
OF OTHERS. LET'S NOT FORGET THE
VICTIMS OF THESE CRIMES WHO ARE
FORCED TO LIVE WITH THE TRAUMA
BROUGHT ON TO THEM BY THEIR
PERPETRATORS, THEIR CHILDREN,
AND THEIR FAMILY MEMBERS, THEIR
LOVED ONES. BECAUSE PERHAPS IN
DIVERSION, YOU HAVE 24 MONTHS TO
THINK ABOUT WHAT YOU DID. BUT AS
A VICTIM, YOU'RE NOT GRANTED
THAT SAME LUXURY. THIS BILL
WOULD NOT ONLY REINFORCE THAT
IT'S OKAY TO COMMIT CERTAIN
SERIOUS CRIMES, BECAUSE THE
CONSEQUENCES ARE MINOR. THE
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A MISDEMEANOR
AND A FELONY. YES, WE MUST
STRIVE FOR A JUSTICE SYSTEM
THAT'S FAIR AND REHABILITATIVE,
BUT SENATE BILL 1282 POSSESSES
SIGNIFICANT RISKS TO PUBLIC
SAFETY AND GOES TOO FAR. OUR
PRIORITY SHOULD BE TO PROTECT
OUR COMMUNITIES AND ENSURE THAT
JUSTICE IS SERVED FOR EVERY
VICTIM OF CRIME AND THOSE WHO
CHOOSE CRIME, EXCEPT THE
CONSEQUENCES FOR THEIR ACTIONS.
I URGE MY COLLEAGUES TO CONSIDER
THE POTENTIALLY SIGNIFICANT
RISKS OF THIS BILL, AND TO
PRIORITIZE MEASURES THAT TRULY
BALANCE REHABILITATION WITH
ACCOUNTABILITY. THESE ARE OUR
SCHOOLS. THESE ARE OUR CHURCHES,
OUR SYNAGOGUES. THESE ARE OUR
NEIGHBORHOODS, OUR COMMUNITY
CENTERS. SOMETIMES IT'S JUST THE
SAFETY OF TRAVELING WITH YOUR
CHILD IN YOUR CAR, TO THE
GROCERY STORE, OR EVEN TO SCHOOL
. THERE'S NO TELLING WHEN
SOMEONE WILL MAKE A CHOICE TO
ENGAGE IN A CRIMINAL ACT. AND
INSTEAD TAKE A LIFE. NOW, WE MAY
CALL IT INVOLUNTARY. WE MIGHT
CALL IT MANSLAUGHTER. WE CAN
HAVE ALL SORTS OF EXCUSES
BECAUSE THAT'S WHAT THIS IS.
THIS IS AN EXCUSE FOR BAD
BEHAVIOR. THIS IS AN EXCUSE TO
DIMINISH LIFE. AND THIS IS AN
EXCUSE TO SAY THAT WE'RE A BODY
THAT CARES ABOUT LAWFUL GUN
OWNERSHIP, BUT YET NOT PUTTING
THAT SAME CARE TO THE VICTIMS
WHOSE LIVES ARE TAKEN BECAUSE OF
UNLAWFUL GUN OWNERSHIP. I URGE A
NO ON THIS. THANK YOU. SENATOR.
SENATOR CORTESE. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
SB 1282, AND I'M JUST CONCERNED
TOO. WE ALL HAVE THE ANALYSIS IN
FRONT OF US. WE ALL HAVE IT HERE
, YOU KNOW, ON OUR LAPTOPS OR
WHATEVER YOU CALL THESE SCREENS.
WE JUST HEARD SENATOR UMBERG,
I'M SORRY, OUR COLLEAGUE FROM
ANAHEIM, GO THROUGH A VOIR DIRE
WITH THE AUTHOR, WHICH CLEARLY
INDICATED THAT THESE EXAMPLES
THAT ARE BEING USED ARE ACTUALLY
EXCLUDED FROM THE DIVERSION IN
THE BILL. I REFERENCED THE I
REFERENCED THE ANALYSIS BECAUSE
THE ANALYSIS WALKS THROUGH
THINGS LIKE ANY OFFENSE.
INVOLVING A WEAPON, ANY OFFENSE
INVOLVING DOMESTIC VIOLENCE,
STALKING AND SO FORTH. BUT THE
ADDITIONAL AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE
BEEN WALKED THROUGH, JUST AS FAR
AS I'M CONCERNED, BOTH AS AN
ATTORNEY AND AS A STATE SENATOR
AND SOMEBODY WHO WORKED ON THESE
ISSUES FOR A DOZEN STRAIGHT
YEARS AS A COUNTY SUPERVISOR.
THESE QUESTIONS HAVE BEEN ASKED
AND ANSWERED. THESE EXAMPLES ARE
NOT GOING TO BE EXACERBATED BY
THE BILL. AND IN FACT, HAVE BEEN
EXCLUDED BY THE LANGUAGE IN THE
BILL. AND I WANT TO THANK THE
CHAIR OF THE JUDICIARY COMMITTEE
FOR WORKING THROUGH THESE ISSUES
WITH THE AUTHOR, CLEARLY, THE
AMENDMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN
COMMITTED TO ARE GOING TO CAUSE
THE BILL TO COME BACK ON
CONCURRENCE. SO WE'LL HAVE THE
ABSOLUTE OPPORTUNITY WHEN IT
COMES BACK TO MAKE SURE THAT
THOSE CHANGES HAVE BEEN MADE IN
GOOD FAITH. AND ANYTHING ELSE
THAT'S WORKED OUT IN THE
ASSEMBLY, HAS BEEN HAS BEEN
HANDLED IN GOOD FAITH. I, FOR
ONE, HAVE NO QUESTION ABOUT THE
AUTHOR'S GOOD FAITH, STARTING
RIGHT NOW AND I FELT THE SAME
WAY YESTERDAY AND THE DAY
BEFORE. AND AS LONG AS I'VE BEEN
HERE, WORKING WITH THIS AUTHOR.
SO I WOULD ENCOURAGE AN AYE
VOTE, GIVE THE AUTHOR AN
OPPORTUNITY. VÆ TO MAKE GOOD ON
ALL THE HARD WORK THAT'S BEEN
DONE. AND TO COME BACK ONE MORE
TIME AND SHOW US, THAT TRULY,
THESE ISSUES HAVE BEEN ASKED AND
ANSWERED IN A WAY THAT THE
SENATE CAN SUPPORT. I URGE AN
AYE VOTE. THANK YOU, SENATOR
CORTEZ. ANY OTHER DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE HERE ON THE FLOOR?
MEMBERS, ANY OTHER MEMBER WANT
TO BE HEARD. SEEING NO
MICROPHONES UP, SENATOR CUEVAS
MAY CLOSE. THANK YOU SO MUCH,
MR. PRESIDENT. I WANT TO THANK
MY GOOD COLLEAGUE FROM SAN JOSE
AND MY GOOD COLLEAGUE FROM
ANAHEIM FOR THEIR, THOUGHTFUL
COMMENTS AND MY GOOD COLLEAGUE,
SENATOR ALVARADO GUILD, FOR HER,
HER HER WORDS. BUT ONE OF THE
THINGS SHE SAID WAS FACTS. AND
SO I WANT US TO FOCUS ON ON THE
FACTS, AND, AND I WANT TO REPEAT
THIS BECAUSE SHE WALKED THROUGH
GUN SECOND AMENDMENTS AND DRIVE
BYS AND A LOT OF THINGS IN HER
STATEMENTS THAT JUST WERE NOT
FACTUAL ABOUT THIS BILL. AND I
WANTED TO JUST CLARIFY THAT THIS
BILL IN PRINT TODAY ALREADY
EXCLUDES ALL SEX OFFENSES AND
ALL VIOLENT FELONIES AND HUMAN
TRAFFICKING. I HAVE ALSO
COMMITTED TO TAKING AMENDMENTS,
WORKING WITH THE CHAIR OF THE
JUDICIARY Kò TODAY ALL DAY TO
CLARIFY THAT THIS BILL WOULD NOT
ALLOW DIVERSION FOR THEFT OVER
$100,000, VEHICULAR MANSLAUGHTER
, DRIVE BY SHOOTINGS, AND A
FELONY THAT RESULTS IN GREAT
BODILY HARM AND A FELONY THAT
INVOLVES THE USE OF A FIREARM.
AND AS A SURVIVOR OF SEXUAL
ABUSE, MYSELF, I WANT TO SAY
THAT I TAKE SOME OF THE
ACCUSATIONS TO HEART, OR NOT,
SOME OF THE POINTS THAT WERE
MADE EARLIER TO HEART. BUT I
BELIEVE THAT WE CAN HOLD FOLKS
ACCOUNTABLE AND PROVIDE SOME
LEVEL OF JUSTICE AT THE SAME
TIME, I THINK WE CAN DO THIS IN
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA. I THINK
THERE IS A COMMITMENT AS MY GOOD
COLLEAGUE FROM SAN JOSE SAID, TO
MAKE SURE WE WATCH THIS BILL AS
IT GOES TO THE ASSEMBLY. AND
WHEN IT COMES BACK THAT IT'S
SOMETHING THAT REFLECTS OUR
VALUES, ALL OF OUR VALUES. AND
WITH THAT, I RESPECTFULLY ASK
FOR YOUR AYE VOTE. THANK YOU
SENATOR. ALL DEBATE HAVING
CEASED. SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. ALAN. BARBARA. RINGO.
NO ARCHULETA. ASHBY NO. ATKINS.
AYE BECKER. AYE. BLAKE. SPEER
AYE. BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO
CORTEZ. AYE. DALLI NO. DODD.
BARRASSO AYE. EGGMAN. AYE.
GLASER GONZALEZ. AYE. GROVE NO.
HURTADO. NO. JONES NO. LAIRD.
AYE. LEMON AYE. MCGUIRE. AYE.
MENGIBAR AYE. MEN. NO. NEWMAN
NGUYEN. NO. NILO. NO JOBO. NO.
PADILLA. AYE PORTANTINO. ROTH
RUBIO. SATO. NO SKINNER. AYE.
SMALL. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN
UMBERG. AYE. WAHAB AYE. WIENER.
AYE. WILK NO. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN. ARCHULETA
CABALLERO. NO DODD. GLASER
NEWMAN. PORTANTINO ROTH. RUBIO
STERN. SENATOR MOVES A CALL.
MEMBERS. WE'RE GOING TO GET OUR
PAPERWORK TOGETHER, AND THEN
WE'LL LIFT CALLS. SO STAY TUNED.
OKAY. MEMBERS. MEMBERS. WE HAVE
FOUR BILLS ON CALL THAT WILL, I
THINK, COMPLETE OUR BUSINESS
TONIGHT. I'D LIKE TO ASK
EVERYBODY TO RETURN THEIR SEATS
IF THEY WOULD. WE GET ALL THE
MEMBERS TO RETURN TO THEIR SEATS
. OKAY, THIS IS THE ORDER WE'RE
GOING TO GO THROUGH THESE. WE'RE
GOING TO START WITH FILE ITEM
28, 27, 2033 AND 25, FIRST UP IS
FILE ITEM 28. WE'RE JUST GOING
TO GO THROUGH THE ROLL ONCE,
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN ARCHULETA.
BECKER. BRADFORD DODD. GONZALEZ.
MCGUIRE. AYE MENGIBAR MEN. IDA
NÓ NEWMAN. NGUYEN OKOBO. ROTH
RUBIO. WAHAB AYE. WILK WILK.
AYE. CORTEZ. AYE. TO NOW, ON A
VOTE OF 18 TO 10, THE MEASURE
FAILS 17 TO 11. EXCUSE ME. 17 TO
11. THE MEASURE FAILS, THE
AUTHOR WOULD LIKE TO REQUEST
RECONSIDERATION. IS THERE ANY IS
THERE ANY ANY OBJECTION TO
RECONSIDERATION? ARE JESUS, I
WANT TO ASK IT ONE MORE TIME OR
I'LL GET IN TROUBLE. ANY
OBJECTION TO RECONSIDERATION?
HEARING NONE. AYES 36. NOES
ZERO. RECONSIDERATION WILL BE
GRANTED AND THE AUTHOR THANKS.
YOU. ALL RIGHT. NEXT UP, FILE
ITEM 27. THIS IS SB 1348 BY
SENATOR BRADFORD WITH THE
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN ARCHULETA.
BECKER. AYE JONES. MCGUIRE
NEWMAN. MCGUIRE. AYE NGUYEN.
OTOBOKE. SATO WILK. THE
SECRETARY. CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ONE LAST TIME. ALLEN
ARCHULETA. JONES NEWMAN. NGUYEN
OKOBO. SATO WILK. AYE ON A VOTE
OF 33 TO 0, THE MEASURE PASSES.
NEXT UP IS FILE ITEM 33 BY
SENATOR STERN. THIS IS SB 1283.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN ARCHULETA.
CORTEZ DODD MCGUIRE. CORTEZ AYE.
DODD MCGUIRE. AYE. NEWMAN.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS WIENER. AYE
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN.
ARCHULETA. DODD NEWMAN.
SMALLWOOD. CUEVAS.
ON A VOTE OF 35 TO 0, THE
MEASURE PASSES. LAST ONE UP IS
FILE ITEM 25. THIS IS SENATE
BILL 1282 BY SENATOR SMALLWOOD.
CUEVAS, SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN
ARCHULETA. DODD. GLASER. AYE,
AYE. NEWMAN. PORTANTINO ROTH.
RUBIO STERN. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS. ALLEN.
ARCHULETA. DODD NEWMAN.
PORTANTINO ROTH. RUBIO. STERN
SENATOR MOVES A CALL. MEMBERS.
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE A SHORT
RECESS. WE'D LIKE YOU TO ASK
THAT YOU ALL REMAIN HERE IN THE
CHAMBERS FOR JUST A SHORT, SHORT
PERIOD OF TIME. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR PATIENCE TODAY, AND THANKS
FOR DOING ALL THE GREAT WORK
TODAY. SO STAY TUNED. WE'RE IN
RECESS.
WE'RE ALMOST THERE. ASK ALL THE
MEMBERS TO COME BACK TO THEIR
DESKS.
OKAY. THE SENATE IS BACK IN
SESSION. WE HAVE ONE MORE ITEM
ON CALL. WE'LL CALL FOR THAT
ONE. THIS IS FILE ITEM 25, SB
1282 BY SENATOR SMALLWOOD CUEVAS
WITH THE SECRETARY. PLEASE OPEN
THE ROLL CALL. ABSENT. ABSENT.
MEMBERS ALLEN ARCHULETA, DODD
NEWMAN. PORTANTINO ROTH. RUBIO
STERN. WITH THE WITH THE
SECRETARY. PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS ONE MORE TIME. Þ
ARCHULETA. DODD NEWMAN.
PORTANTINO ROTH. RUBIO STERN.
STERN. AYE. STATED WITH THE
BEFORE A MOMENT WITH THE
BLAKESBERG I TO NÓ LAKE. SPEER.
I TO NO ANYBODY ELSE? ANYBODY
ELSE? EGGMAN ITEM NO. MENGIBAR I
DON'T KNOW ANY OTHER ANY OTHER
VOTE CHANGES BEFORE WE CLOSE THE
ROLL. ALL RIGHT. SEEING NONE
EYES 17. NO, 16. THE MEASURE
FAILS AT THE REQUEST OF THE
AUTHOR. THE AUTHORS REQUEST FOR
RECONSIDERATION. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. AYES 36. NOES ZERO.
EXCUSE ME. EYES 35. NO, ZERO FOR
RECONSIDERATION.
AND IF THERE IS NO OTHER
BUSINESS, SENATOR MCGUIRE, THE
DESK IS CLEAR. ALL RIGHT. THANK
YOU SO MUCH, MR. PRESIDENT.
MEMBERS THANK YOU. CAME IN LATE
TODAY BECAUSE OF YOUR FANTASTIC
WORK, TOTAL BILLS COMPLETED
TODAY, 86, WHICH INCLUDES THE
CONSENT CALENDAR. WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE SOME BRIEF THANK YOUS
TOMORROW AND A BIT OF A LIGHTER
LOAD. WE'LL HAVE A CONSENT
CALENDAR TOMORROW AND 1 OR 2
ADDITIONAL BILLS TOMORROW. WE
ARE GRATEFUL FOR ALL OF THE
INCREDIBLE WORK. THANK YOU FOR
YOUR COMMITMENT, MR. PRESIDENT.
WE ARE. OUR NEXT SESSION IS
GOING TO BE FRIDAY, MAY 24TH AT
9 A.M. THE SENATE IS ADJOURNED.
WE WILL RECONVENE FRIDAY, MAY
24TH, 2024 AT 9 A.M. WE ARE.